Hey,
hey, hey.
kiss me.
Hey.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Join me
and
I might shoot you in your face.
Bombs and
do the trick.
What do we need here?
Do you ever want to catch
a little
faster?
Try something right now. I guess people
need
so much better.
So much fun.
Let that rosection
blow up the
faster. Just a little bit of energy. I
want to try something better now. I get
some people
and see what
it's
not
Heat. Heat.
Regional qualifier Sydney. My name is
Julian Pacar and I'm very very pleased
to welcome you all to my beautiful home
city. I'm joined by Steph Panic. This is
going to be an absolutely incredible
weekend.
>> I'm so excited. There is such an energy.
I'm really really thrilled to see so
many people turn out in Sydney. It's
going to be great.
>> Yeah, they literally just paired the
first round of the main event right
before we went live. They were
absolutely slamming it as uh as they
went through over the loudspeaker. And
already things are quite hectic here in
the hall as you can see.
>> Absolutely. There is so much happening.
Everybody's moving around. I I there's
just too much.
>> Yeah. So, the new set, new era for
Riffan Unleashed has finally been well
unleashed upon the world. 40 legends now
in the game. Only three sets in. That's
an unbelievable number of decks to try
and contend with.
>> Incredible amounts to try and wrap your
head around, prepare against. I mean, I
don't envy it. Le let's be real. I I I'm
so impressed by everybody who has
managed to just brush up on their
knowledge so quickly and be ready for
this weekend.
>> Oh, let's take a look at what we have
coming up this weekend cuz there's a lot
for us to take you through. We have
quite a few players registered for this
event. It's about 1,600 or so, but how
we got here is kind of a fun one. This
is a 2026 road map. We started at the
very end of last year in 2025 in Houston
crowning a champion there for Origins.
Spirit Forge came out then. Bolognia was
then the first event after that for that
event. Las Vegas we saw quite a few
Dravens in the USA. And then moving on
we've kind of had a few more events. Lil
hosted near the end of Spirit Forge
Atlanta quite recently a few weeks ago
crowning a champion there as well on a
fun new track in Annie kind of mirroring
Houston. Then unleash came out on May
8th and you may notice Sydney May 15th
to 17th. Those two dates are quite close
together.
>> Just a little bit. Yeah, no pressure.
>> And
>> then Vancouver also coming up for the
rest of Unleashed season alongside Utre
and Hartford. And then don't worry,
there's even more road mapap to be had.
There is so much roofbound to be played.
Vendetta finally aligning the releases
for China and English, which is an
incredible feat for the Riftbound team.
And then Barcelona is going to kick off
that season in August before Singapore.
And then Radiance and then LA is going
to kick off the year in September. So
that's quite a lot of Riftbound.
>> Just enough, I think.
>> Just enough.
>> I think I could be okay with one more.
One one or two more of it. So yeah,
squeeze them in. Why not?
>> We'll have a look at what we're doing
this particular weekend, though. The
schedule is uh pretty packed, I have to
say. If you've never been to a car game
tournament before, never watched one, uh
I guess strap in cuz there's quite a lot
for you to witness. Saturday, which is
today, right now at 10:00 a.m.
Australian Eastern Standard Time, which
if you're watching, is just about right
now. 5:00 p.m. Pacific if you're back
home there in LA. Uh eight rounds of
Swiss today is what we're going to have.
And then on Sunday, on Championship
Sunday, excuse me, five more rounds of
Swiss. That's 13 total. And then a top
eight. So eight rounds each day
effectively. But the last three rounds
of the weekend maybe a little bit more
special
>> just a little. I mean every every match
is special in its own right.
>> Very true.
>> You know
>> and of course the format is constructed
which has been the uh the format for
Riftbound since its inception. Day one
as we said Swiss play as six you need
six wins to advance. So X and two of
those eight Swiss rounds and then our
five rounds of Swiss trying to honestly
hold on to a pretty good record to make
top eight. The size of this event I
think is around 1,600 players were
registered. So, your record needs to be
quite good to be one of those eight
players left.
>> It's honestly a really impressive
turnout. So, good luck to them.
>> All right, we'll have a look at the
prize pool, of course, cuz it's not just
uh the glory, the best of the things
that people are playing for. There's
actually quite a lot of prizing on
offer. So, day two prizing if you make
top 128. And you may have remembered
there's a few thousand people in the
room. So, that's still pretty special.
You get this pretty sweet Vex playmat
featuring her alt art. Top eight though,
we've changed the promo. It is now Poppy
Defender of Deique alt art. Both promo
and playmat. And then a champion prize.
No longer just a blade of the ruin king.
It is a yortle with a hammer that you'll
get to win.
>> And a cute one at that.
>> Very cute one. There's a lot of stuff
here. Some prize prize prize war
tickets. Uh decent chunk of money chunk
of change for flying on over here and uh
doing battle. But pretty sweet to see
Unleashed have a new bit of promo kind
of pushing different things as the
seasons roll on. But of course, if you
want to play some Rift, whether it's
competitively or maybe more casual, you
should do one of these two things. You
just either scan the QR code on your
screen, get yourself to a Nexus Knight
and prepare for your next battle, or if
maybe you need something in between an
RQ and your Nexus Knight, Summoner
Skirmish, a really great way to not only
kind of get your appetite wet in terms
of competitive rift bound, but also
maybe get a buy, which uh turns out to
be pretty critical in a tournament
that's 16 rounds long.
>> Yeah,
>> we may know that one player particularly
well known within the scene maybe
doesn't have a buy.
>> Very true, which is unexpected, I will
say, but we'll see what happens. Yes, if
anyone knows prismaticism allegedly does
not have a buy. Didn't realize that he'd
run out. Won a lot of skirmishes, but
apparently didn't win enough.
>> Well, I mean, he didn't have a lot of
time in between Atlanta and now and
unleashed. So, we'll see.
>> That's true. Not a whole lot of testing
time, but you know, we're here at the
cast desk, both here outside the
interview area and on the desk itself.
Do like to uh I don't know, use our
scrying orbs, if you will, our little
plants, and see what happens. Let's have
a look at our predictions cuz I have to
have a feeling that we may not get
everything right. But we tried to
predict the winning legend and champion.
Explain yourself.
>> Okay, look, Logan and I are both in
agreement here. I think Diana is a
really strong pick. She's been really,
really popular since Unleashed. And I
think when piloted well, she can wrap
things up really quickly. So, I'm
feeling reasonably confident.
>> Well, I'm curious to hear what Profess
say about Annie cuz that does seem like
a decent pick. I guess I suppose I will
explain myself for Leblanc. I think this
is uh I'm the law of large numbers in
this pick. I think Leblanc will be one
of the most, if not the most represented
deck in this field. I obviously think
the yellow chosen champion is where you
want to be. Although I think everywhere
at Once is also a decent pick. So, I'm
just going this time. You know what? I
am going to pick the most represented
deck to actually convert. That usually
doesn't happen. But I think even though
there's a lot of players probably on
this deck, I think skilled pilots are
very good and I know there's probably a
few lurking out in the field. So, I'm
hoping that the very big number converts
domains that have never done well at
Rift Archus. We'll see. I look, as I
said, I'm feeling pretty confident on my
pick, but you never know what's going to
happen.
>> All right. Well, what I love even more
than yapping about Ripbound is hearing
other people yap about games of Rift.
That's what we've got coming up. Rafound
Rice and Logan, take it away.
>> Thank you so much, Pastry and Steph.
Now, I think I have to explain my
prediction as well. Now, I did pick
Annie, but I didn't hear about how
Prismatic didn't have that buy in first
round. So, now I'm a little bit
sweating, but I still believe in the
Annie. We saw a miracle in my opinion of
seeing Annie do so well. I mean
throughout all of the regional
qualifiers so far. But of course, let's
not yap too much about Annie. Let's
start talking about what we are here
for. We are here for round one of the
regional qualifier. Sydney,
>> I'm very very excited for this one as
well. Ricey and as you were saying,
Prismat not having that buy and
obviously I predicted Diana too, but the
rest of the regional qualifiers here in
Sydney is what we're here for. And we
have some exciting matchups to talk
about for all of you today. We have the
best of the best in the world. Former RQ
winners and aspiring RQ winners amongst
the crowds. And I don't even know where
to start with this. We have so many new
legends, new battlefields to accompany
those legends. And do you have any
favorites so far? Well, I mean, I I
picked Annie mostly because I believe in
the Prismat uh legacy he's he's trying
to build, of course, but I do think
there's been so many uh Diana's as well,
like you and uh Steph did choose Diana
as your prediction, and I was thinking
maybe I'll pick it too, but I decided,
you know what, let's go uh with one of
the stronger pilots, of course, Prismat
Annie. But I think there were so many
other legends that I'm really excited to
see as well. Uh, for example, I want to
see Ireelia in this new meta.
>> Yeah. I also want to see um Master Y. We
saw a lot in the pre-qualifiers, so I
want to see how he ends up going. Uh, as
well as, of course, Leblanc. You know,
Leblanc's like kind of the talk of the
town at the moment.
>> Yeah, Leblanc is definitely one to keep
eyes on. Obviously Allan also going on
Diana shows a lot of strength. Those are
very good colors. We've got the mind and
the chaos combined. uh dare go into that
sort of control style. But as you say,
Leblanc, she'll be well represented.
She's already seeing seen, but we have
those new mechanics as well. We also
have XP, which is favored into the Yi,
Ka'zix, and Poppy. We have ambush, so we
can expect to see Rengar popping that
one out. Those thrill of the hunts will
be very exciting to see what they can do
with that too, Naomi, as we do get ready
to go to our game soon.
>> Yes, of course. I'm very excited to see
what happens with that game. I could
hear them talking about it over the
speaker. But there's also another thing,
another legend or maybe play style that
is the talk of the town as well. Now,
Aurora, how do you feel about Aurora,
Logan?
>> Aurora has definitely been popping up in
the sort of social media sphere, but
also a lot of pro players have been
commentating around the play style of
Aurora. We have arguably the single best
Aurora player in the world here in
Sydney. Ali El Drazzi who also went 5
and0 in the pre-regional qualifier. So a
really good representation. But what I'm
hearing about Ali's Aurora deck is
fantastic. He's leaning a little more
toward that sort of mid-range style so
that if you don't hit those Auroras or
they get countered, which is quite easy
with a lot of gear removal, you can
still play the game. You still have outs
and options to win there, Naomi. Yeah, I
think there are still quite a few
techniques as you were saying to counter
these Aurora. And as you mentioned, I
definitely want to see how Alli does
with this Aurora deck. As you said, he's
one of the best, if not I mean, you're
saying arguably the best Aurora player
in the world. So, we're privileged to
have all of these amazing international
stars here in Sydney, and they're going
to be competing here to see if they can
get the uh become the champion of the
regional qualifier, Sydney. Yeah, I mean
they want to join the ranks of Prismat
and Allan and uh Dwali who's here as
well as regional qualifier winners. They
want to secure that top 64 position at
absolute minimum so that they know they
have that ticket and that competitor
ticket as well up to the regionals when
they do occur. So there is a lot on the
line. Even making top 64 is fantastic.
And as we did cover off, there is that
new prizing structure as well. So even
rewarded for being top 128 which you do
love to see, right? because you're
competing, you're grinding, you're
spending two whole days here fighting
against the best players we have and you
would like to be rewarded for that. And
that's exactly what they've done here.
They are rewarding the best players here
at the regional qualifiers in Sydney as
we do get ready for that main event. We
can we can kind of hear in the
background.
>> It's it's making me so excited.
>> You're part of the crowd. You can hear
it all. I absolutely do love it.
>> Yeah. I think um as the announcer was
saying, round one is about to begin. I
heard like a huge cheer and it really is
bringing a wonderful atmosphere into
this uh event of you know the regional
qualifier Sydney which of course I mean
we all know it it is the first ever
regional qualifier in the southern
hemisphere and in this side of the
world. It's it's really exciting to to
see it here locally as well.
>> Yeah. And I think that's what really
matters, right, is having that local
investment, that local representation
because there is such an amazing
community down here in Australia for
Riftbound where they've exploded and
there's thousands and thousands upon us.
And as we were talking about in that
sort of pre-show there, we've got the
Nexus Knights, which is where that
community kicks off. It really starts to
build and develop. And then you take
that up into those summoner skirmishes
where you win those buys before you come
to these regional qualifiers. So, so
many people have invested so much time,
energy, and effort into becoming experts
in their favorite decks. We have some
one tricks here who will be looking to
make a fantastic showing here at the
regionals and just show exactly what
we've got. I know we've got a few best
of set competitors, some best of Garen
competitors. Always a fun one, that one.
Yeah, lots of uh as you said specialists
in their legends and as you mentioned
Nexus Knights is such a wonderful time
to develop those specialties in those
legends and as well as join the
community. I think personally Nexus
Knights feels like a little home ground.
It's like your home turf and as I' I've
seen so many of my um Nexus Knight
buddies walking around and playing in
the competition and I personally will be
looking out for them and seeing how they
go. I've got my uh phone here to see the
score and double check on all of my
friends because that's what I think is
really special about Riftbound. It's
such a good community.
>> It's it's a lot of why I'm so invested
as well, right? Even even my wife, she's
out there on the show floor. She's at
the main event. She's uh she's playing
Aurora, you know.
>> Oh, watch out.
>> I know. But like it's part of that
investment. It's part of that value that
we play. You see your friends. I see my
friends. You know, my wife's out there
and and the community and the judges as
well. So many of them there. You find
them at your nexus nights. you find them
at your summoner skirmishes and I think
that kind of tangible connected to the
humans is what makes it special. But
Ricey, it looks like we're getting ready
to get into our first matchup here.
We've got uh Oh, the new playmats. They
look nice and clean.
>> They do look really nice and clean. So,
this of course Logan is round one. That
does mean that these players did not get
their buy at the summer summoner
skirmishes, but I wouldn't count them
out just yet. Of course, these people
are, as you said, specializing in their
craft, specializing in their legends.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We do see that they
are getting ready for their games.
They're just getting those instructions
from the judges. So, this is something
that we can expect to see throughout
where judges kind of give them a pregame
rundown. They're like, "This is what
we're expecting. This is how the games
will go. This is what will happen
otherwise, etc. Make sure all the deck
lists are up to speed, up to scratch."
And um this, as you say, will be the
round one game. They haven't secured
those wins at those summoner skirmishes.
So, they have an uphill battle in front
of them here, Ricey. They're going to
need to not only win uh, you know, seven
on day one, but they need to win that
eighth as well to really make sure they
get through to that day two. But I will
be very interested to see what kind of
legends we're going to be seeing here in
this game one matchup. And here it is.
Ah, Diana, after my own heart, also the
overnumbered art. But let's take a look
at some of these cards.
>> Well, obviously we know Diana is minding
Chaos and we know how strong Chaos is,
especially these new cards such as uh
Vex Apathetic is there. Um, and Starross
as well. But what else do you feel about
this deck?
>> Yeah, look, I absolutely expected
Starcross and Vex Apathetic to be there.
Vex Apathetic is a very, very strong
hold card. It also prevents a lot of
early aggro kind of matchups. So
something like Lilia, it's really useful
into abandon is a new piece of tech as
well. It's a good counter. However, it
goes back to hand so your opponent can
play it again, but the value comes from
that sort of predict mechanic that we've
got there. But additionally, I do like
to see the top end. They've got a plan
to close this one out. We've got the
moonfall where you can win the combats
on those battlefields and that classic
that thousand tail watcher, but Ricey,
they've teched into anti- Aurora. They
have that acceptable losses
>> and I wonder what they have in their
sideboard.
>> Yeah, we don't show the sideboard here
on day one. Uh that is I want to say the
compromise we made with the players so
that we don't show their full tech but
we can still talk about their deck list.
We can see what maybe we can predict
happening into this game. I mean Diana
does a lot of predictions so maybe it's
good that we can do predictions too.
>> And I am loving the new battlefield that
we're seeing here as well. The abandoned
hall. do that one represented in sort of
the spell slinger combat focus decks
here. So I would imagine that in a rally
but it's great to see it here in Scorn
of the Moon Diana that new legend from
Unleashed. But Tide Turner, Tide Turner
is always a nice kind of effect that you
want to have. You can switch units
around and uh suddenly the combat is a
lot more different than your opponent
expected. I do note they don't have the
Diana no longer human which is that
Raven Bloom student amplified does have
that ambush does have that plus two
might per spell instead of the one
>> but I just think there are some better
options out there which is why we see
the Raven Bloom and not the no longer
human.
>> M yeah of course the chosen champion
there is Lunari which is of course as I
was mentioning earlier the predict
ability is very strong with Diana. It
helps make the uh help the pilot choose
and understand the the flow. And I'm
trying to figure out my words here. I'm
trying to predict my own words. But
basically, this means Joshua will be
able to look ahead a little bit, maybe
change the cards around so that they can
have the most optimal board.
>> Yeah, that filtering is something very,
very strong here. I have seen some lists
running Luna Boon as well, which gives
that discard one draw, too. So, it is
interesting that that one's not in this
main board, but it could potentially be
in that side. As we said, that's hidden
tech for now. But Huay Huay is a
superstar.
>> We have to talk about Hay.
>> Absolutely.
>> He's one of the most versatile units in
the entire game. I mean, you can choose
three different um uh options,
activities, abilities in Huay, which is
absolutely amazing. It means that they
can, as I said, be very versatile with
their play.
>> Yeah, that way can jump from five to
eight might. It can draw you the card.
It can ready two runes. You've just got
options galore here. And uh I'm excited
to see what this Diana deck can do
because this will be the first time
we've seen it. And like we've said, this
is the first unleashed regional
qualifier here. These gamers over the
next two days, they will be all eyes on.
They're going to be helping to define
the meta moving forward here.
>> Yeah, one of our newer legends to come
out. So, it's really good to see. I
mean, first day is great to see how
Diana is going to be playing here. I'm
also very curious to see who Diana is
going to be versing and I think we'll be
seeing that soon. Looks like a
battlefield has been chosen I believe by
Joshua on the left but I'll be corrected
I'm sure later by producers. Um and I
mean we're nearly underway.
>> Yeah, nearly. But shout out to the
camera team. Look at this work. I love
the panoramic view we're getting here.
Both players, they are sat. They are
ready. They've got their headsets on.
Our judges look ready here as well. So
very, very exciting. We've got those
card shuffles now. Obviously in these
high OPL events as well, we do need to
make sure that we're running brand
spanking new outer sleeves and you got
to choose either iners and outers or
just those outers for that competitive
integrity and you do not want to risk
any marking either. So it is good to see
that these guys they've brought their
shiny new sleeves. We've got the deck
cuts happening. This game is imminently
happening here. And um yeah, we've got
those indicators towards the
battlefields. The judge appears ready
and I'm excited for the first ever game
of unleashed at a regional qualifier.
>> First game down under. Very excited to
see how Joshua complete uh shows us how
his Diana Tech is going to go. Of
course, I'm very excited to see how uh
the as you said the switcheroo was
switcheroo
>> the tide turners turners. Sorry. Sorry.
Tie around. Yeah, that's what I meant.
Tie turners. We got you know last rides.
got Huay. We got so many really exciting
tech here in of course this chaos mind
domains.
>> We did just see the roll off occur
there. The battlefields, they have been
revealed. A little bit of a pregame
banter there. We've drawn the four off
the top. So, it'll be interesting to see
what we decide to mull here as they're
considering their options. Sometimes the
first four cards are arguably the most
important. It's how you start the game.
Whether you have those turn one plays or
you're slower and you're in those turn
twos as we see it is Diana Scorn of the
Moon into Pike Blood Harbor. It's a
double unleashed legend match up here.
And that treasure hunter has hit the
base of closed on Sunday.
>> Closed on Sunday. I hope he's not closed
tomorrow. Hope he does try and make day
two because that's a bit of a name that
I would uh probably not want to have in
this event. You definitely want to make
that championship Sunday. First turn has
occurred. Of course, they brought out
their one, two, even a three might unit.
Actually, that Diana's already in play.
>> Yeah, Diana Lunar and this is the power
of Diana Lunari. She's that three energy
unit that can be played on that first
turn if you don't hit that allimportant
drop. But we do see closed on Sunday
moving to conquer the battlefield first.
So he's moved in that treasure hunter
and it doesn't appear that there is any
response coming out of the of Joshua
right now. I think they're deliberating
because a piece of tech that we did see
in Jua's deck here is Gust. So Gust is
really good at messing with early game
tempo plans and it looks like we're now
over to Joshua. I do believe that closed
on Sunday did conquer that battlefield
unless we're still deliberating. Ooh,
and we did get a peak there. We do see
Joshua does have that thousand tail
watcher. So, if we can get to that late
game, he definitely has a strong closer.
>> Yeah, I mean, as you mentioned earlier,
you were keeping your eye out on that
Thousand Tower Watcher, which actually
is such it's a card that's been so
strong throughout all of the uh the
stats being released, and it's still in
play here. As you said, it's a strong
closer. And I mean, maybe Joshua is very
keen to try and make that thousand tail
watcher work later on, but at the
moment, I believe it's uh still Joshua's
turn. He's thinking about what he wants
to play here. Obviously, he can't play
Thousand Tailed Watcher right now, but
he's got quite a few options here. I
think he's I saw a ghast potentially as
well.
>> Yeah, there was also a there was a
stupifier, a ghast, and a thousand tail
in Jashua. So, he definitely has a lot
of tools to be able to answer this sort
of early game pressure that we've
already started to see from Closed on
Sunday. Obviously, being able to get
onto that battlefield nice and early on
that Ripper's Bay, which is that brand
new unleash battlefield that really
helps you. It rewards you for actually
bouncing off that battlefield.
>> So, it is good to see it's that when a
unit here is returned to a player's
hand, that player may pay one energy to
channel one rune exhausted. So, it also
serves as ramp if you can bounce off of
that one.
>> Yeah, I burst a pike in my Nexus Knight
and I have a bit of trauma from that
because the Bewitching Spirits is so
strong, especially in the early game. I
ended up with literally zero cards and I
had to top deck every single turn.
Somehow though, I think I managed to
still go 1-1. So, it kind of worked out.
But in this matchup, I'm very excited to
see what Close on Sunday's tech is going
to be. How is he going to be utilizing
that rippers bay, the pike's legend, and
all the other onplay effects?
>> Absolutely. Obviously Pike being in fury
and chaos does have that aggression from
the fury and that control from the chaos
and is able to kind of loop these
bewitching spirits if he has that in the
deck. You you can use your pack of
wonders as well to help out with that.
Uh, Starcross, a potential card that
could be with closed on Sunday, which is
an offensive and defensive card as we do
see that traveling merchant picked up
for Joshua here too. And one thing that
I always love seeing is the absolute
blinged out decks here. But Diana Lari
goes in on that abandoned hall right
that very powerful new battlefield from
>> Gus gets used by a close on Sunday to
try and not let Diana stay on abandoned
hull but instead he's going to just
stupify the treasure hunter just maybe
to get that extra draw card because
drawing cards especially on Diana is
very strong.
>> Yeah, card draw wins games and that is
mostly what stupify is used for these
days. It's such a phenomenal one drop.
You just go, "Yep, thank you. Minus one
might and I will draw that card."
Typically, card draw is costed at nearly
two energy, about 1.5. And Vexathetic
already.
>> Oh no, that Vex apathetic is so so
strong. Every unit you play is stunned
on entry and also cannot move as well.
So, accelerated units, they don't do
anything. Now, Pike isn't the worst
matchup. Like, as you mentioned earlier,
Lilia is really bad into this. So I'm
curious to see how closed on Sunday is
going to approach now with Rex Apathetic
on the board.
>> Yeah, and we do get a little bit of a
look see into closed on Sunday's hand.
And he does have that bewitching spirit
that we were talking about. So he
doubtlessly wants to kind of get that
out and start looping it at that three
energy. It is something you can do at
turn two. And he is six runes up right
now. They are both at one conquer point
a piece. So if clothes on Sunday is able
to get that bewitching spirit out and
start that loop. There it is.
>> What a good prediction coming through.
Beijing spirit forcing Joshua now to
discard one card from hand. And they're
going to choose to discard.
>> I can't read.
>> That's Traveling Merchant.
>> Yes, of course. Traveling Merchant,
which as you travel, you gain a gold
coin. Um, so that I I am not surprised
that they did get rid of Traveling
Merchant instead of one of the other
cards, which are pretty strong in their
hands as we saw before. Obviously, the
uh Tower Watcher and everything else.
Yeah, Traveling Merchant, you move and
you discard one, then draw one. So, not
a bad discard coming out of Jashua
there. The thing with Bewitching Spirit,
right, is yes, it's good for card
discard, right? You force your opponent
to reduce their hand size, but they get
to pick the card that they're going to
discard. And right now, I'm pretty sure
Joshua's quite happy with what he has
just discarded as we are trying to get
that updated B. And there's one of those
new unleashed alt art mind runes as
well. The thing I really love about this
set is it's really focused on the
jungle. So, a lot of jungle objectives.
We've got the Gromps, we've got the
pits, we've got the towers as well if
you are a League of Legends fan. And
Joshua has opted to move off of the
abandoned hall here. I see
>> abandoned hole, which is such a strong
battlefield for Diana. As as you
mentioned earlier, when you use a spell
on abandoned hole and target one of your
units, you can increase that might by
one. And I mean, with Diana's other
abilities, it can get quite quite
strong. Um it is of course a chaos and
mind deck. So a lot of things happen.
Now it's closed on Sunday's turn. He is
awakening, channeling and going to be
drawing and it's up to him. The bowl is
in his court.
>> Yeah. Right now obviously we've gone
back to the play for closed on Sunday.
He does have that pike and we get some
look at the tech there. And one card
that I do want to point out is Fizz.
Fizz is a phenomenally high value unit
that is in those chaos colors. As we do
see some excellent camera panning here.
We we're trying to get that tech on
Jashu as well. But Fizz is able to recur
from the graveyard. So that Gus that's
currently sitting in the trash for
closed on Sunday, he will be able to get
that back out if he wants. But the
timing is what will matter.
>> The timing of course will matter. He has
gone and conquered. And it looks like
Joshua is thinking how can I respond to
this? Is he okay with this? Is he able
to get that conquer point? Um, looks
like it will in fact be able to get it
and will be in fact reinforcing that
Ripper's Bay reaching spirit is for
walking in. But of course that legend
tap using the rune to bring the reaching
spirit back in and that tech that Pike
is so well known for. Be riching spirit
going down and forcing you to discard
another hand in of course another play.
>> Yeah, we do love to see the blood ripper
there returning it to hand and as you
called straight back out going to force
another discard. So Joshua is in a race
against the clock here because closed on
Sunday has actually started to develop
this loop. He's going to be able to do
this every single turn and it's going to
put a lot of pressure on Joshua.
>> Starross was the one that was discarded
and we were talking about this at the
beginning of the game here. Starrust is
a very strong card in Chaos. So now
Joshua is forced not to be able to use
it. But also in the same way if you push
back the return to hand the wrong card
for close on Sunday, he's just going to
play it again. He's Pike.
>> Yeah, we did see the Starfall go in
there. But we also saw the moonfall,
that new signature spell from Diana go
into the trash there. So, I really think
that that was what was uh discarded
there with that bewitching spirit.
Joshua not sort of highly valuing that
right here, right now. And uh we've got
that pack of wonders closed on Sunday is
beginning to put together this loop.
Pack of wonders. You'll be able to
exhaust that and return the Bewitching
Spirit, play it again. You'll be able to
hit that Blood Ripper and bring that
Bewitching Spirit and play it again. So
he's leaning very heavily into this
force discard here as Joshua just taking
a quick look seeing what he's got.
>> Yep, he is seeing and of course then
gets to draw that card too. Diana being
able to conquer a abandoned hole getting
themselves to three points but is
considering to also contest Rippers Bay.
Out goes Vex. Let's see what Close on
Sunday has to do in return.
>> Yeah, this has kicked off a showdown at
Rippers Bay and Joshua has a handful. He
had another one.
>> That's why he discarded if you have two.
I mean, you have cards to discard and
when you're versing a pike, you kind of
want to have as many cards as possible,
which Diana is really good at drawing.
And out comes that Moonfall. And now
going to be contesting Spir goes in as
well. And uh I think it's going to be
Joshua who wins the battlefield for
Showdown.
>> Yeah. So, Moonfall, really good new
signature spell here is you choose a
battlefield where you have a unit, you
may move up to one enemy unit to that
battlefield. So he's actually gone and
grabbed that bewitching spirit from the
base, dragged it into this battlefield
and forced it to fire into Vex apathetic
and then it applies a minus two might to
every opposing unit the en enemy unit
that is there. So that spirit cop that
as well and now Vex apathetic easily
wins that showdown there.
does win that showdown. Doing a minus
two to all of these units, including
Bewitching Spirit, who's only on two
might, which means that there's not
going to be much might for that
Bewitching Spirit to have.
>> Yeah. So, it does go down to that zero,
and obviously points of damage need to
be allocated to actually kill a unit.
So, that's a little unknown piece of
tech there that you can get a unit's
might down to zero or less, but it does
not die unless you actually attribute a
piece of damage to it. So, that is
exactly what that combat showdown did
there with Vex. Obviously, no might
present. was just able to easily win and
take that showdown. And we do take a
quick look at the score here. Joshua
already racing ahead at four points to
closed on Sundays, too. So, he's finding
ways to work around this discard loop
that closed on Sunday has presented. And
we do see Starcross hit the board.
>> Does hit the board and of course going
to be returning one of his own units to
hand. And one of Joshua's own units does
choose to pick uh Diana. Diana is such a
lowcost unit that I think Diana was
going to come back out next turn.
>> Yeah. So that Sacross hit that treasure
hunter on the side of Close on Sunday
and hit that Diana Lunari on the side of
Joshua. But then he's happy to do this.
He immediately replays that treasure
hunter. He brings out that Pike as well,
the champion unit here for Blood Harbor
Ripper Pike Doside Butcher. That is the
Fury variant and has that untapped pack
of wonder as well. So interesting to see
what he's going to be doing here. We
have the ambush mechanic. No, sorry, the
hidden mechanic as well as the ganking
on this pike. And has that optional
extra as well. You can recycle that fury
rune as an additional cost. And when you
play me, if you and the paid the
additional cost, ready me and give me
plus two light this turn. So that could
be a huge unit when it hits, but it
appears he has not opted to go for that.
He is tapped out on the
>> Oh no, that's another Vex apathetic
coming through from Joshua. I and
another al Diana of course coming out
once more. Raven Bloom student is on
that abandoned hole which as we said
earlier is such a strong battlefield for
those who love spells like Diana like
Raven Bloom students and now this army
on both sides is getting quite quite
aggressive.
>> Yeah, they're definitely developing
their board states here. The bases are
loaded up with units. I I dare say I'd
be more fearful of Joshua's units here.
He is currently on those six points and
having a Raven Bloom sitting on
abandoned hall is effectively a much
cheaper Diana no longer human. You get
that plus two might per spell cast
>> just for having that Raven Bloom and
closed on Sunday having to consider his
options here. He has ready his runes
falling star fantastic removal piece.
>> Yeah, we'll be using that falling star
of course on Joshua's unit. Deal three
to a unit and can do it twice. going to
go for the backline. It looks like
actually just choosing to get rid of one
Vex using both uh strikes on to the Vex.
>> Yeah, that's right. Vex being that four
might makes him a little bit harder to
remove and having to commit both lots of
three to that one Vex. It kind of feels
uh bad like not a high value, but when
you've got two, you've got to do
something about it. He could only remove
one unit and that Fizz.
>> Oh, Fizz is out. And when you play Fizz,
you may play a spell from your trash
with energy cost no more than three and
you get to ignore it. So guess what
comes out again? It's going to be that
Bowling Star has to pay of course the
power cost still recycling it. And this
time let's see what Sun is going to be
targeting.
>> Yeah, we do see Joshua hovering that
Diana Lari. I think they're trying to
decide what is going to be used. They
had to sacrifice those gold tokens and
it does hit that second Vex apathetic.
So a very costly turn for closed on
Sunday, but this is the late stages of
the game. He has to be doing something
to get presence on those battlefields.
And those Vex apathetics are such a
phenomenal unit to prevent that, Rasi.
>> Yeah, indeed. And the Vex now out of the
board, but I'm trying to remember. I
think Joshua only had two Vexes in deck.
I'll double check the deck list later,
but with this four point difference
right now, two close on Sunday is trying
to now get himself to three. That
treasure hunter is on Rippers Bay right
now and Joshua has still got his uh uh
Raven Bloom Student on Abandon Hoe. I
think Close on Sunday may be considering
to try and get both right now because he
has to try and catch up.
>> Yeah, you are right. There was those two
Vex apathetics in that deck. So Joshua
is done with those for now. So close on
Sunday obviously he doesn't have that
information though. He may need to play
or consider around that third Vex
apathetic. But Pike moving into the
battlefield, the abandoned hall.
Abandoned hole showdown begins and out
comes of course quite a few spells. You
see Diana here wanting to use dupify as
is quite standard is going to be also be
able to get that card draw from it and
maybe something useful will come out
from that top deck.
>> Yeah, this is exactly where Diana wants
to be moving into that abandoned hall
being able to just spam multiple spells.
Hitting that stupify into that card draw
increases the chance of more spells.
Diana giving that free energy as well.
So that stupify hasn't even hit the rune
pool of Joshua. He is still three runes
up.
>> And there it is.
>> That's going to be quite rough. Close on
Sunday does not win that showdown. And
everybody heals after a showdown ends,
but that stupify the the benefits from
abandoned hole. They stay throughout the
entire turn.
>> Yeah, that was a really great move. And
unfortunately close on Sunday. There's
not much he could have done into that.
Three runes up with a fourth spare
energy on that Diana Scorn of the Moon
Legend. That stupify obviously reducing
the might of the pike down to three and
putting that Raven Bloom up to four with
the abandoned hall. Fantastic combo.
>> Now on seven. All Jashu needs to do is
try and take Rippers Bay and he will win
this first game. He does of course have
that Diana still up and only treasure
hunter is on Rippers Bay in on forclosed
Sunday. He does have four runes up, so
potentially is able to do something. But
I believe that gold is not usable this
round. So all he has is those runes
>> right now. Joshua full hand of runes has
sent Diana Lunari into Rippers Bay which
will kick off that showdown here. Closed
on Sunday.
>> There it is.
>> Yep, that is game is going to be
Joshua's first win of this series.
Currently 1 Z. Of course, this is a best
of three and we will be sideboarding
between these two rounds. So, close on
Sunday may now take some time to think
what tech does he want to put in to try
and win against with Diana.
>> You're so so right. The best of three
match here and Joshua takes the first
one convincingly there. It was eight
conquest points to close on Sunday's
three and as you say that sideboard
could be coming through. We do see
closed on Sunday reaching for his
sideboard and um surely he'll be looking
to have some more answers into that Vex
apathetic style. I don't think the
falling star was the most efficient use
of it and recurring it was so costly.
Setting him back four runes you had to
recycle for that. And uh it just felt
like the discard wasn't working into
this particular Diana build right now.
He had all the answers. He was happy to
discard that moon for cuz he had another
one.
>> Yeah, this Diana with the predict with
all the card draw, you know, stupify and
all the other cards that he has to his
disposal means that even if Pike is
going to force Diana to discard. I mean,
Diana has cards to discard.
>> Well, exactly. You're playing into the
mind domain, right? And the mind domain
loves to draw cards and it also loves to
predict cards, too. So you are
filtering, you are drawing, you will
have a healthy hand as I do believe we
saw potential piece of sideboard deck.
Uh a mindsplitter
mindsplitter being one of the most
powerful cards from Origins. Uh seven
and two able to force the discard of
whatever you want at your choice as well
for that Pike player. Closed on Sunday
was taking a quick squeeze at it and uh
it'll be interesting to see how this one
kind of changes up the game or if we'll
even hit those sideboard cards here.
Yeah, I mean we didn't get to see the
Thousand Tower Watcher in the hands of
Joshua anyway. So maybe we won't get to
that late game and we'll be able to
finish it up in the early game again.
But I mean it's up to these players of
course, but that was a very very
fastpaced first game.
>> Yeah, that was actually very quick. It
was well controlled by Joshua and
fantastic call chase um that thousand
tail watcher. He had it in hand the
entire time. Never discarded it. He had
a closer, but he just simply didn't need
it. That abandoned hall proving its
worth on that Raven Bloom student.
>> I'm very curious, speaking of abandoned
hole, what battlefield do we going into
this next uh game? I mean, we did get to
see Joshua's deck list or we'd know what
two other options it could be. But we
don't really know what Pike is going to
be playing except of course what is
currently meta on Pike.
>> Yeah. So, Diana is a deck that wants to
conquer, but it doesn't necessarily want
to hold a lot. So, I would expect uh
potentially Targon's Peak, right? So,
when you conquer, you can ready two
runes in your end step. So, that
obviously gives them more runes up to
answer anything this aggressive pike
deck would want to do.
>> Y
>> I I think that would be a terrific
answer. He's currently in a winning
position, Joshua, cuz he is up that one
game and he will be looking to close it
out here in this game too, Ricey.
>> But what fascinates me is what
battlefields does closed on Sunday even
have? We've already seen the rippers bay
which is fantastic at sort of bouncing
those units back. We did see him start
to get that loop going but with an
aggressive fury and a control chaos
deck. It remains to be seen as we see a
Zorn Warren as well as what appears to
be is that a I think that might be a new
unleash one. It's abandoned hall. It's a
that abandoned hall again. We're getting
twice and a treasure hunter has been
played. Treasure Hunter is out once
more. I mean, Claus on Sunday is going
to be coming starting first. Of course,
he got to choose and most people here in
Riftbounder do like starting first here
and treasure hunter is out and turn two.
Joshua always has a turn to play. It's
going to be Diana of course with those
three runes.
>> Yeah, I do like the Zorn Warren
battlefield that we're seeing on the top
there as well. Rice, that speaks to
discard. Uh you move in, you discard one
so and draw one. So that plays a lot
into the closed on Sunday style there as
Diana Lunari is out as well. And uh
we're back to close on Sunday already.
These first turns they move very
quickly. They obviously feel comfortable
and confident in what they're doing.
>> That's what also Malaganning helps with.
But our girls treasure hunter going to
be contesting Zorn Warren. And out comes
that gold of course from that treasure
hunter. Diana is going Joshua is going
to be look doing a stacked deck in
response. This is such a good card. I
mean, it's it's an action. You get to
play it immediately and look at the top
three of your cards of your main deck
and put one into your hand and recycle
the rest. And against the Pike who loves
discarding it, Diana Joshua is going to
have more cards to their disposal.
>> Absolutely. And it's a very very strong
part of this game, right? Is filtering
cards, drawing cards, and Stack Deck is
definitely one of the best at doing
that. We see just a a little moment
there just having a bit of a giggle
amongst themselves. It's great to see
the spirits are still high in these
games as well. Yes, it is a high OPL
event. Yes, it is a competitive series.
They're having a good time.
>> They are definitely having a fantastic
time. This is still also closed um
closed on Sunday's turn from uh round
three. And so he's going to be using his
legend ability here to bring back that
treasure hunter and also play that
treasure trove as well. That's now two
gold on hand and out comes that treasure
hunter once more.
>> Yeah, treasure hunter such a high value
unit in these chaos decks as well. Gets
some great early pressure. Being a two
drop means turn one plays uh you could
also get multiple of them on turn two,
but I I would imagine you'd reserve one
or two here and there. Blood Ripper has
been tapped as well. And uh yeah, that
Zorn Warren's great if you want to
conquer. So you conquer one and uh you
discard and draw. Yep. Then obviously
that forbidding waste on the other side
there for closed on Sunday. Currently
though, Closed on Sunday is ahead. He
has one conquer point and we get a look
at the hand. There's a gust. There's a
flash. God, they're quick with it. They
know we're looking Rosie.
>> They want to hide their cards from us.
We just want to have a little sneaky
peek. Um but yeah, forbidden waste is
the closed on Sunday's battlefield here.
Um, as you said, he does have that one
cocoa point, but so now has Joshua
bringing in Diana into Zorn Warren. So,
they're now even. But close on Sunday
does have a little bit of that temper
going first, but I don't know how long
it's going to last. I think he just
considered bringing out a
No, he decided, oh, he has to discard
first. He's going to be discarding Quay
and now playing that Vex Apathetic that
he was of course thinking about, but Vex
is out. That has to feel really good as
Jasher as well. Consistently seeing Vex
apathetic getting maximum utility out of
it. But close on Sunday does have a
healthy hand there as well. Does have a
few runes up with those gold tokens. So
able to recycle and pay into those
falling stars that we saw from that game
one. Oh, the hand.
>> Did I see another treasure trove just
there?
>> Potentially. He did have two in game one
as well at least. I do believe he has
three in that deck list as that treasure
hunter moves in.
>> Yep, treasure hunter moves in. Out comes
another gold. That's two currently
available for this turn. And that third
one is exhausted. Diana, of course, as
Joshua was pointing out, still has that
legend ability is going to be gusting
using that extra resource. A treasure
hunter away now. Coe, how is he going to
respond? He wants that point. He wants
to stay on top of tempo. The problem
here though with moving into forbidden
waste, forbidding waste, when a unit
here is defending alone, it has minus
two might.
>> It does have minus two might. And out
comes Star Frost. We talked about this
so many times. It's such a strong uh
spell to use and he's going to be taking
away that Vex and going to bring himself
bring that treasure hunter back into
hand.
>> Yeah, interesting. So the Gust obviously
returns that unit to hand, but he's
opted to Starcross, taking the chance to
return the Vex apathetic as well as his
own unit.
>> Yeah,
>> which forced Joshua to commit his
resources for August for nothing
>> because Close on Sunday turned it
around.
>> Still had one rune up though. So Joshua
is now going to be responding to Pike. I
swear if Joshua has another Gust, it's
be a stupify.
>> It's another stupify because of course
it is.
>> It is. Out comes that card draw, but
still it's going to be just a trade of
course.
>> Got to be happy with that though because
you want to slow down these fast
aggressive decks that closed on Sunday
is representing here with that pike
blood harbor ripper. This Diana sort of
mid-range angro aggro angro loves to
kind of mess with your tempo also having
those. Yeah, and we do see that down
there too. But um having that flash will
also be able to save a lot of Jashua's
units when this pipe comes online and is
able to sort of aggress forward onto
these battlefields here.
>> Stack deck comes out. Such a cheap and
useful card especially in the hands of
Diana who loves looking at cards and as
you were mentioning filtering out the
options top three decks top three cards
looking at them and of course going to
have that to hand put that into their
hand. And uh I'm seeing Joshua's hand.
There's like maybe five, six, eight. I
can't count very well, but so many
options that Joshua has to play, which
is not what Close Sunday wants because I
haven't seen that Bewitching Spirit yet.
>> Yeah, that bewitching spirit not coming
out forcing any of those discards. But
maybe we'll see that Mindsplitter that
we did see being teched in a little bit
earlier. Obviously getting that shuffle
going, but that is the second stack deck
to come out from Jashua. So he's getting
those card draws. He's getting that
control of what he wants as we we take a
cheeky tap of that gold like, "Yeah,
I've got that there to use." Joshua
though, exhausting multiple runes here
and will play
>> Vex. Yeah, another Vex. Of course, we
knew that was in uh Joshua's hand
because that is what Starcross did. But
out comes another Raven Bloom student as
well. Josh now building up his little
army to see to try and conquer of course
Zorn Warren or forbidding waste. closed
on Sunday is now his turn. He gets to
awaken everything. He didn't have
anything to respond up uh against what
Joshua had, but no one was contesting
just yet on the battlefield.
>> Yeah, forbidding Waste is an interesting
one obviously because if you defend
alone, it's minus two might. Yes. So,
you want to send in multiple units at
once if you're going to go and conquer
for that one. Zorn Warren though allows
a lot of hand control cuz when you
conquer, you discard one and draw one.
So if you have multiples of a thing and
you don't think you need it,
>> that's the better battlefield to go in
and conquer and start those points. But
this one much slower right now. Rice, we
do see treasure hunter and noxious hope
will come down with that legion cost
reducing it by two. But right now
they're just developing their boards.
>> They are developing their boards and of
course treasure hunter when I move play
gear token exhausted and as you
mentioned no hopeful I get cost two less
when I am played after another card has
been played. So, as you said, two cost
for a four might unit. And out comes
Fizz. When you play, you may play when
you play me, you may play a spell from
your trash with energy less than three.
I'm wondering what close on Sunday is
going to pick. He's only got three. Star
Quest. Oh, I see units out and you
bounce it for the Vex Athetic again.
>> Yeah, I'm wondering whether Treasure
Hunter is going to be the uh the side of
close Sundays. Yeah,
>> I think it might be, as you said, cheap
units. And get rid of that Vex. That Vex
is so annoying.
>> We're still, I believe, waiting for the
decision to be made here. The Vex, but
we're over to Joshua.
>> Oh,
>> okay. Joshua's turn. We've moved the
Raven Bloom into that Zorn Warren. And
he conquers.
>> He does conquer. Now on two points and
on Zoran Warren, of course, discarding
one. He's got to be discarding that
flash you talked about and drawing one.
Yeah, we do love a good old flash. Able
to save a lot of units. And we do see
Joshua. He has exhausted some runes.
He's recycled one rune there.
>> There it is.
>> That's the second Hay. We did see him
Joshua Joshua discard one Hay, but we
mentioned earlier Hay is such a
versatile unit and we I personally when
I see a Hay coming out on a Diana, I
start quivering in my shoes. Another
Raven Bloom student. And now close on
Sunday's turn. Yeah, Joshua has
developed a healthy board, but closed on
Sunday equally. Able to place three
units down in his base on his turn. So,
he's in a decent position from the
perspective of units. But, I mean,
moving into a Raven Loom student is not
something you want to do unprepared. So,
just moving that treasure hunter over
will conquer that forbidding waste. And
because it's obviously it's not
defending right now, but when it defends
being only a one minor unit, it will
actually go to minus one might there.
So, it's just a quick little and uh
that'll remove that little problem. But
does get that exhausted gold token.
>> It does get that discard exhausted
token. And as you mentioned, a minus
one. I joked about this on one of my
Nexus. No, a mind spplitter. Never mind
my nexus knight. This mine spplitter is
way more interesting. Let's see Joshua's
full hands and let's see if Close on
Sunday decides to discard.
>> Ooh, we've got some options. Abandon
Flash and Fizz. And that was a quick
decision that closed on Sunday, getting
rid of that flash. So Joshua will now no
longer be able to remove units from
those battlefields.
>> That explains why Joshua decided to
discard the flash. He had a second one
in hand. This seems to be a common theme
for Joshua when he's choosing to
discard. If he discards one, there's a
likely chance he has a second one in
hand. And now three units on in the base
for Joshua. Is he going to try and
contest both cards, both battlefields,
or is he going to just hold for now?
>> Yeah, so he has just held up to three
points. So Joshua is in the lead. Three
conquer points to close on Sundays, too.
>> He wants four, as we mentioned, momento.
You want that even point. So I'm
expecting him to potentially go for that
forbidding waste. But of course, if
you're defending alone, you get that
minus two. But Joshua has a few more
units than one.
>> Yeah. A few
>> a few more units than one.
>> Three more units than one. A total of
four. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, good counting. We're so good
at this.
>> I do math. Good.
>> English, too. Apparently, he does decide
to pull back that Raven Bloom student
though. Values that greatly and will
protect it. Does have a handful of runes
though here. So, interesting to see as
it looks like he's exhausting one, two,
three. Oh, I thought it was going to be
four. He's exhausted two and recycled
one.
>> Out comes a fizz and he's just going to
be able to play from the trash. And the
card he's choosing is stacked deck. And
he gets to pay that for free because it
doesn't use any power costs. And so top
three cards looking through it, choosing
what kind of deck he wants. Starcross.
Was that a gas and a tide turner?
>> Yeah, really, really good there. So
obviously tide turner able to switch
places that Starcross able to repel an
opponent and bounce one of yours as
well. And Gus just strong generally a
good removal for low might units which
closed on Sunday is presenting a lot of.
He's happy to decline the shuffle. So
Joshua obviously handing that shuffle
option over to close and he went, "No,
that's fine." But it is interesting
seeing that Fizz dropped just for that
stacked deck. He does have another one
in his trash as Raven Blue moves in.
>> Raven Bloom moves in solo close on
Sunday. Is going to concede. He has no
runes up I I think from the directions
I'm looking at which means Yep. Joshua
now on four points.
>> Yeah, Joshua goes to that four points as
you said. closed on Sunday. Tailing
relatively close behind on that two, but
the clock is ticking. He doesn't have
that bewitching spirit, so he's not
forcing any discard from Joshua. Joshua
very much being able to play the game
that he wants to play and in mind and
control.
>> Oh no, that is Starross targeting mind
splitter. Such a strong uh body of a
unit, you know, seven cost as well. So
to be able to bring that mind spplitter
back out, it's going to be really
expensive. But hang on, that might not
be too bad. Maybe he can just see all
the cards in Joshua's hand and force him
to discard again.
>> You took the words right out of my mouth
there.
>> I was going to say obviously it's a very
powerful unit. Seven might presenting
able to conquer these battlefields, but
a lot of the value with this mind
spplitter is that forced discard, right?
And he can pick anything. That's one of
the biggest perks of mind spplitter. It
doesn't just care about units, spells,
gear. It can pick anything out of your
hand. So, it can very quickly tear apart
a game plan. But obviously Joshua
choosing that minds spplitter has
something in mind here. Ricey,
>> he definitely does have something in
mind. And is he doing another Star Wars?
Did he play the Fizz?
>> Yep.
>> Again. And now doing another Star Quest.
Oh my goodness. Close on Sunday has a
diminishing
base now.
>> Yeah, the board stayed over on Closed on
Sunday's side. Looking very slim here as
that Vex apathetic moves into that
forbidding waste. Now no longer only one
unit defending. Yeah, no longer one unit
which means these units are four and two
six mine on forbidding waste and we know
how strong vex apathetic is. Now any
unit that close Sunday plays is going to
be stunned on play as well as not able
to move. Close on Sunday does I think
pack deck sometimes do have accelerated
units but I haven't seen any that close
on Sunday has played so far so I'm not
sure how it's going to affect him as
Fizz is uh active in play. And out comes
another stack deck.
>> Yeah, stack deck obviously closed on
Sunday. Trying to get some cards, trying
to filter through to find those answers
into this frankly oppressive board state
that Jua has put forward on this Diana.
I would have to imagine obviously we
didn't we didn't see the deck list here
from close on Sunday, but if we're
thinking about units that he would have
in this aggressive Pike deck that he
wants to return, we have seen that
Sharkling tech. Sharkling new with
unleash. Oh,
>> falling star. We saw close on Sunday do
this last time which deals do does it
twice deal three damage to a unit and
this time not actually targeting Vex I
believe he targeted way
>> because he's got another Fizz he's happy
to do it again
>> yes of course doing it again having to
pay that two power cost out comes
falling star once more this time I think
it's going to be Vex
>> have to wait and see he's making the
decisions but it's got to feel good to
get this two games in a row here
It's actually going to be the Raven
Bloom units. Now, I don't hate this
because remember when you're defending
alone minus two. So, Vexier now only at
two might and we know Fizz is a three
might unit. But I mean, how many runes
does Joshua have up?
>> Joshua looks to appear only having one
rune up right now, but that Fizz moves
in.
>> Fizz moves in though onto Zorn Warren.
Now Joshua with that one rune and of
course that legend is going to be
stupifying and get that extra card draw.
>> Yeah, valuing that card draw, valuing
that sort of tempo acceleration here.
Fizz obviously going down one might
doesn't really care. Conquers, discards
one, draws one and takes closed on
Sunday up to three conquer points here.
But I was saying a little bit earlier,
we haven't seen those sort of assault
units, those fury units come out of this
Pike deck right now. So I would love to
start to see those jump out onto the
board, conquer with their accelerate and
then return to hand with that blood
ripper which is kind of the play style
that this one really wants to see. Is
that noxious hopeful?
>> Nox is hopeful. I mean it is one of the
more aggressive units you were wanting
to hope to see. Um as costs two less and
still has a four might unit and going to
be using the first one is going to be
using that pike legend to return to hand
and maybe play fizz again. Yeah, look,
returning Fizz to hand is fantastic
value. At 3 in one, it's a cheap,
repeatable unit. Being able to get those
spells out of your trash and play them
again is fantastic. However, because
that falling star was recurred from the
trash, it is now recycled to the bottom
of that deck. So, that is now no longer
an option. And speaking of fizzes, let's
take a look at Joshua. He's got that
existential dread. He's got that Fizz.
He's got a few options. Right now, board
states are dwindling, but Joshua in the
lead with five points to close on
Sunday's three. and deliberating. He
does have a lot of runes. Exhausting
three here. Recycling. Could be Fizz.
>> Yep, there is Fizz. And going to be
playing Flash from the trash and going
to be using it on Vex.
>> Yeah, Val's removing Vex from that
battlefield there. Wants to keep it
readied as well,
>> which means that with that ready, Vex
unit could in fact get another conquer
point on his on Warren and making him at
six.
>> Yeah. And obviously with a discard one
draw one looking for answers into what
this blood harbor ripper is being
presented here from closed on Sunday. I
do like though as we go into conquer
zorn like we suggested. Yes.
>> I do like when the game slows down and
they're considering their options.
They're having a look at their hand.
What answers do we have? Because you got
to remember close on Sunday. He still
has that mind spplitter that was bounced
earlier as well.
>> He does. He does have that mindsplitter.
He has that fizz as well. He has lost a
few runes. you know, currently sitting
at six, but has that one gold and next
turn will be on eight, so can play that
mind you mentioned.
>> Yeah, but Joshua also only on six runes
here. He is, however, holding five of
them up for closed on Sunday's turn,
you've got to be concerned heading into
a mind and chaos domain deck with that
many runes up.
>> Five runes and of course the Diana
legends ability, too. So, in showdown's
equivalent of six energy, which is quite
a lot when you think about a Diana, how
many single one or two cost spells does
she have?
>> I mean, we've already seen one of those
stupifiers, but Diana is definitely
indexing heavily into the ones and twos,
the stack decks, the stupifiers. Another
falling star, Ricey,
>> that's pretty good. I'm wondering
whether Closenste is going to be
targeting the Vex here. I wouldn't be
surprised if it goes both onto Vex to
try and be able to conquer both
battlefields as quickly as he can, but
Joshua has an answer.
>> You love to see the abandon. That's that
new unleash counter spell. It will
return that spell to hand and he'll be
able to predict. So close on Sunday. He
can play it again if he wants to, but he
will have to sacrifice those last two
fury runes that he has.
>> It might be too dear of a cost to pay
here. Yeah, Close on Sunday is losing
runes so quickly and Joshua still has
three runes up and that Diana legend
ability which I don't know what Joshua
has in hand but I would be terrified
person decides not to use it again and
just goes to conquer forbidding waste.
>> Yeah, nice little conquer there. Fizz
getting that one point. Not something
you'll typically see a Fizz going in as
the solo conqueror here, but he has to
do something. He has to stay a pace of
Joshua. Joshua thought about it is not
going to responding to it. Has still two
cards in hand and close on Sunday. Let's
see what he's going to do here with the
last remaining four runes.
>> Yeah, so four runes up has just drawn
his card. Six for Joshua, four for
closed on Sunday. One unit a piece on
both of these battlefields here. Joshua
with the three runes and the Diana Scorn
of the Moon energy as you said. And
Falling Star again,
>> expensive expensive outcomes. Falling
Star going to be using that gold though
as well. and is going to be targeting
Fizz and presumably Diane, sorry, Vex
with the other three.
>> You can also just put both pings into
the Fizz, but if he has put that second
ping into Vex, it's currently sitting at
one sort of it only needs one more point
of damage before it dies, which Noxus
Hopeful can do.
>> Going in now with a four mightite. Noxus
Hopeful, but Jashu does have quite a lot
of runes up. is going to be recycling
one
>> and going to be playing existential
dread.
>> Yeah, that's the new unleashed stun
card. And if a unit is already stunned
and you've paid the repeat, it actually
bounces it to hand. So this will shut
down that Noxus hopeful and ah
>> star is still available in the hands of
close on Sunday. He's going to be using
it to return Vex to hand which does
close on Sunday. Will be able to get
that conquer point. Joshua conceding
with the Starcross and now Joshua has no
units on board and only two cards in
hand.
>> Joshua still ahead in tempo though.
Closed on Sunday only has one rune. So
not much closed on Sunday can do here.
He is in the uh ahead position from a
perspective of units on battlefields.
But he is behind on points and Joshua is
ahead on runes as well. Playing that Vex
apathetic into right the wind. I see
>> and that vex apathetic is going straight
into fizz and with that one rune off
close on Sunday has no answers now on
seven points. I mean all Joshua needs to
do is try and conquer Zorn Warren and he
wins this round but no he will concede
and is going for a hold instead.
>> Yeah, closed on Sunday. We got a quick
look at his hand. He doesn't look to be
in too strong of a position in there. I
think that headshake is very very
telling. There's the concede.
Congratulations Joshua taking the round
one here in two quick games. Ricey,
>> very quick games. Had full control of
the entire playing field with all the
card draws, all the stuns, all the
vexes. My goodness, I I do have trauma
with Vexes. I don't know about you with
your Nexus Knights, but I actually
really want to play Vex myself. But
seeing how well Joshua utilized Vex and
of course all the other cards in hand,
it was fantastic to watch.
>> Yeah. One thing that I really did enjoy
about watching these two go at it is
there was a lot of consistency from both
of those decks as well. We did get to
see that sort of double falling star,
that fizz falling star. We got to see so
many star cross which is absolutely a
breakout card from the unleash set here
and seeing so much control. It was it
was quite good and I felt like uh close
on Sunday's Pike deck struggled to have
answers into it unfortunately. Yeah, I
did like what Pike was trying to do um
trying to do all the uh return to hand
and everything, but we didn't seeing
Spirit. We saw a more expensive version
like Mind Splitter, but he was only able
to play that once. Wasn't able to bring
that multiple times to try and reduce
Diana's hand further. I mean, Joshua was
only left with two cards, but I mean
Diana's cards are really strong and
really created.
>> Yeah, exactly. It felt like every single
card of Diana's deck got value no matter
what card it was. Whereas it felt like
Cloon Sunday, unfortunately, he did have
a pack of wonders sitting in hand, but
without that bewitching spirit to be
able to loop it, he wasn't then able to
play it. So, it was effectively a dead
card. So, he wanted to conquer into that
Zorn Warren, but Joshua just wasn't
giving him the opportunity to conquer
it, to discard and draw something new
and different.
>> Yeah. And as a result, I mean, as you
said, Diana had so much control over the
entire game state, being able to choose
which cards Diana wanted and also
forcing so many cards of uh Pike back
into hands, you know, with the Star
Cross and all the other things that
Diana had to disposal.
>> Yes, but Jua taking game one has to feel
amazing here at the Riftbound Regional
qualifiers in Sydney. You take that game
one, that round one. It puts you in a
good position moving on up for the rest
of the day. And a good showing from
Diana, that free resource coming in
clutch actually quite a critical moment
in that game one. Able to cast that
stupify for free and turn that
Battlefield showdown around as well as
getting that extra card draw. So, it's
good to see these legends here
represented. I'm stoked we got to see
Pike and Diana here in that first round
as well, Rice. Yeah, I mean I know
you're really looking forward to see
more Diana's. That is your prediction
and that is I think your favorite legend
deck from my understanding of what we've
been talking about behind the scenes. So
I'm so glad you got to call us Diana
here on round one. And just a reminder
for everyone, round one is a very
interesting round because a lot of
people have buy. So it's actually less
players playing in this first round.
>> Yeah, a few less that's for sure. But uh
some exciting and spicy games if you
will. We get to see all that sort of
interesting sideboard tech. We get to
see some more unusual plays. Uh I mean,
one of my favorites from that game that
we did just see was the clothes on
Sunday got to double loop Falling Star.
He got to loop it in game one and then
he got to loop it again in game two. So
that's like that's got to be a feels
good moment, right? Because that feels
like your deck is doing its thing and
it's working. And Fizz just so strong in
these Chaos decks.
>> Very very strong. able to as as we were
saying multiple times, we got to see it
from both players, I believe. I mean,
flash was used from Joshua being able to
>> use flash again with that Fizz. And
yeah, as you said, just play any spell
from Trash as long as it's less than
three energy.
>> Yeah, that's the one.
>> And has to still pay that power cost.
>> Yeah, definitely. But they definitely
value it as well. Obviously, not having
to pay the energy, it offsets some of
that. And then when you've got those
gold tokens. Um, yeah. But that was some
great games and we're going to throw to
the winner interviews.
>> All right, we are here with Joshua.
Congratulations. You've kicked off the
weekend with a win. How are you feeling
about it?
>> Yeah, pretty good. Um, had a pretty poor
performance yesterday. Um, so I spent
pretty much the afternoon last night um,
fixing my deck. It feels a lot better
now. Um, still worried about uh Aurora.
>> Oh, look. Fair enough. But I mean, so
far so good. So, you got to count that.
Uh, how was your preparation coming into
this? Obviously, you've only had a short
period of time since Unleash released to
get this going. What was it like in the
leadup?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think for the past
month, we've just been running reps, a
lot of proxy games, reviewing cards,
trying to understand where the meta
lies. Um, it's a lot of guessing. I
think coming out to this event early has
helped a lot kind of build what uh the
expectation is. So a lot of changes uh
early on.
>> Um but yeah.
>> And have you done many matchups against
Pike?
>> Yes. Uh so my mate pretty much mains
Pike. So almost all my reps is into
Pike. So feel bad for the guy pretty
much knew what he's going to play every
time.
>> Fair enough. Look, there were a couple
of really uh interesting moments. What
do you think was the the main turning
points for you during the games?
Yeah. Um I think it was just trying to
continue watching for the break points.
So understanding where I need to build
my board. Um develop score, how far I
should extend, how far I shouldn't. Um
when you're playing against discarding,
um I think there's a lot of hard
decisions. Um some cards might be
viable. I think I threw out a Moonfall
>> and held an abandon anticipating the
falling star.
>> Um that could have gone the other way.
He probably could have minds splitted,
you know, anticipating the the
working out.
>> It was also really awesome to see you
running two Vexes in there.
>> Uh really, really, really obsessed with
Vex at the moment. Everybody is really
loving. What was the uh the decision-
making behind having them both in there?
>> I mean, at the moment, uh they've
released pretty much ambush for every
every uh every uh deck. So pretty much
and even just the four four um energy
four might deflect alone.
>> It's a it's a scary unit even without
the stunning and non-m movement, but
it's pretty much standard. Um Lilia, you
just need to be able to stop those
sprites.
>> Absolutely. So coming into this,
obviously there are so many people here.
You have to prepare against so many
different decks and styles of play.
Aside from Aurora, is there anything
that you really did go, you know what, I
really need to lock in and prepare for
this? Yeah, absolutely. Um, Aurelia is
still a huge issue.
>> Um,
>> understandable.
>> Yeah, I've got a couple couple things on
my sideboard specifically for the
Aurelia matchup. Still not looking
forward to it. Um, but yeah, I think
Aurelia and Aurora are going to be my
biggest biggest threats. Yeah.
>> Well, the only other thing that's worth
noting, I think, is that we know that
Allan CQ is also running Diana and
probably going for that best of.
>> What are your thoughts? Are you are you
feeling competitive? How are you vibing?
Look, I I I knew a lot of people uh very
good players, great players who have
been successful across multiple
regionals be playing Diner. Um I
honestly came for fun. I enjoyed Diner.
If I was playing anything else, I don't
think I'd have nearly as much fun. Um
ultimately here to compete. Uh if I get
a best sub, that's great. If I don't,
still had a great time.
>> Awesome. And so now that you've had this
win, are you gonna carry that momentum
across? How do you prepare for your next
match?
Uh, I think I got to uh, you know, I
can't let it go to my head. Like I have
to I have to be consistent. Uh, you
know, uh, play my game how I play it
every time. Um, try my best and
hopefully I can, uh, continue the
momentum going.
>> Absolutely. I mean, it's the best way to
do it. Thank you so much again.
Congratulations. We'll see how you go
for the rest of the weekend and, uh,
fingers crossed for you. Uh, we'll go
back to our wonderful casters.
>> Thank you so much, Steph. It was so
lovely to hear what Joshua was saying
about that matchup and how he feels
about Diana in the grand scheme of
things. We're going to probably be
seeing a lot more of Diana as we go in
through day one and day two of course,
but I'm very excited to see what we're
going to have coming up next.
>> Yeah, I mean some of the questions were
really, really good. I quite enjoyed the
concept that Aurelia is still strong.
That is one of my personal beliefs as
well. I definitely think Aurelia will
post up very highly in day two. But we
will, as you say, be going to the next
match soon, which I'm very keen for. I'm
hoping we get some different uh
unleashed legends from this one though.
We saw that very interesting Diana. We
saw that Pike. Uh maybe we'll see that
Lilia that was alluded to interview and
I know you are a fan of as well, Rice. I
am a fan of Lilia and I love what people
call the the strategy of Lilia online. I
don't know if I should mention it on
broadcast, but you know,
>> I'll come the sprites and Lilia goes
forward, he comes back, leaves a sprite
behind.
>> Yeah, that's it. No, but I'm I'm very
very interested to see
>> the sprite fountains as well. Uh that
sort of fast aggressive maneuvers that
the Lilia can do. And um yeah, hopefully
we get to see it as we go to that second
match.
>> And so we'll have to see what these two
players are playing, what legends they
have. Um right now you see them of
course shuffling and preparing
themselves for the start of game two.
important things
of these players, right? They have a
consistent representation of their
cards. They've got the consistent
sleeves. They've got the consistent
decks because you're only allowed to
have the cards you're going to play plus
sideboard. That's it in these deck
boxes. And here it is. There's the
Aurelia matchup into Renga. This will be
a good matchup, Ricey.
>> Now, I'm very excited about this. As you
mentioned before, Ireelia is considered
quite strong still in this meta, but
Rengar, he is one of the new ones. He
has a lot of ambush tech. Um, so it's
going to be really interesting to see
how these two legends face off against
each other. How do you feel about this
match up? Do you think it leans one way
or the other, Logan?
>> I feel excited because Rengar is a
little bit more of an unknown when
compared to Aurelia, right? But Aurelia
is strong. I think you could talk to
anyone. You would see that she is very
strong. We would expect to see an
abandoned hall from Aurelia potentially
throughout this best of three matchup.
>> Yes, I assume Aurelia ran that abandoned
hole in game one. And uh looks like our
uh I unfortunately cannot read Chinese,
but looks like they did win that first
match.
>> Yeah, definitely. So, we've got the
Aurelia. They've won game one here. We
do find ourselves in that game two of
the best of three matchup situation. And
there is that overnumbered
Borro. We do love to see it. The lonely
Porro. They're looking a little bit sad,
but the Rengar Rengar bot is being
featured here as well. Has actually
played out one of the the one of their
body cards. We just had to get a double
check on that one. You always love to
see that when you play your card out and
your opponent goes, "What was that? Can
I please read that card? It tells you
that they haven't really practiced into
it, but we get a look at Rengar Bot's
hand and there was actually a couple of
Kaiser survivors in there. So, we could
get some explosive turns happening.
Rising
>> could indeed. And Ireelia is going to be
playing
>> is that
apathetic? I recognize the art. So,
well, we're going good here. Also has Ty
Turner in hand as well. Um, lots and
lots of options to go for for our
Ireelia player. Um but right now no one
actually has conquered just yet. This is
still early days and well with Renab bot
I think he had to skip turn one having
to play a four might unit four might
unit here on the second turn.
>> Yeah that four energy three might there
one of the classics. It's that second
turn. Unfortunately you don't want to
miss that. We do see a card being played
out here. uh tapping those exhausting
those five runes and potentially
recycling the one waiting for the play
here. Oh, we get another look. There's
still that Kaiser survivor.
Oh, we can see another Aurelia Fervent
in the hand of our Aurelia player here
too.
>> Exactly. Yeah, another Ireelia. And
Ireelia is over the sleeve. Very strong.
And being able to have another one is
going to be really good for Ireelia. And
out goes Rangabot's unit to go onto
Sunken Temple. Ireelia is not going to
play anything in return. Is happy to
concede. First conquer point on the
board in the hands of Rangabot.
>> Yeah, Rengarot is actually uh in the
Riftbound Australia Discord as well.
He's one of the community that we get to
hang out and talk with quite a lot and
is a passionate believer in the Rengar
uh community. He champions this one
quite a lot very heavily here. But we do
see that uh the Kaiser Survivor has gone
in and has conquered one point. So
Rengarot on the board. However, we do
take a look at Shinjia there and we've
got the Tide Turner. We've got Aurelia
Fervent. We've got Defiant Dance, the
signature spell of Aurelia Blade Dancer.
It will be interesting to see how she
lands here in the Unleash meta, at least
here in the first regional qualifier,
cuz she was so strong in Spirit Forge,
and a lot of pundits still believe that
she is strong here. She's been given
some extra tools such as abandoned hall,
which we did get to see in that game one
fortunately. So, Defiant Dance suddenly
becomes a a six a seven might swing as
well depending on how you play that one
around Nengar considering his options
while uh this Aurelia play is just
currently weighing up his options. He's
segmented his runes into five and two.
We're thinking oh tide turner nearly
slips there but five and two. So, we
could look at an Aurelia here
and there it is. Aurelia Ferven has hit
the board.
>> has hit the board. And we know how
strong Ireelia is, of course, especially
with that ability where if you use an
ability on Ireelia plus one, it's very,
very strong. Um, and so Rangot is on two
points with that hold, but Aelia is
still building up their base right now
and will probably want to go in to
contest shortly.
>> Yeah, we do see Zingo. He has played
that Aurelia fervent. But when you
choose or ready me, that is when Aurelia
will get that plus one might. And we
just saw a headshake coming out of
Rengar potentially. We not quite sure
what that one is there, but has decided
to pull back that Kaiser survivor,
protect that Kaiser survivor in the face
of what is already an imposing base
board state from this Aurelia player
here. They will definitely be looking to
move in and start conquering, but
critically it doesn't look like they
have any of the protection pieces
outside of Tide Turner uh to protect
that Aurelia Fervent if she does decide
to go in here.
>> Yeah, Ireelia of course has to be
protected. You protect the queen, try
and do as much as you can possibly with
her as such a strong unit, especially in
this meta. And uh with sunken temple
though being the battlefield of choice
for Ireelia, I'm very curious to see how
it's going to work. But Rangabot at the
moment building up that army, building
up that base, has four units currently
available for themselves. Um and yeah,
now it's going to be very interesting to
see what Ringot is going to do. As you
said before, they pulled back that
Kaiser to protect that Kaiser. Now
Aurelia, it's their turn. Drew a flash.
>> That is a good pull. That is a fantastic
protection piece of the queen as you
said and Aurelia Fervent moving in has
been readied so gets that plus one might
is currently a five might unit onto that
sunken temple and as a reminder for
sunken temple when you conquer here with
one or more mighty units which Aelia is
you may pay one energy to draw one card.
>> Well I think that is exactly what
Ireelia maybe wants to do here.
Find your center has been drawn
>> and it's tempting to use find your
center. We know how strong Find Your
Center can be. Remember, you can use it
and gain more cards and more runes.
>> Yeah, cards win games. We do see that
Find Your Center come down here just to
get some extra tempo. Draws into that
second Defiant Dance. So, as you see,
find your center, action speed, draw
one, and channel one rune exhausted will
be all the benefit this one gains. It is
not cost reduced because the opponent is
not within three points of that victory
score. But
>> we do see Xiaou here. We're testing the
waters. We're contemplating our game
plan. Has a lot of tools here. We do
know that Defiant Dance was already so
strong in Spirit Forge. And it is just
as lonely porro. Out goes Lonely Po on
to Sigil of the Storm. So, Ireelia now
being able to get that two conquer
points now, which means that the tempo
is kind of the similar between the two
players. Renabot also on two conquer
points. And I don't think Ren is going
to be answering this. Now, it's up to
Ireelia has a few more runes up. Do they
want to keep those runes up to try and
hold these battlefields or will they try
and do one more play? Lots of cards,
lots of options. As you mentioned, fire
dance is available, but do they want to
even use it right now?
>> Yeah, I don't think they do right now.
There's there's a strong sort of base
state coming out of Rengarbot will have
a lot of units to be able to throw at
that problem, but then it's down to what
answers he could have into that defiant
dance. Obviously, we're in body and fury
domains here. There's not much sort of
countering that can be done, especially
if it's on the Aurelia, right? So they
obviously got Repulse in Unleashed, but
that has to be something that targets
your unit. And Defiant Dance, obviously
half of it does, the other half doesn't.
So that could potentially work here. But
what I liked here, the lonely porro
going in onto that sigil of Storm, Zinho
knowing that he has a lot of runes up
and is happy to recycle one of his runes
to get that conquest point. And that Vex
Apathetic is going to shore up that
second battlefield.
>> Vex Apathetic, you can't get away from
her. She is absolutely ever right now,
especially on purple. And as you
mentioned, out onto sunken temple, which
does mean, I mean, Renabot doesn't quite
have an answer for her just yet
potentially. But now it's Renabot's
turn. So, let's see what he has to say.
>> Yeah, Rengarot will have to develop some
answers here. Does have a lot of units
in. That's a lot of units in hand,
actually. He may not even have
I can't spy many spells in that hand
that would answer much of what this
Aurelia player is going to be doing.
>> I would love to see this Rengar deck use
some of that ambush techniques, that
tactics, that new mechanic that has come
to unleashed here to kind of swing these
board states. But Vex is such a problem.
>> It really is. Vex is a hard counter to
ambush. Amb sorry. What Vex does is when
the enemy plays any unit, that unit is
stunned, cannot deal any damage and
cannot move. Ambush is a card that you
play on as a reaction speed and so you
like to play it onto a point, but once
you play it, it doesn't deal any damage.
It completely nullifies that ambush
tech. So, this is a very hard matchup
for Rangobot right now. And I mean,
still is considering what to do here.
has played a card and is going to be
buffing uh giving one might to Kaiser uh
with that Kra Kadrick Grin the Infernal.
>> Ah Kadran the Infernal. When you play
me, draw one for each of your mighty
units. So getting a couple of cards
there. I do believe we're seeing three
mighty units on the base of Rengar Bot.
And that card draw definitely looking
for some answers. You can see he's
smiling here. I think that was the smile
of old criy. I didn't find that answer
I'm looking for. I'm going to have to do
this the oldfashioned way and send some
units in to fight with this one. Four
runes exhausted. It will be interesting
to see what is going to be played here.
And it looks to be another Herald of the
Scales. So, this is kind of like a
sleeper dragon deck here as well. Rice
here. And um I'm liking the development
of this base state here. He's going.
It's a slow game, right? So, right now,
they've both got two points a piece.
Rengarbot is building this base up.
There's so many units. That will be so
much might presented. That Herald of the
Scales. The dragon's costs are being
reduced significantly. So, turn after
turn, he's going to be able to play more
and more and bigger and bigger units.
The Kaiser goes in.
>> Kaiser goes in and is going to be
attacking the Lonely Po. But the Lonely
Parro was in fact very, very lonely. So,
the Death not trigger will go off and
Zhao Chang is going to not do anything
else. Concede that conquer point to
Rangabot.
>> Yeah, Shiao there obviously letting that
lonely Porro die getting that car draw
which he is definitely putting a lot of
value on. Is in the driver's seat does
have that game one under his belt and a
healthy hand of runes there Icy. That's
11 runes up. The world is his oyster. He
will be able to protect the queen. He
will be able to contest any and all
battlefields here. No matter how much
might this Rengar player will be able to
present, but we still haven't seen what
Rengar can do to this Vex apathetic.
There's just no answers right now. And a
Stellaricorn Herder to boot for the
Aurelia player here. It's a tough
mountain to climb for Rengar bot.
>> Very, very tough. And Ireelia is going
to be playing that Selicon Herder you
just mentioned. It's such a strong card
for reasonably cheap when you move draw
one. And Ireelia, how many cards does
Ziao Chang already have? It's quite a
lot. We are protecting the queen.
Bringing Amelia back and bringing Vex
back as well. Now Rangabot does mean
that does mean that that Vex passive
though is not what is not active
anymore.
>> Yeah, really good to get that off of the
battlefield. Obviously, it frees it up
for Rengarot, who now has an opportunity
to conquer if he feels like he can, but
that's exactly what Aurelia wants to do.
Aurelia wants to conquer. And obviously
with our vision, we know Xiiao has the
answers and can protect that Aurelia
Fervent. He has another Aurelia Fervent
in his hand. So if he wants, he could
commit the one on board into a trade and
then get the second one out and develop
it because a lot of the time these
Aurelia decks typically only run the
one. Oh.
>> Oh no. Out it comes. You were just
talking about it. Now there's two and
it's going to be quite difficult for
Renabot to contest these. But I mean at
the moment Zia Cheng is not going to be
potentially trying to get those conquer
points. He's building up his army and
looking for the future.
>> He's got the time here, right? As we do
see the Evelyn as well. Love the flavor
text on Evelyn. Uh if I do say so
myself, it's a bit of a banger. But Ghou
has the time. Both of these players,
they're at three points a piece. Sigil
of the Storm, you typically only want to
conquer that one time. You don't want to
force the recycling of your runes too
often. So Sunken Temple is the one that
they will contest where you conquer with
the mighty, you pay your energy, you
draw the card. And it does just look
like that's all he wanted to too. He
wanted to play that Aurelia fervent and
hold as many runes up as he possibly
can. And uh it'll be interesting to see
if Ranggarbot wants to call that bluff
or or play into it here. I see Rangabot
is going to be holding going to four
points, but of course there's more that
Rangabot wants to do. Is going to be
channeling those runes drawing and lots
and lots of cards on the board for
Rangot. That looks pretty strong and
Vex's passive doesn't do anything to
them. Number one, she's not on a
battlefield. Number two, they're already
in play.
>> Exactly. So, that is a healthy healthy
board state that Rengarbot has. That
will be a lot of might that um Xiaosi
has to overcome here. We do see though
Kadrian moving forward.
>> Does move in, does take over sunken
temple, gets that conquer point as well.
Ireelia doesn't want to respond with
anything. Does have two runes up though,
so potentially something else could
happen later on. But for now,
everything's all good. Rengarot is now
going to be drawing another card.
>> Yep. Xiao just sitting on the opposite
side of that one. Rengarbot is deciding
what to do here. Has exhausted one of
his body runes,
riffling through the cards because these
dragons are so cheap with two Heralds of
the scales. And that is another sort of
blazing drake there that we see there
hitting the board. And it's so cheap
right now. The Blazing Scorcher has
Accelerate 2. If you pay into that, I
don't think he has here, which is why
it's represented as not ready. It is
currently exhausted on that board. And
we do see Xiao looking at his options.
He does have the two runes up. Rengar
placed yet another drake. This cost
reduction from the Herald of the Scales
is adding up right now. that June Drake
when I attack give me plus two might if
there is a ready enemy unit here
>> that's pretty exciting and that might be
really good against I play due hold
later on but currently Rena is on five
points which is getting closer to
potentially that needed eight and once
you get sorry six needed six to then get
to the eight once you hold onto the
battlefield but of course Ireelia I'm
not counting Irelia out just yet. Look
at those cards. We are scared of these
Vexs. We're scared of the Ireelia, but
still Renar is so scary now.
>> Rengar is scary. But we see a Baron
Nasher as well in the hand of Aurelia.
This is a new card from Unleashed. And
if we do get to see it played, it will
develop that additional battlefield,
that baron pit, which will force you to
have to conquer all three in one turn,
which could extend the life of this
game. I really do like to see this from
Xiho.
Aurelia is traditionally sort of that
mid to late game, right? Aurelia can
easily conquer two battlefields in a
turn if she does find those boots of
swiftness. And this gentle gem dragon,
>> I mean, its energy has been reduced by a
total of four. So, he's only paying four
energy to play this out.
>> When you play me or another dragon, we
see so many dragons in Rangabot's hand
right now. Ready up to two runes. So, we
can see how many runes Rangabot has
still off. This gentle gem dragon is
doing a lot of work for Rangabot,
meaning out comes another card.
>> Yeah, it almost feels like Rengar Bot
strategy here is I'm going to wamp you
in the face with the most amount of
might you've ever seen in your life and
there's not a thing you can do about it.
Aurelia, however, is in the Chaos
Domain. I know we haven't seen one in
that hand, but there could potentially
be rebukes, which was a classic in
Spirit Forge. There could be some Star
Cross, which is definitely an emerging
card here in Unleashed. And there it is.
Thrill of the Hunt.
>> Thrill of the Hunt is such an exciting
card, especially of course for Ranga. It
is their signature spell. And let's see
how Rangot's going to be using it. Of
course, looking at Sunken Temple right
now. So, let's see how Ringer develops
everything.
>> Yeah, thrill of the hunt. Obviously, a
reaction speed banishes a friendly unit,
then its owner plays it to any
battlefield, ignoring its cost. So, he's
going to get so many cards off this
Kadrick in the infernal because it gets
a card for every mighty unit. He's about
to draw half of his deck here. I see.
>> Wow. Rangabot has really developed their
playing field right now. And I think I
saw a little bit of a smile on Zhiao
Changeng's face that like what on earth
is going on? This Renga is absolutely
crazy. How many cards did you say he's
going to draw?
>> Uh so he's got the gem dragons. He's got
the heralds which are presenting as
mighty. So there's three, four, five, at
least six I think because Kadrian as
well Kaiser at least six cards drawn out
of that. That is an extremely high value
Kadrian the infernal that we saw.
>> And up goes two more runes readying
them. again.
>> Not done yet
>> cuz he played that uh dragon card once
more from the banish and he gets to play
it again. So, two more runes readyed up
once more. And so, now looking at his a
billion and one cards. Um I can't even
see what cards he has in his hands. It's
just too many. And he's also not showing
on the screen. So,
>> oh, we did see an ancient henge in hand
actually. That's some really cool tech
there where you can swap your uh energy
and power around to to play with. I'll
just double check that one cuz it's not
one we actually see too often here. But
what do you do when you've got half your
deck in your hand? And another Herald of
the Scales that reduces dragons by a
total of six energy now, Ricey.
>> That's incredible. And it was a dragon,
right? Herald of the Scales is a dra Oh,
does it doesn't say dragon. It's not a
dragon. So, it's just a unit. It doesn't
actually ready up his two runes, but I
mean, I think he's got another dragon in
there if he wants more runes.
>> Yeah, this is definitely a dragonheavy
deck here. And just going back to that
ancient henge, I did see it is a gear
when you exhausted reaction. You can pay
any amount of energy to add that much
power of any color. So, resources are
plenty here as Rengar still in his turn
has decided to recycle one there. And it
looks like with there it is.
>> Yeah, there out comes that ancient
henge. Now that means with so many runes
up, he doesn't need to recycle them. And
he can just he has to explain the card
to um Ziao Chang as at the moment. We
can explain it to you guys too.
>> Yeah, as we were saying, it is two
energy, one power gear in the body
domain and it is an exhaust reaction
speed which is so so critical. And what
it does is you can pay any amount of
energy to add that much power. So it's a
fantastic sort of transference of
resources.
>> Does that mean as well if you need a red
uh power, you could actually exhaust a
yellow power to then pay that red yellow
rune to then pay that red power?
>> Yes, absolutely. Because energy doesn't
care about which domain it comes from.
So you can convert any domain's energy,
so to speak. It is domainless into
whatever color power you need, any
domain power you need. So right now,
Rengarbot has to be happy with this
board state sitting at that five
conquest points to Aelia's three. Xihao
looking at this developing board across
from him going, how can I answer this?
But he does have the card draw. He has
two Aurelia Fervent does have that
defined dance. More card draw. Having to
look at this card as well. So this one
is new I believe with the spirit forge
set. Show of strength reaction speed and
it's another Kadrian the infernal
effect. Rice here.
>> Draw one for each of your mighty units.
A unit is mighty. Well, it has plus
five. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10.
I'm worried Rengarbot is at real risk of
decking himself out. We're having a
quick check. It looks like there's only
two or three cards left. So, he has seen
nearly every single card in his deck.
Ricey, he has to have the answers here.
He's passed the turn. It is now over to
Xi Xiao to find a response into the army
of dragons.
>> This is absolutely insane. And I have no
idea if Rangobot was looking for one
particular card, but if he was, unless
it's the last two remaining cards in his
deck,
>> he probably has it.
>> I would hope so.
>> I would hope so, too. Anyway, five
points for Rangabot. Three now for Ziao
Chang. And it's now his turn. Everything
is ready up. He has a lot of runes to
his disposal. He has, in fact, I
believe, oh, 12 runes. So, he does have
answers. And we talked about the power
of Nasha before when it was his turn 10
million years ago. Um but yeah, we've
got that Baron Nasha up so available. So
let's see if Aelia is going to be using
it.
>> Yeah, interestingly Baron Nasha is 10
and three. So Xi Xiao is currently in
the place to just straight up hard cast
that one. Baron Nasher has been a quick
favorite to slam into Aurora deck. So
it's less likely to be seen. And there
it is. That's going to create that third
Battlefield Baron pit.
>> It will create that third Baron pit. And
that is though going to be extremely
expensive for Ireelia going to be using
those 10 energy cost and three power
cost and so only has two runes up for
this next uh next part of the game the
turn.
>> Yeah, this is really good though. This
is the first time we've seen Baron
Nasher played here at the RQ as you play
me add the Baron Pit Battlefield token
to the board if it's not there already
and if you do I enter there. So
immediately conquers up to four points.
I cannot be chosen by enemy spells and
abilities. So has that really great
protection from enemy spell slingers and
other friendly units have two might as
well.
>> Very very strong unit being able to give
all your friendly units plus two as
well. And we can see those plus two dice
coming out right now on to all of Ziao's
units making them quite strong. And
maybe maybe Ielia will have an answer to
Rangabot right now. Be able to get
themselves to potentially six points if
they can conquer the next two
battlefields. Yeah, one thing about the
Baron pit too is units can move here
from anywhere. So you don't even need
ganking. You can just move straight into
Baron Pit from anywhere. So it's a very
very accessible battlefield if you will.
But having hard cast that Baron for 10
and two Xiao considering their options
with what they do have left in hand. But
even with that plus two might across the
board. Shields are down right now. Only
two runes up at the moment. Yeah,
>> could potentially use the last of them.
But this is something that if you're
Rengar bot, you love to see, right? Your
opponent leaning over going, "What's
that card do? What's this card do?" So
many cards Xiao has had to look at. So
Rengar has that practiced advantage,
that mental advantage if you will, that
level of unfamiliarity.
>> Yeah, Ireelia is a very, very common
legend. So I'm sure Rangabot has versed
Ireelas before. So that unfamiliarity is
not relevant to Reno board. But as you
said, this Ireelia player Zhiao Chang
might not be familiar with Renga or even
this style of Renga.
>> Well, I mean, who is Rengar is one of
the new legends from set 3 unleash. So,
it is difficult to be familiar with this
and this is why it's such an exciting
regional qualifier here, Rice, because
this is the world's first look at a high
OPL level at all of our set three
legends. And Rengar bot smiling, right?
He knows he has an overwhelming board
state, a formidable board state. And Gi
Xiao is in the position of how do I
answer this? Obviously having played
that Baron Nasher, he's considering his
moves. He's got Vex Apathetic.
>> He does have Vex Apathetic. He's going
to go in with two units with one of
those Vex Apathetic and Stellicorn
Hoarder and is going to be contesting
that sunken temple. Rangaport, remember,
doesn't have any runes up. He has that
one mighty unit.
>> Yeah. And shields down for Rengar. As we
saw, you said, he has no runes. We're
getting some of that might match up
here. And I think that's the correct
call to take out that Vex apathetic,
that oppressive unit, stunning those
units on entry. It's gone. It can't have
its impact anymore.
>> Aelia now goes to five points. May want
to consider getting Sigil of the Storm 2
to get that six, but also may want to
instead build up their base. It's up to,
of course, Ziao Chang. What does he want
to do? Because Rangabot, as we can see,
there's a huge army looming over that
hill.
>> Yeah, does have a nice draw there. Gets
that switcheroo. So, is potentially
considering holding up those two runes
because then he'll have the energy and
the power he needs to cast that one
should it happen. And we do see,
>> as we were mentioning, Sigil of the
Storm does get conquered by Ireelia. has
to of course pay the cost to conquer
Sigil of the Storm, but that does bring
Ireelia up to that six points. Now, all
I needs to do is hold two of those three
battlefields in this next turn. Two
runes up and let's see what he can do.
>> Ooh, we're getting another potential
recycle here.
Doesn't look like he's done yet. He does
still have that two energy
considering Tide Turner potentially.
Switcheroo has defined dances. Isn't in
a showdown does control every single
battlefield. So if he holds these three,
he will win.
>> He's considering where to hide this tide
turner. I think it's very important
where do you need to put it? Because
when you use tie turner and when you
reveal it, you can switch places. And
obviously I think he's I think
personally I would consider not putting
it on Baron's pit because you you'd be
wanting to move Baron pit to the less uh
protected battlefields.
>> Uh Baron pit makes sense to me to not
put it on there because it also has that
innate protection. It is a massive unit
itself with a lot of might. Uh can't be
targeted by those spells and abilities.
So it will be difficult to remove. Does
opt to put that tide turner down on the
Aurelia fervent battlefield. that sigil
of the storm here and with two runes up
still has options available and right
now Xiao just playing that patient game
knows that every single play here right
now matters and has opted to switcheroo
onto that south battlefield there as
well adding another layer of protection
hiding that so these hidden cards right
now adding such incred and another tide
turner has hidden on every single battle
Battlefield is absolutely in control
right now and it will be up to Rengar to
find these answers.
>> Rengar has no idea which one is which.
I'm sure though he is very well aware of
what it could be. Probably knows one of
them. Might be a tie turner, might be a
switcheroo, but he doesn't know which
one. So, which battlefield is the safest
to go? The old very scary. Rangabot,
it's his turn now. Everything is getting
ready. Look at that army. Yeah, and he
does have a lot of runes and energy to
sort of the power and energy to work
with Rengarot, especially with that
ancient henge. He can change some of
those resources around. But you've got
to take a look at Xihao's board state.
He's at six points. He's holding all
three battlefields. So Rengar has to
remove him off of at least two of those.
Does have that thrill of the hunt,
another gem dragon. I mean, what doesn't
he have in his hand? but he's had a lot
of time to think about his answers into
the board state that Ghia has presented.
>> Out comes Is that a gem dragon again
coming through? It's It's such a large
army and well, let's see how Rango is
going to do it because has to do a lot
of maths. Outcomes the plus ones of
course that this unit has provided.
>> Yes. So that is another gentle gem
dragon when you play me or another
dragon ready up to two runes. So because
of all the cost reduction, it only costs
two runes. So he will now ready those
two runes. He's essentially got that
unit for free. He's just showing his
opponent how we went through that rune
process and how explaining it just you
know good sportsmanship and fairness
there. Obviously it is also to the rules
and she's yeah I was looking at this
board state going oh my goodness. But
it's up to Rengar bot. Yes, you've built
this massive army, but you know, Xiaou's
board state itself is no slouch either.
That's two Aurelia on battlefields.
>> Out comes another gentle gem dragon
costing two. Going to be able to ready
up those two rings that are costed and
at the same time buffing that other unit
when you play a dragon or mighty unit. I
don't remember exactly the the text of
it, but it does give them another two
might.
>> That's the one. That one there being
buffed is that herald of the scales.
And I don't think there
isn't
a name like Rengarbot and a legend of
Rengar. I was expecting to see way more
Rengar than these dragons as another
Dune Drake comes out as well. And we
have to remember
>> it's the sequencing here that matters.
He has almost every single card from his
deck in his hand right now. If he plays
this right, he's playing everything and
he's walking the judges through the
process. He's going, "This is how I'm
playing this dragon for free because I
have so much cost reduction and then
rune gain because of the gentle gem
dragons."
>> Exactly. Exactly. I mean, there's three
gentle gem dragons. Does that mean if he
plays a dragon, he gets to ready up six
runes?
>> Yes, it does. So, with that cost
reduction bringing most dragons down to
two, he's readying six. So he could
almost hold some dragons in reserve once
he's exhausted other runes, then play
the dragon and top himself back up
again. So I'm really liking this
sequence of play. The problem with all
these dragons that entering is they're
not entering ready.
>> No.
>> So if he has a way to be able to sort of
force the ready, it could work.
>> Looks like though he can though using
these dragons buff that scales you were
talking about. And maybe that's what
he's considering right now. They are
free units. They are free cards. It's
just a free might.
>> He could absolutely also just decide to
start trading into these battlefields.
He could force uh Xihao to pop these
hidden cards, get that information,
learn about it before committing his big
bad units to overwhelm and conquer the
battlefields. The problem Xiho is
presenting two runes up.
>> Yes.
>> And we know he has two Defiant Dancers,
which is one and one. So that's a big
sort of six might swing that he could do
here.
>> I mean Airelia is scary in this meta for
a reason. I mean Rangabot's battle base
is looking extremely scary. But we don't
want to count out just yet with those
defiant dancers as you were mentioning
those two runes up. They're very
important and well Rangabot is still
considering though what else to play.
>> He has to get it right. That's why it's
so important in a small correction. It's
a five might swing. There's no abandoned
hall on this particular game here as we
do see Rengar, but I I mean he has the
thrill of the hunt. He has the
mobilizers as well. He has the
detonates. There's no gear being
presented though, so can't use that one.
>> I mean, he has everything. He only has
one card, I think, in his deck. So, he
has his entire deck in hand minus one
and minus one's been played. So,
lots of options. Maybe, as you said,
Dance. I mean, he's not going to use the
detonate, but so many options. He's
going to be using three runes.
>> It would be an unusual position to be in
with such a strong board state in every
card in your hand and still struggling.
>> Did I just see that dancing grenade?
>> There is a dancing grenade. That is the
card that is on top of his hand. Yes,
>> he could bounce it on himself.
>> He could
>> and bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce,
bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, and then
go onto that Nasher. I've never seen it
happen before. That was just my first
thought. I was like, what if he does
that?
>> But the bouncing grenade itself is a
spell
>> and Baron Asher can't be targeted by
enemy spells and abilities.
>> Oh, I'm so silly. That's fine.
>> So potentially though, I don't think
that could work there. Could work on the
Aurelas. Will have to pay the deflect
cost if you want to target those
Aurelia.
>> Could convert every single piece of his
energy into power. There it is.
>> I'm so excited. I have never seen those
in. I mean, I saw it once.
>> It's unleashed. Yeah, I've seen it once
in one nexus knight, but we were really
confused about how it works. And of
course, IA Zhia needs to understand how
it works as well. So, the way I
understand it works is you deal two to a
unit, it's controller may play may play
this spell again for one power. And
remember with that henge, he can just
instead exhaust a rune. And if you do um
if the if the the controller does do
this, it deals an additional bonus
damage each time it bounces. Uh the way
it works so if you deal two damage to a
unit, you can deal two damage to your
own unit and you are the controller. So
you can bounce it amongst your own unit,
>> building up that damage and stay in
control of this grenade and then once
you pass it off to Ireelia,
>> it's up to them to do anything with that
grenade.
>> Yeah, good luck. Have fun. Here's a 15
damage grenade, you know. So it it's a
strong answer. He has Rengar bot a lot
of mighty units and he's starting to
indicate what units he's using it on.
He's deciding to ping down and kill his
own Dune Drake here just to get that
bouncing online.
>> Yeah,
>> it'll be interesting to see how much he
wants to commit to this.
>> He can bounce it on the same unit
multiple times. And so he just says,
"Oh, this unit, I've got too many. I'm
just going to get rid of it." And
>> well,
>> and he has fantastic targets for it as
well. He has a lot of units that are
exhausted, right? They didn't enter
ready. So, he can't swing with them this
turn. So, they make excellent targets
for this dancer grenade to build that
damage up.
>> Oh, there goes another unit.
>> Another June Drake. Yes.
>> Yeah. Let's see. I don't know how much
might this has. Uh maybe 10 at the
moment. Killing another one with a tant
grenade.
>> We do see these small dice just down
here bottom left of the battlefields
here. Is that like a 15 we're seeing?
Uh, it's hard to read those ones, but it
is climbing that blazing score. He's
sacrificed three June drakes, two
blazing scorches. He's gone for the
third. That's six units he's committed
to this dancing grenade so far. Ricey, I
can't count this high.
>> Yeah, I'm a bit I'm I This is such a
powerful grenade. I don't know where
it's going, but I would be so scared if
I saw this grenade coming towards me. It
would be massive. So much damage. And
well, it's starting, I think, to get to
the end of this dance.
>> He has to close it out here right now.
But he is playing into the best dancer
in Riftbound, Aurelia, the blade dancer.
So, you better have your tango shoes on,
mister, because she has answers here,
too. Rengar bottom
from here, because if he's able to play
another dragon, he could ready all those
runes up again and build that dancer
grenade even more. The problem being
>> it's likely going to be a one shot.
>> Yeah,
>> it's likely just going to take out one
Aurelia,
>> right? Probably the Sigil of the Storm.
Clear that hidden. Then what's he going
to do with the rest of the board state
that Xihao has in hand?
>> Lots of questions and Rangabot is
considering it. We can see how many
runes he has left out of three. But as
you said, if he plays any dragon, six of
them are going to just come back
straight up.
>> You absolutely do love to see that
though. So many runes and obviously we
can't get a good peek at that hand, but
I have to imagine there's still one or
two. I like Yeah. Do you see that face?
He's like, "Oo, actually a light bulb
moment there for Rengar Bot." As we do
see a little bit of tidy up happening on
this board state. Zhao waiting patiently
as Rengarbot works this one out. That
gem jammer there too. We still see that
Thrill of the Hunt on the top. So he has
the ability to kind of bounce one of his
own units and get that play me trigger
again if he wants to do that. And there
it is. Thrill of the hunt.
>> Thrill of the hunt does come out. It is
of course Renga's signature spell and
going to be using it on that gentle gem
dragon.
>> So so nice there with that dragon
entering. It's going to ready up all of
those runes again allowing this dancing
grenade to get even bigger. We are now
in the sort of final 10 minutes of this
match here as well. This second game has
taken quite a while. It will reduce the
time for the game three. But showdown
has started suddenly.
>> It has started between this gentle gem
dragon and Ireelia who I mean we
remember two runes up has that defiant
dance two of them in fact. So it's not
over. I mean it's not that eight and six
doesn't necessarily mean it will lean
towards Renabot because Ireel has things
up their sleeve.
>> Yeah. But this is still a great play
from Rengar bot. That is an eight might
gentle gem dragon that he's just sending
into Aurelia. Aurelia has to have
answers otherwise his gentle gem dragon
will knock Aurelia Fervent off of that
battlefield. Reveal that hidden. So he's
digging for that information. He's
digging for answers.
>> Exactly. Want to see what that hidden
card is. make them force them to use
those extra two runes that are up as
well. Lots of things that Rangabot um is
trying to force out of Ireelia's hand
and it's going to be the hidden
card or not thinking considering is this
the right play.
>> Ah there it is the tide turner.
>> It is the tide turner. Which
tide are you turning?
That didn't work out. Which unit will
actually No, he's not going to be
>> No, he's going to present more might
because of the Baron buff onto the tide
turner. So that sort of secret bonus
unit, that plus4 might, he's able to win
that battlefield.
>> He's not going to be using the onplay
effect for the tide turner and instead
is just using it as a normal unit.
>> Yep. So now Rengarot has that
information. He knows it's only a four
might vi.
>> It's origins VI. That's why he was
putting a lot of units into the trash.
He wanted V by to be really strong
because Vi, you can recycle uh as many
cards as you want from the trash and
give plus one for each card you recycle.
Also has ganking available, but there is
Baron Pit. So the problem is though,
she's not ready. So he has to find a way
to get her ready to swing in because he
still has to find answers into the Baron
pit into the Stellorn and Aurelia and
into the Sigil of Storms with that
fouright tide turner. He's taking a look
through his trash.
>> He is looking through that trash trying
to figure out how mighty they can mate
by. But as you mentioned has to ready
her somehow. Has a lot of cards in
hands.
>> He already actually has the answer.
We're seeing it here. Gem Jammer. So
doubtless
that
a unit. So he will recycle these cards.
He's going to give that much might over
to via destructive an Origins card here.
So some older tech if you will in a
7-month old game and send by swinging.
>> We've seen so many cards as well that
may let him do card draw as well. So he
might also have just put them into the
trash to then recycle them with buy and
then just redraw them up again with
those card draws.
>> Yeah, he's actually keeping himself
alive. He's preventing that burnout and
giving conquest points over to his
opponent by putting it in the trash. And
he's detonated the ancient henge.
>> He detonated the ancient henge and he
gets to draw two cards. So, one card,
the remaining card in the deck, which he
probably knew from uh elimination, and
one card that he discarded earlier.
>> Yeah. So, Vi has been the might
increase. I don't think we have an
indicator for Vi's might increase from
all of that trash recycling that we did
just see before, but obviously blowing
up his own ancient hen, so can no longer
convert that power into whatever color
energy he needs here. Ricey, he's kind
of removed some of that flexibility.
with that June Drake coming down again.
One of the ones that he did actually
kill off with that bouncing grenade from
earlier.
>> Yeah. So, June Drake comes down and with
those gentle gem dragons will be able to
ready up those runes once more. This is
just uh what do you call it? A snowball
effect essentially that Renobot Renabot
is trying to utilize. And well, we can
see of course the scales going up in
might as well. Lots of things are
happening with every single play that
Rangabot is choosing.
>> Yeah, that June Drake triggering the
gentle gem dragons obviously only having
two left on the battlefield. So, he will
get to ready up four runes total, but it
almost feels like we're caught in a loop
here. Ricey, it feels like Rengarot
knows how this deck works and very very
well. He's sequencing it in such a way
that he doesn't gas out. He's always got
this power. He's got this energy to make
the plays when he is good and ready to
make that play. He did get that info
from the top battlefield earlier.
>> He is pointing out that his VI is meant
to have a a dice on it.
>> The might indicator.
>> Might indicator.
>> Yes.
>> So, we'll see um how he's now going to
be going into these fights. He still
hasn't got control of any of these
battlefields. He wants to conquer 03
because he's five and eight.
>> Yeah, five. You want three more to get
to eight. Sorry. But there's three
battlefields because of the baron pit.
So if he's able to move into all three
in this one turn as we do see some
smiles happening here as we if we move
into all three in one turn he could win
from this position right here right now
as well. Rice here as this game is
fantastic. I'm loving the the longevity
of it. I'm loving the tech that we're
seeing out of Rengar Bots's Rengar deck.
>> It's so much stuff going on. So many
maths. So many numbers. I don't know if
anybody comes to these regionals with a
simple calculator, but I wouldn't be
surprised if seeing this game, it feels
somewhat like needed cuz I mean you can
use pen and paper of course with your
maths, but so much math is going on
right now.
>> For numbers this high, I think you need
a scientific calculator, the sign, the
cause, the tan, all that sort of stuff.
Yes, I did physics. What are you talking
about? But that was getting real
complicated. I'm really glad that we
have a judge on hand for all of these
featured tables because I I think it's
very very critical that with every step
further that you take that it's tracked
accurately, correctly, and well, and in
fairness to your opponent, too. Because
right now, you've got to remember this
is unleash. This is set three. Your
opponent is not as familiar with your
deck as you will be because you've been
practicing that. Yeah. And game one uh
that ended. It was 2-1.
>> Wow. Yeah, it has ended. Of course, this
is a uh one of the our second feature
match. So, we do have the results. It is
going to be Rangabot who does take that
second game. It's one at the moment, but
there's not much time left in the uh in
the round. So, I'm not sure if it's it
is going to be a tie as the final
results.
>> Fantastic. So, a fantastic tie there
from Rengarbot and Xiho. And we'll be
right back after this break.
Welcome to Riftbound Basics featuring
runes. In the Riftbound TCG, your energy
to play cards comes automatically. Each
player brings their own rune deck
consisting of 12 cards. This consists of
runes in the domains of your legend. A
Draven deck, for example, can play chaos
and fury runes. At the start of your
turn, immediately after you have readied
all your cards and received points for
holding a battlefield, you may play the
top two cards from your rune deck. You
need runes to pay the energy and power
costs on your cards. For example, for
Victor Leader, you must pay four energy,
which means exhausting four runes of any
color and then pay a power cost. You do
this by placing a rune of the color
shown under the energy cost at the
bottom of your rune deck. This process
is also called recycling. Some cards
such as Seal of Insight have no energy
cost but do have a power cost. However,
to ensure your energy isn't lost, you
may float the energy. That is, exhaust
your runes, place them under your rune
deck, and later use the energy gained to
play another card. Consequently, power
costs have no effect on the current turn
in which you play the cards, but can
have a significant impact on subsequent
turns as you are constantly playing with
fewer runes. How do you like your runes
best in Riftbound? Do you prefer them
furious and chaotic or rather calm and
orderly?
We're here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Sydney 2026 and we're
going to take you for a tour of the
showgrounds. Let's go.
So, the first step on our journey to the
Sydney Showgrounds is here. This is the
badge collection, where you will start
your Riftbound journey in Sydney 2026.
Make sure you get all of your promo
cards and your playmats.
Enough you've got your badges. Don't
forget to get your merch here. We have a
full merch wall as well as statues,
playmats, and more for your riffbound
enjoyment.
So, you've got your badge, you've found
your way past the merch wall, and you
are inside the showgrounds. Now, don't
forget to come to registration where the
friendly and helpful staff will make
sure you are signed up for all of the
events that you want to play.
So, now that you've registered, you'll
be wanting to earn tickets for the prize
wall. Don't forget there are some unique
prizes you can earn here which include
the metal prize wall tickets. But we
also have some oversized battlefields as
well as the Riftbound regional qualifier
Sydney pin.
But it's not all about competitive
events here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Sydney. We also have some
free play areas where you and some
friends can just get together and play
some games. We also have cosplayers
roaming the halls to bring the magic of
League of Legends and Riftbound to life
here today. And we also have some
creator activations where you'll find
some content creators putting forward
their best content for you to enjoy.
For your competitive viewing pleasure,
if you're knocked out early or side
events were your jam, we also have a
schedule where you can come and enjoy
the competitive scene here with the big
screen and the chairs behind me as well.
It's a viewing platform for everyone to
enjoy. And if you've forgotten any cards
you need for your decks at the regional
Riftbound qualifiers in Sydney, the
vendors have you sorted. With more than
six different vendors, they'll have you
covered, including signed overnights.
A new addition at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifier Sydney is the signature wall.
Don't forget to get down here and check
it out and maybe sign it just like I
have.
At the Riftbound Regional Qualifier
Sydney 2026, you'll also find side
events. We have a little something for
everyone from 2v2s, trios, sealed, and
preconstructed fights. You'll find it
all here in the side event area. Here at
the Riftbound Regional Qualifiers in
Sydney, we even have the featured
tables. This is where we will see the
best of the best Riftbound players in
the world come together to fight it out
for the regional championship. And on to
Worlds. And here we find ourselves at
the main event. This is where all of the
action happens. These players will be
fighting for best of cards. They'll be
vying for the second day gameplay and to
hit those featured tables. But more
importantly, they've come here to win it
all. And for all of you hungry gamers,
do not forget we also have three food
trucks parked out the back, including
some of our personal favorites, the
pizza. Make sure you check that out on
your breaks between games.
So, that's the Riftbound regional
qualifiers for Sydney 2026. You've seen
it all. You've got the tour. If you're
not here, then where the bloody hell are
you?
>> Hello and welcome back to coverage of
regional qualifier Sydney. We're about
to kick off round number two. My name is
Julian Patan Car. That is Steph Hannah
Casio. Hello.
>> Welcome to the desk.
>> Thank you for having me. It's nice to be
here.
>> I didn't really do anything. I just
showed up. They put me in here and then
put a microphone on me and here we are.
>> There we go. Ready to go.
>> This should be a fun one. Uh Sydney,
obviously my hometown. Lovely,
beautiful, wonderful place that you
should all be at playing Riftbound. But
this set is extremely exciting.
Unleashed has done quite a lot to the
metag game.
>> Absolutely. I'm really, really excited
to see how people are making their decks
considering it's only been like a week.
That's crazy. To be able to come to this
point and be ready to go and have
everything all ready in your mind for
whatever matchup you end up getting. I I
mean it's it's wild.
>> Well, I know our players are getting
ready, so we can have a little peeky
perhaps at the feature match area as our
players are getting settled. And I also
happen to know what matchup we will be
getting. Uh it'll be I think one of the
most common decks in the room, although
we haven't had the metag game breakdown
just yet versus what I'm going to say
one of the least common. Should be
Leblanc versus Ivvern. It's going to be
our round two match up.
>> I think you might be right on that one.
I I can't imagine there will be a huge
Ivvern showing, but Leblanc definitely
going to be a dominant presence more
than likely. So, it'll be interesting to
see how they shape up together.
>> Yeah, haven't seen the metag game just
yet. Very excited to bring the alt to
suit you once we have the numbers all
crunched and solidified, but based on
the preview yesterday, Leblanc was the
most represented deck and certainly I
think of the unleashed legends is the
deck people have been most excited
about, which is funny because these
domains haven't been particularly good
>> since Origins.
>> Yeah, look, it's it's about time to turn
that around, but you're right. It's it's
definitely been one of the more
predominant decks. And ironically, as we
said, Ivan, I feel like yesterday had
such a small showing comparatively.
We'll see how that ends up coming
together. Now,
>> now the the people do know I love Leona,
and Leona obviously resides in the calm
and order domains. And look, Leona
hasn't had uh the best showing at the
regional qualifier level. you can say
she failed to make day two uh for almost
every regional qualifier until Lil and
the French rallied around Leona and she
managed to make it to day two for the
first time ever in I think I don't know
six RQs or something given she's an
Origins legend. So, you know, not
looking so hot perhaps for where Ivan
does reside as far as domains go. But
perhaps Ivan is the take on the
archetype that uh really the domains
needed to at least win round two.
>> Well, look, if Leil was good for Leona,
maybe Sydney will be good for Ivan.
Who's to say at this point? We will uh
we will have to find out as it unfolds.
Look, I'm really really excited to see
how they come up together. It will
definitely be an interesting one, I
think.
>> Yeah, it should be. I mean, we'll talk a
little bit more about the legends as we
get in cuz these are going to be two new
ones on stream. Leblanc though, I think
one of the reasons people are so excited
is just because uh I don't know, card
game players just really like value, and
that's basically what Leblanc screams.
>> Mhm. 100%. And look, I'm really excited
to see a lot of those death nail
triggers go off. It's going to be fun.
I'm excited to see how it match m
matches up. So,
>> look, I think given that people are so
new to these champions, it will be very
very curious to me how they pilot
together. I don't know. I I my instinct
is that it will be potentially very uh
let's say heavy on one side, but I mean,
look, who's to say? It's anyone's game
at this point.
>> Yeah, it depends on the build. I guess
at a high level just thinking about how
these decks are generally built. There
are relatively versatile. Ivan I think a
little more narrow. You tend to I mean
you kind of the card does tell you to
play dogs, cats, pors and birds and
there are only so many of those. Pora is
obviously pretty popular units
especially early on but the rest of them
>> not so good. I can tell you given that
I've looked at all of them in my times
of brewing with Ivvern. But the Blanc
you can do a number of different things
but both these decks kind of feel like
they fall into the I want to do
something mid-rangy.
wants to get a lot of value, really use
her reflections to get a lot of
different death note triggers and acrew
value. And Ivan's just kind of like,
well, if I ever take a battlefield, not
only do I turn off your battlefield with
my legend ability, but I turn it into a
brush, which for Ivvern is kind of a
one-sided Trafarian war camp, given how
good that battlefield is,
>> pretty powerful thing to be doing, but
is it enough to overcome the uh the
endless value trend that the Blanc could
potentially generate? I guess we'll find
out.
>> Look, I think either way, it is safe to
say we are going to be seeing a lot of
tokens in this game. There is going to
be a lot on both sides and it will be
Oh, look, I think you're right when you
say mid-range. I think it's it's going
to be one of those ones where it could
really really shift moment to moment.
>> Yeah, a little soupy perhaps as far as
this matchup goes. Also kind of
interesting to see how many spells
players want to play. I think Leblanc
has a bit more balance, but Ivvern kind
of incentivized to play a lot of units
because you get so many rewards for
playing them. I do think we'll see
something like flurry of feathers which
has been a pretty interesting new
unleash card that can uh kind of do an
ambush impression at times especially if
there's a piece of brush as more birds
and you can shake a stick at shooting
out of that spell every now and then but
Leblanc I mean you do get a lot of
different options even something like
call the week which is kind of order's
uh classic removal spell uh can be quite
good even if it's symmetrical because
sometimes you kill a death nail unit
that you wanted to remove anyway.
>> Exactly. It's it's really just uh
exactly what you kind of want to fulfill
there. But I mean, look, I if I can if
you can permit me to be a little basic
for just one moment, I will say I really
like watching Ivan because it just like
>> cuteness, aggression is just everything
to me. And seeing all those cats, dogs,
porros, it's Oh, I'm I'm here for it.
>> Yep. Smothered by cats. That's what Ivan
is going to want to try and get done in
this one. And Leblanc, I don't know.
Just got a card, make a reflection, and
uh see what happens. But we should be
seeing a lot of new cards, I guess, if
you're tuning in seeing like, you know,
what is happening in Unleash these days.
But we'll probably show you quite a few
new unleashed cards in this round given
that it's two unleashed legends that we
haven't had on stream just yet. And even
though we do expect to see a decent
amount of Leblanc as kind of the event
moves forward, I don't know how much I
burn will see the deeper we get into the
tournament. So, good thing we're here in
round two getting it on stream nice and
early.
>> Absolutely. I mean, look, I'm excited to
see. We'll uh whether or not we do see
more down the line remains to be seen,
but for now, I'm I'm just keen to see
how it plays out. I haven't been able to
see a lot of play with Iburn lately. So,
look, let's go for it. I mean, I'm I'm
very very excited to see how each of
these players are going to pilot it just
to figure out what is going to set the
tone, I suppose, for the rest of the
weekend. Now, I'm not an expert, but I
have been observing everyone in the
feature match areas, our players, and of
course, our wonderful judges that are
making this event run uh smoothly as
they can. It's not easy moving, 1600
people around event hall. I don't know
if you know this, but uh the funny thing
is I see the players pointing at each
other and I see them kind of looking at
their headsets and perhaps uh perhaps
there's some issues through resolve. I
am no stranger to this from the League
of Legends side. Uh you would not
believe what a professional player can
do to a headset in a matter of seconds.
Sometimes they just stop working and uh
shut it eventually uh it gets resolved
but every now and then you have a tech
check even uh even sometimes even in a
physical card game sometimes the
technology doesn't work.
>> Look technology a friend a foe somewhere
in between wants to say realistically
again moment to moment could be
different.
>> Uh thinking more about this match up as
well I'm curious about what chosen
champions these players want to play. I
think the more expensive order I has
been kind of the standard. It's uh very
good on conquer or hold. Gives you a way
to maybe get some extra points, steal a
win from now on and there. I do think
Leblanc is also probably what most of
the Leblancs want to play, but I do
think there is certainly a choice there
cuz the uh the mind one is very powerful
if you can let it stick.
>> Look, I think either way can be very
successful depending on how you're
piloting it. I'm I'm intrigued to see. I
think you're right on Ivan, but look, I
mean, realistically, I don't know that
we will see that much in the way of Ivan
like you said before. So, I I hope that
we Oh, okay. Actually,
>> let's do some learning, shall we?
>> Let's have a look.
>> This is Hanzu, our Ivan player. It is uh
Ivan Printo all as the expected chosen
champion and kind of what you expect
along here. A couple flurry of feathers,
couple friendships, bunch of uh cats and
dogs alongside their poro friends, and
even some birds. So, soaring scout,
trusty ram hound and mutated mouse are
kind of filling out your early drops and
then uh the big ones if you will, which
are you know this deck not so big. Uh
ultra soft power kind of a fun one if
you can get it on board and stick that
can make a ton of birds quite swiftly.
Other than that uh Vmore kind of at the
top end alongside Vi who's been a pretty
powerful unit. I think a lot of
different auto decks have been drawn to
VI peacekeeper as a unit they can play
but uh a lot of just very value ccentric
stuff. Again, we expected mid-range and
we've certainly gotten mid-range.
>> Absolutely. And like there's there's
necessities really. We've got the
defies. We've got some hidden blade. It
it just makes sense, I think, that this
would be the setup that you'd go with.
>> Yeah, makes sense. See if we can have a
look at the other side cuz again,
Leblanc certainly a bunch of different
uh options you can go down. Lots of path
for you to kind of move through.
>> Have a look at our Leblanc players deck.
Let's see what they've got. Brewing.
>> Not yet.
>> Little tease for you.
>> Remain in suspense. The anticipation.
>> All right. We'll have a quick squeeze
then, shall we? It is breaking Sydney.
Hey, I don't like that.
>> Keep Sydney in one piece, please. But it
is Leblanc everywhere once. It is not in
fact Leblanc fragmenter. Although there
are three copies of it in the main,
which as you might expect, three copies
of mirror image sacrifice certainly been
one of the better tools that order has
received. I think a lot of players that
might like these domains have been
looking towards the new unleash card
thinking, you know what, it does kind of
feel like things are working better. But
as expected, uh basically a bunch of
cars and then a bunch of things that are
good with Karthus in this deck.
>> Absolutely right. And obviously we do
have the thousand tailed watcher that is
kind of inevitable. Uh but no, it it all
tends to make a lot of sense along the
lines. I I think having I mean look
sprite fountain good to see. Very
excited to see a lot of these cards.
>> Has a death knob as it turns out. Pretty
good one as well. Maybe not doing quite
as much making quite as much use of that
card as maybe say Lilia would see later
in the day. Certainly hope so as we try
and get I think as many unleashed
legends as possible on the stream in the
early rounds. And uh we're doing all
right so far. Gotten two new ones
already and two new ones once again in
uh what two and a half games or so.
Going to kick things off. It's Hansu on
the play. Going to be playing old trusty
Ramhound. That's our Ivan player on the
left. Breaking Sydney again. Don't
really like what that implies but do
like the deck they're playing here in
the blanc. So they're going to go
channel up three runes and put something
on the table. Honest broker. not so
honest its outp especially when Carthus
gets involved.
>> Yeah, not so much. Uh it's interesting
to see battlefields we've got Sigil of
the Storm and Dust Bros Lab makes a lot
of sense for both. We will uh have to
see how that plays out.
>> Yeah, Sid was a fun one for Ivan. Again,
Ivan has the power to turn off uh any
battlefield and kind of make it a
one-way street. And I think turning off
Dusk Grow Lab feels really good here.
That's why you want these early units.
Ivan immediately going to get exhausted
and that will get turned into a brush.
So, Ramhound right now is a three might
unit chilling at the lab. And more
importantly, the lab is off, which uh
that's real bad news for Leblanc.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Not ideal, but I mean, look,
at this point, I it makes sense to try
and try and snipe that one out, I think.
>> And again, a sigil, you can turn off as
well if you feel like you don't want to
keep having that effect happen.
Although, it is a bit more interesting
because you do have to do the effect
when you first go there, even though you
can stack your conquer triggers. I
believe you still have to pay for sigil,
although I could actually have the
interaction slightly wrong. as it is
though reinforced down to that bottom
battlefield which is now a brush. Frisky
Hunter one of the better turn two plays
out of Ivone not only is a three might
cap but makes a one might burden. If you
add those together well that's four but
if you add the brush pump all of a
sudden six might just for more energy.
>> Quite a little bit more oppressive
there. And also if I may say once more
again a little bit basic but really cute
>> very cute.
>> So cute and dangerous but hey the
cuteness is still there.
>> Yep. I think uh for everyone at home, if
you're playing against Ivan, just
remember to do the math properly. When
there's a brush there, don't just add
the numbers up. Uh make sure to add plus
one for each other unit as well. So 3,
four, five, six, plus seven for the ram
hound having a friend. Plus three,
that's 10 might on that brush right now.
So honest broker understandably going to
have to go to the other side of the map.
And uh turns out sigil not such a fun
place to go having to recycle rune even
though breaking Sydney grabs a point
after playing Mixologist. Maybe not so
happy with what happens. And this uh
call the week is going to look Oh, never
mind. It got discarded. That makes more
sense. We're making a honest broker
reflection.
>> Oh, look. It's good to see the
reflection start. I'm keen to see more
of those as we proceed.
>> So, again, little temporary unit would
have been great at the lab. Get yourself
a little card draw out of the deal cuz
the temporary unit's going to go away
anyway.
>> But a couple points here for Ivon. Two
already thanks to the conquer plus hold.
And of course, one on the other side for
Leblanc as two runes get channeled and
Hanzu going to go ahead and figure
something out as players are just
deciding where they want to place their
things. very important in any card game
to make sure your table is laid out. So
a backoff draw your vial more as well.
So plenty of good options for holding on
to the battlefields which is kind of the
thing these domains do.
>> Yeah, look it is definitely worth trying
at the very least. But no, I I love an
organized board state. I think by all
means take the time do a little bit of
you know
>> little housekeeping
>> rearranging housekeeping make it nice.
>> Getting spicy with it as it were. Ivvern
friends are all going to reinforce and
you get to choose a tag. Ivvern grabs
that tag. They already have bird, dog,
and cat. And wouldn't you know it, I
don't know exactly, but I'm willing to
bet that Ivvern is a porro.
>> Almost definitely.
>> And of course, the reason you want to do
that is when I conquer or hold, you
score one point if your units have all
of the following tags among them. Bird,
cat, dog, and poro. Notably, Ivvern also
is Ivvern, and Brush does also point to
Ivvern as one of the tags it cares about
pumping. I actually don't know if that
means if Ivan gets plus two might or not
cuz I've never thought about it until
literally right this second.
>> You know what? I'm actually not sure.
It's
>> a fun thing for us to discover later as
break and Sydney going to awaken
everything and have a little trigger in
the beginning phase is that temporary
honest broker. It's going to go the way
of the dodo.
>> Looks like we are putting something on
the chain cuz he can play reactions. Not
just yet and decides to let it go.
Reflection goes away. gold gets
generated and a little bit of value
along with the point that you get for
holding. So, so far so good as far as
the point total goes, but I did manage
to go first, get the points on early.
And of course, with all of those units
stacked up on that battlefield, not only
is that a lot of might just being held
there in that bottom side, but all the
tags are currently fulfilled for Ivvern,
which means if you don't move in and try
and break out, I don't know, maybe that
little birdie that's flying around, I's
going to get two points, one for holding
and one bonus one for being Ivvern.
Yeah, look, I mean, it's a very, very
strong start building that. And look,
it's when it comes down to it, a lot of
this is going to come down to tempo and
it come down to really making sure that
you're addressing those more aggressive
uh plays down to uh look, I mean,
looking at that, let's be real, it's
it's dominating. It's it's very much a
uh a concerning force, and you want to
make sure that you're addressing that as
early as possible.
>> There's a carus, which is usually very
good news for the Leblanc players,
doubling those death nails. So,
Mixologist can maybe get two units back.
broker could make yourself two gold. Bad
news right now. Uh there is nothing for
the mixologist to go and grab. Temporary
units do not end up in your trash in
your bin.
>> I can I could actually see breaking
Sydney just kind of like thinking about
moving the mixologist in which doesn't
feel great. It would get a few units but
there's no death now you would get but
which feels extra dragged with the carus
but you kind of feel like you know what
do I have to just run a unit in and
break up these tags? Can I really
realistically let you score two points a
turn when I'm already behind in this
race? Look, I think economically you
can't really afford not to, but I mean
it's it's still a gamble either way.
>> All right, move in, move out. Honestro,
sorry. Mixol just goes in, occupies the
sigil, honest broker moves out. Does
mean you don't actually reconquer the
battlefield, which means you don't have
to recycle yet another rune. So, it
seems like a pretty reasonable thing to
do, but Ivan off to the races. A bunch
of might and two extra points. They're
up to four already for Hanzu as we are
going to awaken our runes.
>> Look, I I won't lie to you. I I was not
expecting such an explosive start from
Ivan, but I'm really really quite
impressed. I think it's one of those
ones where you really do need to start
aggressively and especially playing
against Leblanc. My goodness, I you want
to really establish that as soon as
possible.
>> Leblanc start hasn't felt all that good.
Kind of drawing the pieces in a bit of a
desperate manner, right? Karthus with no
death nails that you really want to use
doesn't feel great. Uh maybe not the
early removal to try and get a unit.
Although again, Carl doesn't necessarily
do a whole lot of work when there's a
bunch of tokens being made, even though
it would potentially break up the board.
Looks like Hanzu is just saying, you
know what, I'm just explaining how
Ivvern goes. I think players are
checking that all the tags are there.
Certainly should be given that it's
Bird, Cat, Dog plus one, and Ivvern can
fulfill whatever one is missing. And
again, Breaking Sydney, little read cuz
again, it's early on in the RQ and you
maybe haven't seen this card before.
>> Absolutely. And with only a week since
Unleash, I mean, look, there's there's
also every chance that they haven't
played a match up like this before.
There's there's not a lot of opportunity
between that week to be able to get to
it. And I mean, I don't know that they
necessarily would have predicted this
matchup in the leadup to it. So,
>> got to be ready for anything.
>> Who knows?
>> I earn friend to all, but not to your
opponents.
>> Exactly. Right.
>> Little might check there on the bottom
battlefield. 6 7 8 9 10 + 2 is 12 + one
from the ramound is 13 plus at least
four thanks to the brush that's still
there. That is 17. And I still don't
know if Ivan double dips on brush or
not. So 17 or 18, which again pretty
tough to break through. And you can
potentially move on over and just pick
off a bird or two. That's only two
might, which would stop Ivan from doing
all of that work. but doesn't feel great
to run your unit into a battlefield
where there's nothing but uh a little
bit of a trade happening.
>> Look, I mean, at this point, you have to
wonder if the gamble would be worth it,
though. Because look, that whether it's
17 or 18, that is just truly a a huge
force to contend with.
>> All right, breaking Sydney awaken. See
if it can solve some problems cuz uh
Hanzu is passing back over and we are
going to start with a little cull.
Oh, it's actually never mind. It's a
little bong trigger. When I conquer or
hold, you may discard one and exhaust me
to play a ready reflection unit token.
There you can see. Oh, just checking.
Nope, wasn't actually being played. The
bird was ready to move to the bin, but
it is actually another mixologist. So,
can we get another unit in to the
graveyard in this turn cycle? Maybe try
and get some value out of this Leblanc
>> cuz again, just on points right now,
>> dramatically losing the rest to this
Ivan on a single battlefield.
>> 100% 100% there. There needs to be some
significant change here if if they want
to have a a decent shot at regaining
that ground. But look,
it it's still a question of making that
risk assessment and it's not easy to do
in the moment, especially not easy to do
when you're fresh to a new champion. It
is. Look, I I don't envy them. I'll say
that much.
>> So, what do you think of uh Zunicord
Vilemore?
>> You had a had a go with that one yet? I
I haven't had a go with it myself, but
I've certainly come up against it. And
look, in that situation, not so much of
a fan. I think if I was piloting, maybe
a little bit of a different story, but
uh when I'm coming up against it, less
inclined to be
>> I just want to point out that that is
one of the newer bigger jungle monsters
that came out and unleashed. And it does
cost eight and two calm power. And that
just happens to be how many runes Hanzu
has open. And right now it does seem
like Breaking Sydney is considering
moving in and trying to at least cut the
uh cut the army of dogs, cats, poros,
and birds just down a little bit to at
least break up uh the Ivvern's kind of
extra point gain. So you are going to
play Leblanc fragmented. This one uh
when I die, draw a card. Sometimes you
draw quite a few cards actually,
especially if you make a reflection. If
it's your beginning phase, you draw two
instead. And well, that is uh happens to
be when temporary units do go away.
Reflections are temporary units, so you
can kind of see where the value comes
from with LeBlanc.
>> Absolutely. Look, it's it's one of those
ones I'm really excited to see how they
try and unfold from here.
>> But again, Bmore is kind of I was
alluding to does have ambush. So, uh,
Bore has a lot of text on it. Uh, eight
might is one of them in the top right
corner. Ambush is another keyword on it.
When I hold draw a card, pretty nice bit
of text. Kind of like a little personal
grove of the godwillow. Mhm.
>> But uh the other one is uh units here,
enemy units here with less might than me
don't deal combat damage.
>> Just a little bit important to include
that one. I think
>> feels kind of bad if you may be thinking
about moving in and doing a little bit
of a value trade, but no, he just pass
it back instead. And I think Hanu might
be SL. Nope. Immediately goes to get the
points.
>> Wants to hold on to the trick for later.
By the way, if you if you didn't know, I
do know there's a viol.
I'm not I'm not just doing all this
setup for nothing. I do know that
there's one there waiting. out when you
are playing to hold a single battlefield
two points at a time
>> in a deck that is known for its uh
pretty good uh spells especially in the
in the reaction step feels like a decent
thing to do. And the other thing about
Ivvern that's kind of fun is that well
Ivvern
>> just cares about holding or conquering
the battlefield.
>> Absolutely.
>> And does want to see all those tags to
get the extra point but those tags don't
have to be with Ivvern. They could be
anywhere as long as they're somewhere in
play another battlefield in your base. I
don't know maybe hiding out in your
opponent's side for some reason.
Although you do have to control them, so
that doesn't actually work. But as long
as they're around, as long as you have
dog, cat, bird, porro,
>> just a managerie all over.
>> Yep. As long as you have the Hanzu.
>> Mhm.
>> You are going to be good to go.
>> Oh no,
>> there's loyal porro.
>> A little uh little upgrade, I suppose,
from Lonely Porro. At least this one
wants friends. If I didn't die alone,
draw one. A much more jubilant piece of
text than poor lonely porro. When I die
alone, draw one. The inevitability of
the lonely porro is just so rough. But
yes, loyal porro again just a very very
cute card which is lovely. Uh this whole
deck just every single time you see the
art it's just ah and then it's a little
bit oh when you realize actually this is
more dominant than I expected especially
in this matchup right now.
>> So we can do maybe a little bit of math
actually right now looking on breaking
Sydney's side is going to get a
reflection notably because uh of course
there is going to be a hold happening.
So turn passes back point gets gained up
to four. But that mixologist is going to
go by and once again did not put a uh an
eligible unit into the bin to recur with
the mixologist despite having a carus as
well. So you're going to get the point
going to lose your mixologist and is
going to have an opportunity to make yet
another reflection if you want. But it's
currently 3 6 7 8 might between the
Leblanc, the Carthus, and the uh and the
broker. And there is 67 plus at least
two nine might on the Ivvern
battlefield. And again, I might remind
you that moving the units back here
actually looks pretty good because if
you hold for a point where you go to
seven, even if Ivan doesn't give you the
bonus point, then if you can just go
ahead and score the other battlefield,
even if it's just a lone bird that did
the work for you, then it's probably
going to be pretty straightforward to
win this game and pick up a very clean
win in game number one. But of course,
if Ivan does stick around and score
those last two points, if the tags do
stick around, then uh yeah, that's just
going to be game of a single battlefield
here for Ivan.
>> Yeah, impressive. I mean, how often do
you think one single bird can really
make that much of a difference?
>> Well, we left it there for a reason. So,
I think Hanzu believes that that one
bird is going to be quite the difference
maker, leaving up quite a few runes as
well. Not quite eight, that should be
seven by man count. So, we are safe from
the giant monster Vmore, but plenty of
other tricks perhaps as ruined Rex,
which is really good when you get a
death nail. Cost six though, cost of
power. And uh if you can't get that
death nail happening right now, going to
be maybe tough to get stuff done. Is
there something else behind this ruined
Rex?
>> Intrigued.
>> Here's something. Looks suspiciously
like call the week. It is not. It is
death grip. That one's pretty good.
>> Mhm.
>> Get yourself a death nail. Give might
over to yet another unit. Death nail
also going to happen twice thanks to
Carus.
>> Absolutely. This look I think with this
setup I I mean where would you be going?
What would you be doing in this context?
I I was going to say something and then
breaking Sydney immediately pointed to
Ivan twice. So that is where those two
ruined Rex death nails are going again
trying to break up the problem as Hanu
is just saying how much damage is it?
It's four twice that would be eight.
Ivan currently is at least a seven
>> and I did see friendship
>> in Hanzu's hand. So might be wanting to
just pump as uh I think players just
clarifying what order things were
happening in. But Ruin Rex is going to
happen after the death grip resolves.
Death Grip should have made another unit
bigger as well. Not sure which one just
yet, but can only make one unit bigger
as uh consult the hand here quickly for
Ivan. And looks like friendship I'm sure
going to be brought to the top of the
hand.
Pretty neat little ong guard on Meow as
I call it. The discipline though.
Classic pumpkin.
>> Interesting.
>> Make the Ivvern bigger. Protect him from
ruin Rex. And there's a bunch of damage
marked on this Ivvern. see if that
matters at all because again if this
combat cleanup happens that Ivan's going
to get all their health back.
>> Oh goodness.
>> All right, so resolve draws a card.
Breaking Sydney also pretty all in at
this point. Not sure which unit got big.
It looks like Honest Broker is the one
that gets plus six might thanks to that
death grip that started this whole
train. But uh there is a hidden card
under this battlefield and we may have
mentioned it earlier but back off.
Pretty nice new card from Unleashed that
could throw a spanner or two into the
works.
I think both players are just going to
mark the damage here on the Ivvern as
well.
And it's minus minus four twice.
>> So, uh six at least 79. So, it's at
least one one or two might for Ivvern
right now. So, doesn't take much.
>> Yeah.
>> To get it done, but will take some
>> more vulnerable position there.
>> And uh plenty of runes ready as well.
discipline. Also drew a new card. Did
pay for discipline. Good uh good work.
Make sure your opponents do pay for
their spells.
>> All right, look. Math being done.
>> I mean, we you don't even need to be
able to see Leblanc's hand at this point
to to figure out what's going on cuz uh
you're just going to have to run some
stuff in and hope it works. And
unfortunately,
given the spell that uh we highly
suspect is under that brush. Yeah, look
>> without anything else. I don't think
this attack certainly not two units in
work. Maybe all three, but Carus is
going to join in the party. So, what's
going to happen?
>> See how this goes.
>> All right, so that one's big. That one's
an eight. I would like to stun that one.
Back off, buddy.
>> Back off.
>> You're stunned.
>> And then sixmite currently playing, I
believe, five.
>> There is the friendship.
>> That's a bit more.
>> Yeah,
>> friendship if you don't know. Fun one.
It's kind of like on guard, but instead
of the units being alone, it simply
counts all the tags you have between
dog, cat, bird, and borrow. I don't know
how many times I can say those words in
a single game of Brit. But uh if you
have all if you get plus one for each of
them, and currently uh four is quite a
lot. So, it's going to be plus four and
the stun. And that's going to be it.
Breaking Sydney scoops them up and
Ivvern gets our first win on stream.
>> Impressive. I look, I can't say that's
how I I thought this would unfold, but
I'm I'm very very impressed by this.
Look, I love to see friendship be the
the real turning point there. Look, uh,
who doesn't love making friends, first
of all, but like in this context, I feel
like it's a it's a positive way to be
deeply oppressive, you know?
>> I mean, I think that game is about as
good as Ivan could have asked for. Going
first, had a two drop, which to be fair,
they have a lot of different two drops
and they all have relevant tags. got on
Battlefield first, managed to conquer
it, make a brush, played a Frisky
Hunter, which is probably easily your
best four energy unit you can follow up
with, and then just Leblanc did not have
a draw that came together quickly
enough. So, just felt comfortable to
slam the Ivvern on three,
>> and all of a sudden it was two points a
turn the entire game.
>> Look, I mean, with that many units,
there's a lot of value for Ivvern. So,
I'm I'm not surprised that he was able
to get that out quite so early, but
yeah, look, a really impressive showing.
I think it will be very very interesting
to see how it goes on the draw this time
around for Leblanc and see if maybe
that'll change things up a little bit
for breaking Sydney.
>> I think also just nice to see that you
know hold is a viable uh strategic
avenue opened up perhaps unleash adding
so much support. I think the Ahri
players from Origins were screaming for
a way for green Ahri to do anything. It
felt like holding those battlefields and
the dream is realized by not a cat and
not a fox cat lady but by a tree man.
>> Look, I also think it's very interesting
to have gone for the lab first up and
really taking that opportunity away from
Breaking Sydney. I think it was a smart
play.
>> Yeah.
>> So yeah, look, I can't fault it. I
really can't. I think with the way that
game played out and I'm curious what
Hanzu's other battlefields are because
we might we might see a theme here. My
goal because Ivan again Ivan's so good
at turning off battlefields and there's
maybe two schools of thought, right? You
can play battlefields that do good
things when you conquer them. And so you
can take the battlefield, get the
positive conquer effect, turn it into a
brush, and then try and turn it off for
your opponent for the rest of the game.
Cuz even if they move back in to conquer
it, it just turns back into what it was
before and you don't get a chance to get
the conquer trigger. The other school of
thought is I'm just going to play the
most oppressive battlefield I can think
of on my side and just take your
battlefield and turn it off. So then you
never get the benefit of yours and if
you want to do anything that game, which
we even saw in game one, having to
conquer Sid of the Storm multiple times,
>> like
>> if you feel confident that your deck can
win off one battlefield, which based on
the strategy presented seems like
something that Ivan can do,
>> then splitting the map in a way where
your opponent just does not ever want to
go to the other side when their
battlefield doesn't work. Yeah,
>> pretty good.
>> Look, it it puts the onus back on your
your opponent to figure out how to work
around it. I'm I think honestly when it
comes down to it, I I would gravitate
more to making them have to make those
tough decisions every single day of the
week. So, yeah, look, it'll be
interesting to see what they opt for
this time around.
>> Pretty sure it's rock for path. Did spot
in the deck list and I can just barely
make out the art. Uh that one is a fun
one. units can't be played here,
>> which uh can be a bit awkward for Ivan.
Ivan does like to play units there, but
again, if it's a brush, don't have to
worry about it.
>> Exactly.
>> Which turns into a one-sided Tfrarian
war camp.
>> Not always. Some other people have many
many other players have poros. Some
other players have dogs. Basically, no
one else has cats and birds.
>> Yeah,
>> unless you make an errant bird token
every now and then. I guess a zir
actually is a bird, which is kind of
fun.
>> Technically speaking, yes, you're
absolutely right. Look, I've I I've I've
uh
>> I've done some cooking, we can say.
>> Oh, really?
>> Yeah. No one wants to see that deck.
>> Interesting. Let me guess. Uh
>> yeah, you don't have to guess.
>> No, I think
>> No, you already know.
>> Yeah, we all know exactly what you've
got in there.
>> Yeah, I call the hook father.
>> Inevitable.
>> All right, so Windswep windswept Hill is
the battlefield of choice here for
Breaking Sydney. Units here have ganking
a classic of origins, especially for
everyone's uh Dave Goskin's best friend,
Yasawo. And it is Rockfall Park on
Hanzu's side. units can't be played
here.
>> Sometimes the brain does the thing it's
supposed to do.
>> Breaking Sydney looks to the sky.
Mulligan's two and thinks about life
choices like registering Leblanc at an
event
>> going going 1 to start things off and
then running into this tree.
>> Yeah. Look, again, I just I truly don't
think that uh well, I don't want to
speak for Breaking Sydney, but if I was
in their position, there is not a lot of
prep that I would have done specifically
for Ivan. And it'll be interesting to
see how they've sideboarded against it
to see what's going on here. Look, the
mulligan is not ideal, but what have we
got there?
>> Death Grip, Riptide, Rex, Sprite
Fountain, and one more going to the
bottom, so I don't have to worry about
them. Instead, it's Broker and Death
Grip. Not a bad two drop. Okay,
>> to kick things off, we'll channel two.
We'll play an honest broker. We'll pass
it on back. What you got, Tree Man?
Draw a card. Don't forget that one.
Honest broker. Go.
Green father, what have you got for us?
>> Apparently green runes.
>> Oops. All calm.
>> Trusty Ramhound.
>> That'll do it.
>> I believe that is a dog large enough to
ride like a horse.
>> Oh, and the best ones are.
>> That's I guess that's true. Yeah, you
can see there's a little in the art in
the bottom right. There's a little
actually quite a large man on top of
that plated dog. Honest broker going to
move into the hill, grab a point, and
Leblanc is going to be activated
immediately. Discard a card, make a
reflection. wouldn't mind another broker
is Mixolist moves onto the bin. Notably
not a unit that Mixolist itself can
recur.
>> Usually one of the ways Leblanc can get
all this value is by obviously using
those death nails and Leblanc usually
kind of does it all right. Not only
makes a copy of the unit that you might
want to use, but does also uh put units
in your bin that you can get back later
with your recursion. But this is an
extremely good start. That reflection
token enters ready, ganks on over thanks
to the hill giving the token ganking and
then Leblanc everywhere at once which
we'll have to give a read for the first
time today
>> is going to be reinforced to the hill.
>> Goodness me mate the complete opposite
kind of start from the first match.
>> Wow. Yeah, absolutely.
>> All right, so everywhere at once
backline I must be assigned combat
damage at last. This is a four might
four energy unit that doesn't have a
power class. Pretty good. Your temporary
units at my battlefield don't trigger.
And you may think, well, why didn't
Breaking Sydney reinforce to the other
side? Temporary units cannot actually
gain points because they will die before
the uh
>> before Yeah, before the scoring happens.
But I think the gold seems valuable
enough.
>> Ooh,
>> may have slightly misunderstood.
No, I think we got to three points.
>> Mhm.
>> Should be all right. Everything should
be above board here. Gold going to get
made. And that is apparently good enough
for breaking Sydney to leave the broker
at the helic with that Leblanc and also
Leblanc trigger going to happen as well.
But decides to say I'm good for now.
Maybe there's a better unit we can grab.
>> Hasn't scored the top battlefield yet.
So still an option here with the
Hillick, especially if we want to again
gank on over, which is fun. You wouldn't
necessarily expect Leblanc to make great
use of this battlefield, but turns out
when things enter ready. Uh you can get
quite a bit done here as ultra soft was
the turn two player I did just miss. And
that one is quite good at making a big
battlefield, but only when you can
activate it and has to be at a
battlefield to do so. So you can kind of
see the difference on going first versus
going second when both players have
ideal draws. As Honest Broker going to
roll on over for point number four,
never didn't have it.
>> A really really quick start. The tempo
in this is so so different to the last
time around and it's it it shows cuz
look I mean
one of these
I I love the Ultra Soft Pro, don't get
me wrong.
>> Very cute.
>> But having the capacity to just go in,
be ready. It's just at this point, look
at that. Look at that. It's just a lot.
>> Yeah. The nice thing is that temporary
units do hang out to at least defend
even though they can't score.
>> Mhm. So, looks like we did want to
consider making a reflection there, but
actually rolled that back a little.
Decided that actually I don't want to do
that right now. In fact, going all the
way back to
No. Okay, still ganking.
>> Mhm.
>> Looks like maybe the players are
consulting the table judge. But, uh, it
seemed like the intention there was
breaking CD to gank from Kilick with the
broker for the path and then, uh, make a
reflection token and copy the honest
broker once again. But we've rolled back
to scoring at the battlefield. So now
four points as a judge call is coming
up. Very curious what the players are
wanting to chitchat about.
>> Any gut instinct there.
>> Looked like a little rewind, which is
fine. You are allowed to rewind. It
looks like Breaking Sydney has rewind to
the point where they discarded a death
grip to make a reflection token. Maybe
thinking that they don't want to
actually make a reflection token.
>> I also Hang on a second.
Does Leblanc play units?
Because if if the reflection token is a
play, Rockfall path says you can't do
that.
>> Yeah. Yeah, you're not wrong. Actually,
>> that doesn't happen very often, but that
may be where the dodge call is.
>> Oh, I didn't even think of that.
>> I didn't either in talking.
>> Look, I mean, that would make a lot of
sense. I think that is probably the most
likely thing to have happened here, but
goodness, I none of us spotted it. So,
>> well, players figured it out now. Judge,
of course, is chatting to the players.
So, at that point, I mean, you don't
really want to make a copy of You could
make a copy of Leblanc everywhere at
once, I suppose.
>> I suppos I don't know that that's
necessarily what I would be wanting to
do, but look, best of a bad bunch
necessarily.
>> I mean, it's not
>> not necessarily a bad bunch,
>> but look, I think of the options, it
does make sense.
>> Yeah. I mean, also just choose to, you
know, not use your trigger, which I
think is fine. Maybe the rest of your
your hand is good. I mean, if you're
discarding a death grip, which was the
card that we saw,
>> not again, not a card that you really
want in your bin. Yeah.
>> Doesn't can't get it back with
mixologist. Uh not really like a spell
that you often want to hold on to to do
things with. So, I think there is a
level of like maybe just copying the
other unit makes a bit more sense cuz
everywhere it runs will keep temporary
copies of herself alive as long as
Leblanc is at the same battlefield. And
it gets really confusing cuz they do
share the text. So then you have to kill
all of the Leblancs to let all of the
shadow Leblancs
>> leave your battlefield. So if you're
trying to build a lot of might at a
single spot, maybe not a bad thing. And
as we can tell with this hill not being
easy to approach by Ivvern, there's kind
of a point where you're just
consistently getting two points a turn
at a very fast pace. And as we've noted
in game one, that is a pretty easy way
to win a game of
>> Look, it's it it turns into a bit of
Leblanc Seion at some point. It does. So
yeah, look, the it's chalk and cheese
from the first time around here.
We'll see what happens as players are
just consulting with the judges. I
imagine that's what it's about in all
fairness as we are going to get some
views of the tournament hall. If you
ever been to a car game event before, if
you're out here watching, uh, if you
having a squeeze and thinking, you know
what, looks kind of fun. I highly
recommend you come and hang out. Not
only did I meet a bunch of players
yesterday that were playing in the preq,
getting a little bit of practicing
before the regional qualifier today. Ton
of players who were were playing in the
main event were just playing in the 2v2
side event instead yesterday. decided
that would be a better use of their time
than a bit more practice.
>> Look, I mean, I think having a good
time, having a nice casual time before
you go into an event like this, it can
take the edge off a little bit. I don't
I don't fault it.
>> And again, I also did talk to a few
players who were happy with their deck
for the most part. Did pretty well and
uh expected to change a few cards.
Apparently, Alz changes like one or two
cards before deck submission. Uh like
like clockwork.
>> Can't ever settle on the last two. how
close to those last few minutes there
were people being like, "Oh, I don't
know."
>> So, deck lists also got extended, I
believe, to 10. Yeah. To 10:00 a.m.
today, which is right before the event
starts, which I think is actually pretty
common. I think that's been the cut off
for most events, although some events do
want to do it at midnight before. And,
uh, I do know there were a few players
scrambling to change things.
>> Absolutely.
>> Cuz I had a quick chat to the dealers
earlier today, and uh, they had quite a
few players in buying cards at about
9:30. Oh,
>> cutting it close.
All right, so we're back and dodge call
has been resolved. There is no
reflection right now, but ruined Rex has
found himself alongside Lanc on Hillick
and Honest Broker is big chilling over
on the rock wall path as we passed it
back. Ivan still with the puro and the
ram town. We're going to send five might
into the path and that is good enough
for a conquer. Ivan going to go ahead
and activate as well. And now units can
be played here because of now it's a
brush. It's not the rockfall path.
>> Are we going to see an influx of dogs,
cats, birds, and porros again?
>> We're halfway there. Ultra soft power
number two. Hidden blade, discipline,
back off, and a charm.
>> The most curious of these options here.
>> Interesting.
>> Might be trying to beckon Leblanc over
into the cuddly arms of Ultra Soft.
Porro
>> just teasing it over.
>> Seems to be the consideration. There's
the charm.
>> Mhm.
>> Hey, one recycle one pointed a unit.
Leblanc, hello. I'd like you to meet my
best friend, Ultra Soft Parro back, you
must apply damage last. Yep, you're the
only unit there. Goodbye, Leblanc.
>> Yep.
>> Pretty handy little removal spell, if
you will. Takes a couple extra steps,
but mostly the same thing for a single
energy and a single power. Certainly a
card we saw a lot of at the end of
Spirit Forge when all the calm players
realize that. Hang on, this spell's
pretty good.
>> Something this this has some has some
juice to it. Absolutely.
>> Look, when it works, it works.
>> Certainly does. Oh, and there's Ultra
Soft Porro, the second 12 might worth of
porro at the top battlefield. That is,
of course, now a brush and perhaps a
little bit more. We're going to put a
hidden card. This could be anything.
>> Mhm.
>> Actually, right now, it could actually
be one of two things. It was a back off
last time, and it may be a back off
again.
>> Back off again. There we go.
>> I mean, hey, it works once, maybe it
works twice.
>> They're behind in point tempo 1.24. But
notably, even if this death now
happened, even if it happened twice,
uh, Porro is a five at a minimum as
looks like the ruined Rex is going to be
made into another unit. Leblanc
fragmented going to be discarded. We'll
make a reflection. There's only one
available option. So we have a ready
ruined Rex at the Hill ready to gank on
over. That would be not quite enough to
take out both Pors would be 10 damage
total between the six might of the Rex
and the four from the death. Now Kus I
think would would clean it all up
>> but doesn't have one right now. See what
breaking city rips off the top
>> coming from the deck.
keeping the cards. Nice.
>> Very close. Yeah, I think I saw a flash
of a death grip there.
>> So 6 plus 6 is 12. That would be enough.
>> You're so right.
>> That would be enough to take out both
Pors. Unfortunately, we have to consider
what is a hidden card. And I think in
either case,
>> you can probably have a reasonable guess
that it's either back off that you saw
in game one or it's hidden blade because
every auto player plays hidden blade.
>> Both of those options are very bad if
you all in on a single unit to try and
conquer.
>> Absolutely.
>> And you're ahead on points right now. So
I don't think Breaking Sydney has the
onus is on them to rush on in and break
up that top battlefield quite yet.
>> Yeah, I think you might be right. I
think realistically at this point you
would be I mean not necessarily sitting
pretty, but you definitely have a lot
more confidence going into this than you
would have much earlier.
>> I also think you know if it's it's a
temporary unit could reasonably just run
it in and try and trade with one of
them. Make your opponent use a spell,
try and grind it out. But we are sending
in everybody. Woohoo!
Let's make it a party.
>> All right. Well, I did do the math
earlier and this is enough to trade with
the Porros.
>> Back off here and backing off the
untemporary one makes a bunch of sense.
That one's going to go away at some
point anyway. And now Sixmite plays 12
between those two fives that are
currently sixes chilling on that brush.
So you could death grip the other one,
but again you're only trading because
the deathnail is going to happen later
and by the time that resolves kind of
all the fun's going to be over.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So we are going to make the
temporary ruined Rex bigger. So now it's
12 plays 12. But uh trading is not going
to give you a conquer. Draws a card off
the death grip.
did indeed point the Rex at the other
Rex. Death now going to do some damage
actually. That no, still not going to
trade. No,
>> it's going to do it's going to do extra
damage in case there's a friendship
perhaps.
>> Yeah,
>> but minus four to that little porro. The
might values are still the same. Damage
does not reduce the might value of the
unit.
>> So, I think we're going to do the math
and say everybody go bye-bye.
>> Yep,
>> the brush is still there unfortunately.
And looks like the second death is going
to take out the trusty ram hound. So
cleaning up the board,
>> but unfortunately you did not conquer
that. So you do not get to replace it.
>> Unfortunate.
>> So not too bad all things considered.
>> Breaking Sydney feels pretty good again.
Up ahead five points to one.
>> There's a very big lead in a race that
you lost dramatically in game number
one.
>> So Ivvern going to have to start to play
catch-up here. And I have to say in
general, uh, Ivan especially
>> very good at holding on to things
>> not great at getting them back.
Look, I do think it just goes to show
that especially with Leblanc, it can be
so important to have that good draw.
Like it's again, just to say it, chalk
and cheese from the first time around
here, having that that quick tempo to be
able to get things out, to be able to
start making those moves early clearly
is far more beneficial. And yeah, look,
rebuilding from Ivan at this point,
it's not ideal. Yeah, it's kind of a get
ahead, stay ahead sort of to deck and
the block I think can uh can play a
little bit more flexibly perhaps, but
obviously that draw was quite good and
uh being the first player on the
battlefield meant that you got that
point lead. And I actually like Hanu
just scooping it up saying, you know
what, I'd rather have a bit more time
for game three.
>> Yep. I think that's reasonable. I think
it's Look, I I like it when somebody
makes decisive choices like that. If
nothing else,
>> good or bad.
>> Absolutely. Make your choice, commit.
There you go.
>> All right. So, Breaking Sydney. Again,
I'm very suspicious about uh the intent
of that username, but
>> yes,
>> I suppose I can be happy given that
we're in Sydney and uh there's a player
on stream with Sydney in their ID as
players are going to thumb through their
sideboards swiftly,
>> figure out what they may want to change
or not. Perhaps everything is already
perfect after game number two. But I
think it's nice to see both decks kind
of do their thing, kind of seeing
>> the game plans very much on display for
this.
>> Absolutely. This is honestly, I think, a
a perfect day one because honestly, I
really am enjoying seeing all of the
unleash decks do their thing. And again,
I didn't expect this. So, to be able to
see both these decks making such a
difference game to game, it is it is
really really nice to be able to get
that exploration of the new set.
>> Yeah, kind of curious what the last
battlefields are cuz Hillick, I think
certainly something that was on my radar
for the Blanc, but looks very good in
that game with that reflection entering
ready. And again, I assume Hanu just has
some horrible battlefield nobody wants
to go to. And I just I'm curious what it
is.
>> Yeah, almost definitely.
>> Could see see forbidden wasteland maybe.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Can I defend alone get minus two? That
wouldn't be a bad one. File moors maybe.
Although I don't know how much you care
about units moving away from it. You
don't really want to move so that
>> and I don't think it's punishing enough.
>> There is some fun stuff you can play
like aspirin's climb. try and cheese
your opponent out in a nine-point game.
Turn it off, win at eight.
>> Get some gets funny sometimes. Maybe
sometimes you draw.
>> It'd be interesting.
>> But uh based on the trend, it looks like
Hanzu's battlefield philosophy is that I
want to make them as unfun as I can for
you and just take your battlefield away.
And we did see claiming that battlefield
look pretty important for Leblanc.
>> Yeah. Look, I mean, sometimes the unfun
thing for everyone else is the most fun
thing for yourself.
>> Yeah.
You got to you got to make those moves
when you can.
>> All right, so players are shuffling up
for game number three. Always nice to
see it go the distance. Battlefields
have been changed out. And uh it's been
too long since we saw the deck list. So
it's Starring.
>> All right,
>> for the Blanc. A nice new battlefield
that I think we're going to see quite a
lot of today. Probably one worth pulling
up so we can give it a read. And it is
indeed Forbidden Waste.
>> Yeah,
>> look at me knowing all the unleashed
battlefields. Thank goodness I looked
him up before we started.
Look at you go.
>> But yeah, forgotten waste. Uh, when you
defend here alone, you get minus two.
And Starring, pull that up if we can.
Give it a little read cuz it's been a
minute.
>> I believe the first time a player plays
a non-token unit there each turn, they
may move another unit they control back
here to its base.
>> Very nice.
>> So, uh, kind of a way to move your
reflections around perhaps.
>> Again, we saw Hillick do a lot of work
letting reflections gank on over. You
can kind of with a few extra steps do
something similar as well. Definitely
something that again Levanc seems to
care enough about the mobility as we're
off to the races. Ramhound right on time
once again here for Hanzu
>> right out of this big
>> with the big dog.
>> And there's soaring scout funnily enough
card that both of these decks want to
play. One of the few bits of overlap and
I will point out it's often not relevant
but brushes are symmetrical. So that
soaring scout out of brush will be a
tiny bit bigger. You're so right.
>> I think it's more for the death now for
Leblanc, but is something that may come
up this game. You do have to remember
that it works for everyone.
>> Look, if that's an inclusion just for
the death nail and it just happens to
work out really well right now, that's a
that's a win-win situation there.
>> Well, sticking to the plan as Ramhound
conquers the Starring, turns it into a
brush, grabs a point, and says, "I am
Ramhound. Hear me roar." And I have to
imagine there's going to be a follow-up
here. M
>> frisky hunter was the play in game
number two. That would be quite good
here.
>> Casual six might and oh my goodness,
it's happening again, isn't it?
>> Yep. There we go.
>> All right, so this is basically exactly
what happened in game number one, which
if you're the block player is not good
news cuz that game did not feel all that
good. We're even going to play a hidden
card here as well. So cutting off the
ability to play Ivvern friend for all on
the next turn to defend this battlefield
even more.
Look, I mean, can you can you learn from
game one here? Okay, going across to the
other one. Forbidden waste.
>> Get a point. Make a reflection. Hey,
another Soaring Scout to the bin. That's
one we can get back with glass
mixologist.
>> Absolutely.
>> And I did spy something that looks quite
good for this matchup. A glimpse of a
beautiful full art origins card
>> that has gotten quite popular since
Baron was uh was spoiled.
Don't know if you think uh I know we
said Ivan wants to hold the battlefield.
So, how do you feel about unchecked
power?
That is one of the cards in breaking
Sydney's hands.
>> All right, Carus is out
>> again. Setting up for this temporary
death nail. It's going to have two
runes. Your death nails trigger an
additional time. Uh this card, another
one from Origins that got a lot more
attention when Leblanc was spoiled as
Iburn going to get another point
breaking. Sydney doing the sports the
sporting thing and reminding his
opponent to grab the point.
>> So losing the race right now and Ivan's
kind of doing the same thing Ivan did in
game one. But seems like a much cleaner
start on the Leblanc side even going
second as Ramhound the second going to
get deployed.
>> I love to see that communication both in
terms of reminding to channel your runes
but also reminding when you get the
points. It's you know whether it's good
or bad communication very very good.
>> Yeah. Nice clean game. Also the soaring
scouts are at least have might value at
the at the waist as second ram hound
gets deployed. One energy left held up
for a potential friendship which is
pretty close to full power.
>> And so scout going to go away. Going to
channel two runes exhausted thanks to
Carthus and then channel two awakened
for the turn because that's that's what
you have to do at the beginning of your
turn of Riftbound.
>> That's it.
>> You must channel your runes. kind of
step one really.
>> Oh,
>> yep. There we go.
>> All right. So, six ready right now. Two
for the next turn. So, going to be 10 as
things stands right now.
But, uh, what's the play here for
Alblanc player? Still the head on points
getting pretty comfy.
Two ram hounds in reserve for the Ivan
player.
Blanc everywhere at once is the play
and watchful sentry going to play it
patient which makes me think that we are
leaning very hard on this copy of
unchecked power.
>> Yes, very much so.
>> If you're not familiar, seven energy,
pretty expensive. Uh you have to exhaust
all units.
>> It's kind of a feels kind of lame. Uh,
the reason though is that you do 12
damage to all units at battlefield.
>> Yeah, look, I mean, in terms of payoff,
I I wouldn't complain at that.
>> Pretty nice. The Soaring Scout is going
to retreat as well. Already got the
point, might as well hold back. And
look, I'm not saying it's uh it's not
the loudest tell I've ever seen, but if
you were potentially signaling to your
opponent what was going to happen on the
next turn, then uh
>> a little bit. Yeah,
>> it's uh kind of showing your hand ever
so slightly. So, we'll see how hands he
wants to navigate here with the hidden
card, defending that brush. Gets the
point now. takes the lead in the point
race. As a reminder, uncheck power does
exhaust your units. So, you can't move
them in after you play your uh your big
spell that sweeps them all away, which
that's one of the reasons it exhausts
all friendly units. But, we are going to
go grab the point point number four.
Turn that forbidden waste into a brush.
>> Let the ram hound vibe and the top side.
Look, I still think it would be a a
valuable play to have that unchecked
power regardless of exhausting your
units, especially because we have seen
that Ivan does struggle to rebuild. Oh,
>> I think we're about to reinforce Ivan
for all one of these battlefields and I
think a disaster is going to strike.
>> Ivan, this is the play that one hands
you game number one. Can't fault the
play pattern given how successful it
was, but this is going to be an
absolutely devastating sweeper.
surveying the lands and says, "You know
what? Taking a turn off doesn't feel so
bad."
>> Mhm.
>> Maybe even go in first for a little
visit. See if we can't grab a point or
two.
>> Sentry for the draw. Perhaps
>> an inscrutable face there.
>> I see Lebon.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> See something else. And I I I can
promise you all I've seen that full art
cuz I have seen that many times back in
the days of the old Victor trial deck.
M.
>> All right, here's V Watchful Sentry
running on in. One might versus three.
Doesn't feel like a particularly fair
fight, but when I die, draw a card. Draw
two cards thanks to Carthus. One, two.
>> What if we did it again? Nope. Never
mind. We're just going for it.
>> And I think the bad news is about to be
given over. Unchecked power. Going to
sweep up the entire board as gives it a
read and will not be happy with the
number on that card.
>> Oh no.
>> So down two points. All the units get
exhausted, but the hidden card goes
away. Oh, that's a very good spell to
have.
>> Emperor's Divide going to move all the
units back to safety. And I thought it
was a back off, but it wasn't. That's
the perfect answer. Emperor's Divide
move any number of friendly units out of
Battlefield to their base.
>> That is beautiful. Oh my goodness. I was
really expecting the worst there. I'm
not going to lie to you. I I really
thought that that was going to be quite
problematic for Hanzu.
>> I thought the game was over. Yeah, 100%.
>> I thought that was a back opera hidden
blade.
>> All units were going to go the way of
the dodo and I thought the game was
over.
>> Not so as Ivan saves their units. Still
ahead in points as well cuz kind of took
a turn off to make this happen. Mirror
image though.
>> You can look to even things up. Choose a
unit. Play a ready reflection unit token
to your base. It becomes a copy of that
unit. Give it temporary. So kind of like
Leblanc's passive trigger, but you get
to do it without having to conquer and
discard a card. Not a bad signature
spell for all Leblanc.
>> Yeah. makes life easier.
>> They make a copy of Leblanc everywhere
at once.
>> Oh man, you have to wonder the the
thought process after going with that
unchecked power and having it be not
exactly as effective as you were hoping,
how you then basically just re-evaluate
how do you go from here.
>> Right. Well, back to Starring as the
brush does get replaced.
>> Mhm.
>> And looks like we activating Leblanc
again. going to put Leblanc fragmented
into the bin which again a very good
unit to recur with your mixologist and
matrons. Although I don't think breaking
Sydney has matrons based on the list we
saw. So it's going to be yet another
reflection and yet another copy of
Leblanc everywhere at once which again I
might remind you not only has backline
as your temporary units at about my
battlefield uh don't have temporary I
think is the text
>> roughly that
>> something like that. roughly that just
pretend they're not temporary as long as
I'm hanging.
>> Temporary effects at my battlefield
don't trigger.
>> There you go.
>> There we go.
>> So, not only do you keep the units, but
you also get your points. So, that's
four might quote unquote for free that
breaking Sydney is currently holding
onto that Star Spring with still behind
in points, but feeling pretty good about
that turn despite the Empress Divide
kind of uh deafly dodging that unchecked
power. Look, it it still puts Hanu a
little bit on the back foot there to try
and figure out what is happening. So,
we shall see.
>> They kept the point lead kind of just
counting. Yep, it's all this might is
Lanca everywhere at once. Both of them
are got to make a reflection of the
reflection
>> after making a mirror image. That's not
confusing at all.
kind of has to decide. Do you want to
stick to the game plan of trying to
score two a turn? Go to the top rush
that you've already cleared out. Move
Ivvern and friends in.
>> First conquer is going to work. That's
good for five.
>> That didn't do it.
>> Oh, it's six actually because of all the
tags. I forgot. Ivon also works when you
conquer.
>> Oh no.
>> Oh my god.
>> That actually is quite tricky.
>> So we just move everything else there.
Hold on to the spells in hand. If you
hold on to all your tags, you will just
win by scoring two points from holding
thanks to Ivvern. Of course, if you move
your units there and lose one of your
tags, you will have to score again
somehow. Yes.
>> So, that's kind of the trade-off, right?
Do you just want to commit I which is
threatening to win on its own and know
any other might to try and protect your
backline units, or do you want to commit
more might
>> because it's harder for your opponent to
crack through, but you might lose some
of your little critters that turn on
your passive texts.
Yes, look, there's the hidden card there
as well.
>> That one I know is a hidden blade. Did
manage to spot that one. And uh
>> one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight. We did mention Vilemore earlier
on. Nice big unleash monster. Have
spotted one. I have spotted that those
runes again. And notably, Hanzu just
recycled the rune that was awakened.
>> Didn't use the energy for anything.
>> Interesting.
>> Keeping the units uh at back in base as
well. So clearly believing that this is
the turn I can try and steal this game
away after dodging the unchecked power.
Scoring two of Iburn can threaten to
score two once again as the reflections
keep on rolling. And yep's like, "Wait a
second. Where'd they go?" Well, they
don't currently have temporary
because they're copies of Leblanc
everywhere at once.
>> All right, channel two runes. Draw a
card. See another Leblanc fragmented.
But what do we have to deal with the
problem like Ivvern
trying to think what answers would be in
general hidden blade I suppose
>> that would be a way to deal with this
Ivvern call is definitely not going to
get there's more than one there's more
than one copy of an extra tag as well so
if you could uh take out one of the
birds or the cat that would also get it
done but unfortunately there's two dogs
So if it's just cull, you can sacrifice
one of those poor little ram hounds and
still keep the four tags you need as
Leblanc fragmented going to move on
down.
>> Starring going to move a ready unit
back. Something we did did expect to
see,
>> but that is at least going to give
Breaking Sydney another unit to charge
on in with. But I'm looking at all these
units and I don't know about you, but
all their might look like numbers less
than eight.
>> Yes. Yes, very much so. Look, I I will
never profess to be very very good at
maths, but it's not looking good. Bomar
is certainly a unit that means you don't
have to think too much about the
numbers. Just make sure your numbers
bigger and then everything's good.
>> So that would mean that would mean
breaking Sydney absolutely needs
something
>> something
>> in combat to deal with the vile mall.
>> One card in Ham by the looks of things
just laying face down on the table just
left of that carus.
>> All the death nails in the world aren't
going to save you from this. And we're
doing the math and I unfortunately I
have to say
>> it's not there.
>> That the math just may not matter.
>> The math is not mathing.
>> What is mathing? Unfortunately, it just
all adds up to zero.
>> Yeah,
>> I've earned so impressive
with how swiftly can acrewue points. And
uh
>> we're going to make the move. Send in
these three units. That seems like
enough might. 8 + 1 or sorry, 8 plus 2,
that's 10 versus seven. or eight
depending on how the interaction works.
I still haven't figured it out.
>> And I think Bomore is going to be the
bad news breaking Sydney did not want to
see.
>> Hund considering all options in their
hand still has a hidden card as well.
>> Currently 11 to seven on might.
>> Oh, the bird's bigger. That's why. And
there's Bmore
>> breaking Sydney. You can see a big
exhale there. And I think Bmore is going
to put the nail in the coffin. Enemy
units here with less might than me don't
deal combat damage. Right now, we're in
the middle of combat.
>> That's that. Look, it's got to hurt.
It's got to hurt.
>> Ambush is a pretty good keyword. And
this is one of the things about
Unleashed that you have to be aware of.
It's not just gear that can come in at
quick draw speed. It's not just actions
and reactions that can come in like they
always could. Now, units are just flying
off the top rope and coming into
battlefields at lightning speed. Death
grip.
>> Try and make something bigger. But
that's not enough. You can't get to
eight. And if you can't get to eight,
well, Vio sticking around. The idea of a
vilemore coming off the top row is a
horrific visual. Thank you. Oh my
goodness.
>> Little elbow drop vilemore
>> with which of the legs?
>> Throw a lot of them.
>> Yeah,
>> maybe it's face first.
>> Still rough.
>> Yeah.
>> Either way, really really tricky
position here. I just I think
>> I think he knows it too. I mean, even if
you get to eight, the other units don't
deal damage or it's just the violor
being traded away and the the eyebender
sticks around.
>> Death group going to draw a card. One
final peak to see what you can maybe
find here.
>> Lanc goes away, draws another card
thanks to Leblanc fragmented death now.
>> Car is triggering twice, but I don't
know what you have left.
>> Three runes available one at a time. We
are going to peek at the cards. I think
I have to find a hidden blade
>> to try and get out of this.
Luck of the draw.
>> I don't know. Breaking Sydney's face
didn't look too disappointed then.
>> Have to consider what the hidden card is
as well. But
>> at this point, you might not be able to
beat it even if it is a hidden blade.
>> So, just have to make the play that you
think best wins you the game in the spot
you're in. And this is quite the pickle.
>> It is. It is indeed.
>> So, 15 + 14 might right now at this
showdown. But again, Vomor is turning
off every single unit at this
battlefield or at least saying it
doesn't deal combat damage currently
because uh eight is a big number and all
the units are smaller than that. Even
the seven after that first death grip,
>> you can't do combat damage on your tail.
You don't get to win combats.
>> It does make it difficult. You're not
wrong.
>> And even if you have units hanging
around, cuz even if there isn't enough
might, let's say, to take out all the
units that moved in, well, defenders get
a little advantage. Attackers have to
leave.
the counting.
>> Doing the math again.
>> If Ivan stays there, I will remind you
if Ivan stays there and all the tags
stay on the field, that is going to be
conquering for one point and then one
bonus point thanks to Ivan. And that is
a point that can get you the winning
point. In fact, if you stack it either
way,
>> yeah,
>> it will work for you.
>> Bonus points can be the final points you
get. So, we're going to play something.
Stupify redraw time.
>> Bellow's breath going to be the option.
>> Yes. Coming down.
>> Bellowing. Oh, bellowing the sententury
to try and draw another card.
>> Cute little play.
>> All right, goodbye. Watchful sentry.
Draw two more cards thanks to Carus.
>> Yeah, look, I mean, at this point, you
just got to keep looking to see if
there's an answer somewhere in there.
>> Fishing for another death grip only to
lose to hidden blade is my prediction.
>> They have to find it first.
>> Regretson. He looks at two, extends a
hand and Hanu Ivvern. It's going to be
two Z onream.
Wow, that is really, really exciting. Oh
my goodness.
>> I love to see it. As someone that did a
lot of Iburn tinkering with me in my old
baited hooks, uh, this looks a lot
better, I will say, than what I was
cooking up.
>> Oh, yeah. You can admit that.
>> I of course, look, I don't build good
decks. I built I built fun decks.
>> I will say I've been friends to all
looking like the best green Arya I've
ever seen.
>> Very very powerful. Given that it works
both on conquer or on hold, you can
acrew points very quickly in increments
of two. And in Riftband, it turns out
that is kind of the number you want to
be getting points by.
>> Yeah. Look, I think it just goes to show
you really do have to be preparing for
any kind of matchup.
>> Oh yes.
>> I mean, look, as I said at the top,
look, Leblanc, I don't think maybe would
have prepared quite so much for Ivvern
as some of the other decks that we've
been seeing. So look, given how the game
has unfolded and that there was that
kind of give and take between the games,
I think a really really exciting end.
>> Yeah, Empress Divide proving to be the
hidden card that is uh always much
better than I think it's going to be.
Absolutely saves that game. The Iburn
and all those all those tags were what I
needed to hold on to to even have a
chance in that game. That unchecked
power looked like it was genuinely going
to end the game. When all the units
live, your opponent is still ahead on
points. You've taken a turn off because
you cannot get points. You got one, but
you can't get two because you had to
exhaust all your units to even cast the
spell. And when it doesn't actually work
out, yeah, you're 12 damage is good, but
when it doesn't hit when it hits one
unit, not all that helpful.
>> No, I mean, forest father indeed, we'll
say.
>> I mean, think I mean, Za's uh spell we
could have had there.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Wouldn't have done anything. It would
have saved the Ivvern, but wouldn't have
saved all the other cats, dogs, birds,
and
>> look, I think in terms of responses
there, just a really really well
predicted move. I think look really I I
truly thought that was the end of the
game.
>> I did too.
>> Was going to just fully
>> end it all.
>> Yep. And the Empress Divide coming up
trumps as Ivan navigated the rest of
that game thanks to Vio. I think a card
we might see quite a bit of in other
decks. Didn't necessarily expect to see
it. what I did expect to see an Ivan
didn't necessarily expect to do so well,
but I think maybe with some Vexes
running around depending on how well
that deck is doing, that is the kind of
deck I definitely expect to see that as
well as a little selfie
>> to commemorate the victory there for
Hanzu.
>> Understandable. Look, I mean, as far as
cats, dogs, birds, and spiders go.
>> Yeah.
>> Look, I mean, it clearly works. So,
>> in in Sydney, in Australia with the drop
spider for the lot of spiders, it makes
sense.
Yeah,
>> bit on the nose, I think. But
>> as an arachnophobe, I'll I'll allow it,
you know.
>> Yeah, Vmore looks uh I mean, he's not
that scary.
>> Look,
he he's
>> he's not that scary. Scary.
>> He's a little scary
>> in game. Very scary.
>> Yeah. In that position, scary.
>> Yeah. And again, for all the value in
the world, no matter how many different
units you can make, they're all less
than eight might. even with the death g
to try and get one to seven that was not
enough. I did appreciate that again not
knowing exactly what was happening not
knowing what the hidden card was.
Playing two routes always good as a
player but uh even without finding the
card at the end of the game I think it
is good to see Leblanc trying to at
least do something in that spot.
>> Absolutely.
>> You knew if you didn't the game was over
and that's exactly what happened
>> 100%. And sometimes you just have to
really just hope that the deck gives you
exactly what you want and in this case
it just didn't happen for Breaking
Sydney. So unfortunate, but it is the
way that it goes sometimes.
>> Sydney stays whole. Good to know.
>> Yes.
>> All right. Well, interview is ready.
Let's get an answer to the winner, cuz I
would love to hear how this I deck came
to be.
>> And I am joined here by today's round
two winner from the featured matchup,
Hanzu. Congratulations, Hanzu, on
winning your round two with Ivvern into
Leblanc. How do you feel after that win?
>> Cool.
>> Cool. All right. Awesome. It is always
good to feel cool after a hardfought
victory. Obviously, you took game one
and game three, but there was a moment
in game three that we were all excited
to see that unchecked power come out.
Did you read that play? How did you play
around that one cuz the answer was
phenomenal.
>> Uh that card is the most card I'm afraid
of uh in the blue color.
>> Yep. So
I use that color card color card color
card color card to
avoid that. Yeah.
>> Damage.
>> Oh, excellent. So you've been
practicing. You knew that unchecked
power could be a big answer into your
style of deck and so you played around
it. You had that Emperor's Divide to
answer even when that we sort of got as
uh Patri time said that almost like a
tell when they pulled off that
battlefield. So really well played,
really well read there. So, you are two
wins, zero losses, zero draws. Do you
have any matchups that you're looking
for with Ivvern? Some favored matchups?
>> Um, Ivon is my favorite legends. Yep.
>> In LOL. Y,
>> so I choose this legends to hear.
>> Yeah. And Ivvern's really unique in that
he's very sort of type all deck. He's
got that bird porro kind of synergy. And
do you normally play uh calm and order
domains?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So did you play a Zir before this?
>> I play it for about
two months.
>> Yeah. Nice. So a lot of practice. And uh
is this is your first regional
qualifier? How are you finding the
experience so far?
Um
because I
really like this gaming atmosphere here.
>> You really like the gaming atmosphere?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I think it's fantastic that we're
also like here amongst the crowd and
everybody can watch you play as well.
Are you hoping to chase down that best
of Ivvern or do you want to win it all?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I want to win.
>> You want to win it all? Yeah.
>> All right. Excellent. Well, we will be
sure to keep an eye on you for the rest
of the Riftbound Regional qualifiers
here in Sydney 2026. And um LeBlanc,
would you say that she's a bad matchup
for you? Like you obviously got great
starts in game one and game three, so
you got ahead very quickly. Were you
more concerned that she could find a way
back in?
>> Um I think it's a bat.
>> Yep. Uh I have possibility to win and
also have possibility to lose.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> But um this is this game.
>> Yeah. Well, it's all part of the game.
It's all the strategy and you know,
obviously with Unleashed and the brand
new legends, there's some unknowns. And
I really think that obviously the LeBlot
and the Ivvern, both relatively unknown,
but you clearly practice so well and uh
as you said, you knew that unchecked
power could kind of dismantle your game
plan. So that Emperor's Divide was was
really good to respond to that. And do
you would you say it saved you in that
game three?
>> Uh about games three.
>> Um
I think I'm the lucky one.
>> Yep.
>> Um
uh he didn't draw the card to
counter me.
>> Uh yes. Yes. I think we were thinking he
might have called that hidden blade to
take out the vilemore and move in, but
he didn't find it. Well,
congratulations, Hanzu, on your 200 and
your round two win here at the Riftbound
Regional Qualifier Sydney 2026. It's
back to you casters.
Thank you very much, Logan. Round two is
still going on. We have more Riftbound
for you all in just a moment. We have a
backup feature match.
>> Yeah.
>> Not just Ivan winning with Bmore after
dodging unchecked power with Empress
Divide. We have even more to show you
all.
>> I'm so excited. All right. All right,
what have we got this time around then?
>> Vex, one of the new decks I think a lot
of players are excited about versus one
of the decks that want to argue in
Europe. Azir
>> Azir. Yeah, there we go. I'm excited to
see this. We are jumping straight in.
So, it will be interesting to see where
they're at at the moment.
>> Yep. Send me in whenever you want
production. If the players are ready, I
am certainly ready. So, we can watch
ourselves some little bit more riftbound
here and see who's looking good here in
round number two.
>> Let's do it. one of the uh not the old
gods per se, but one of the uh one of
the success stories from the previous
game as we are right into game number
two. Azir did win the first one
>> on the wall camp this game versus star
tipped peak. It is SD Lovely Snow versus
Espionage. Seven points to six though.
And this game is looking awfully close.
>> There's a lot happening on that board
right now.
>> All right. Well, soldiers have moved in.
Some of them are equipped. Two of them
in fact. So quite a lot of might at that
battlefield. But that I imagine is the
seventh point. M.
>> So, how are we going to get the other or
we just going to wait there and hope we
can conquer or hold sorry for the final
point. Espionage of course threatening
to win on the crack back
and it looks like lovely snow has just
decided that my best course of action is
to try and make as much might as I can
and park at the top battlefield for the
hold which basically puts the onus on
espionage to say you know what you must
break this or you will lose as cold week
going to come out and uh make the field
just a little bit smaller.
See a couple of defies in hand. What
else is there? Yeah,
>> there's a defy. Honestly, kind of an
interesting one cuz it's just one might
for two. Like that colder week was just
going to make your your side one might
bigger.
>> But Espionage deciding I actually kind
of do need all my might.
>> I mean, when you're when you're facing
down that much, understandable.
>> Looks like Vex Apathetic holding the
bottom battlefield, holding that star
tipped peak. Big big fan of Vex
Apathetic.
>> Yeah, very very good card.
>> Very very good. I think we'll see it a
lot over the course of the weekend.
>> Vex Gloomist of course going to hold for
a draw as well after exhausting. When
you or an ally hold, you may exhaust me
to draw one. And uh you should do that
every opportunity you can. I can tell
you all that for free.
>> Espionage, what do you have to get
through this top battlefield cuz seven
points is good, but it's not eight. And
you must get to eight to win. So if
Espionage can score the other
battlefield this turn, we'll win this
game and force us to game number three.
>> No pressure.
>> You look, I don't want to.
>> Okay, did have a quick squeeze in the
hand.
>> I was going to be I don't want to be
that guy again, but uh Firearm would be
good here. And that's it. Deciding that
I actually cannot get through. The sand
soldiers are too big. Holding for the
final point. Shows the back off.
>> Had it all. Even with the defy there and
the abandon. There was just too much
might on that top battlefield.
>> Goodness me. Wow, that was quick.
>> It was quick. Fastest game I've ever
seen. That's a pretty quick deck.
>> Zipped in, zipped out. My goodness.
>> Well, there we go.
SD lovely snow on Azir getting yet
another win.
>> Mhm.
>> Feels good. Not sure exactly what
happened there, but uh you did actually
see a little bit of why Azir's felt
decent in unleashed. Uh you may have
keen eyes may have spotted soul sword
>> which is a gear that came out in
unleash. Not the best piece of gear in
terms of the stats it gives you but very
importantly uh it gives you some stats
and it costs one.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's a piece of equipment and that's
a bad that's that's basically all Azir
needs. Just more equipment that costs
one so that he can make a sand soldier
with two runes
>> pretty much. Yes. Look, I mean for what
we did see of that very fun.
>> Yeah. Unfortunately, didn't get to see
Vex do the thing. I mean, Vexpathetic
pretty good against sand soldiers as it
turns out. Although, I guess they're not
ready, but they can't move. So, Aziz
Sovereign doesn't get to do the thing,
but looks like just made a big enough
army of sand soldiers. Parked them at
the battlefield and said, "Can you win?"
And unfortunately for Vex, the answer
was no.
>> Not so much. Not so much this time
around. Look, I mean, when you're facing
down that many,
>> yeah,
>> unsurprising, but look, sometimes
there's answers, sometimes there's not.
this time around.
>> Perhaps we'll get vexed again on stream,
but I have a feeling that the Vex
enjoyers out there on the stream maybe
didn't get to see as much of the legend
as they would have wanted.
>> Look, as a Vex enjoyer, I would also
like to see more at some point. So,
we'll see. Hopefully, we can uh get a
little bit more going on soon.
>> Certainly. So, we'll see what happens in
the next round, though, cuz round three
is coming right up. We are going to go
to a quick break, but when we return, it
is more regional qualifier Sydney.
Welcome to Riftbond Basics featuring the
ground rules. Riftbond is a trading card
game based on the League of Legends
universe in which the aim is to score
eight victory points across two
different battlefields. Points are
scored by moving your own units onto one
of the battlefields and conquering it or
by holding it for more than one turn.
The different car types in Riftbound are
units, gears, and spells. To play these,
you must pay an energy cost, which is
shown in the top left corner of the
card, as well as a power cost.
Energy is obtained by exhausting runes.
These come from the 12 card rune deck
from which the top two cards are played
for free at the beginning of each turn.
If you exhaust your runes to pay energy,
you must also pay a power cost for some
cards. To do this, you simply place one
of your runes bearing the symbol shown
on the card under your rune deck. You
can also use runes that are already
exhausted for this.
The domains of the runes and the cards
you play in your main and sight deck are
determined by your legend. Units that
you play enter the board exhausted. This
means they cannot move until they are
readyed at the start of the next turn.
Just like all other exhausted cards on
your side, you initially play your units
and gears into your base. There they are
protected from combat. Gears can't get
into combat. If you already control a
battlefield, you also have the option to
play your units directly from your hand
onto it. This is where your units might
comes into play. This is the number
shown on the top right hand corner of
the units. Might represents both the
attack power and the defensive stat of
your units. If a player moves units into
an already occupied battlefield, combat
stunts. Here, spells with action and
reaction speed can be activated to deal
damage or modify might. When combat
occurs and no player wishes to activate
any more spells or abilities, the total
might of all units is added together and
distributed amongst the opposing units.
Players may decide for themselves which
opposing unit they wish to damage. Once
combat is over, any damage is healed by
units that were involved and did not
die. The game ends when a player reaches
eight victory points, though this is not
quite so easy to achieve. Whilst every
other point simply requires conquering a
battlefield to earn the eighth point,
you must either have held a battlefield
for one round or you score two points in
the same round. Now you've got all the
information you need to know to start
enjoying a game of Riftbound.
We are here at the Sydney RQ. I am
joined by the wonderful base deck
department. Now, you are known for being
very good at deck building. How are you
taking that into Riftbound?
>> I'm trying really hard and failing
really badly because the deck building
is quite different. Uh, but I'm learning
a lot. So, it's good. It's helping me in
other things that I do because I'm
learning a lot and I haven't learned a
lot in a whole long time. So, it's good.
>> So, the deck that you're currently
running, how are you feeling about your
your chances for the weekend?
>> Uh, it's the only deck I've played. So,
I've only played Azir. Uh, I built him
because I saw he did quite well in
China. I'm feeling okay, but I'm still
pretty new to Riftbound, so I'm
expecting to maybe get like middling
results, probably crash out and burn and
then quit early, but I'm hoping I do
well.
>> Okay, so obviously the unleash set only
just released. Did that change how you
approached this weekend?
>> Uh, yeah, a lot. Some decks got a lot
stronger. Aurora,
uh, I there's a lot of cards for my
deck, a lot more card draw that Unleash
brings to Azia, which is really cool cuz
that was a big weakness. So, I'm I'm I'm
really happy with what Unleash brought
to the meadow as a whole.
>> So, basically what I'm hearing is that
even if you crash and burn, you're
feeling pretty good about it anyway and
you're having a good time.
>> Yeah, that's that's exactly what I'm
saying.
>> Awesome. Well, best of luck for the
weekend. We'll see how it goes.
>> We are down here at the Sydney ARQ. I am
joined by Briefcase. You have flown here
for the event. How are you feeling about
your chances? Uh, I'm playing against a
friend, uh, Zach, and I think it's
really good so far because I'm not
competing in the main event. However, I
think I can beat him.
>> Well, I I have some insider knowledge
that he is very new, so I feel like
maybe are taking advantage a little bit.
>> Quite possibly. Quite possibly. I did
also try to rope him into the the draft
itself. So, I did have ulterior motives
here.
>> So, obviously the unleash set only just
came out. How are you feeling about the
new champions? Um, three of my favorite
champions of League of Legends actually
came out this set set. Um, Jin, Lilia,
and Pike. I actually really love them in
the game itself. So great so far. I just
haven't been able to play them that much
yet. I'm like looking to do some more in
their decks.
>> Which one do you reckon you'll build
first?
>> Uh, I've already made Lilia. That's what
Jess is playing. Uh, I want to put my
hands on it a bit more, but I think I
really like the tokens.
>> Well, we'll see how the rest of the
weekend goes.
We are here down at the Sydney RQ. I am
joined by Fasby and we are currently in
the midst of a draft. Is that correct?
>> It absolutely is. You're playing draft.
>> And how is that going for you so far? Is
this the first time you've drafted?
>> Um, it's not the first time I've
drafted, but it is we're playing a very
special trios version. So, it's
something that's never really been
played before. Um, but so, but we're
still in the draft phase.
>> Okay. So, what are you kind of
gravitating towards at the moment? I'm
playing uh a predominantly yellow deck
at the moment with a lot of soldiers.
I've got Azir and um yeah, I'm looking
forward to just getting a lot of things
out.
>> So, do you like your chances so far
given the rest of the people at the
table?
>> Absolutely not. No, I'm definitely one
of the beginners, but uh I every game
that I get to play, I learn something
new and it's just actually really really
fun.
>> So, maybe next time we're in Sydney,
you'll be in the main event then.
>> I I mean, I'd love to have that
experience at least once. Yeah. Let's
see what Let's see if I can take
>> Fingers crossed. We'll see how you go.
Thank you so much.
>> Welcome back to regional qualifier
Sydney. We've just had an exciting round
two and we're about to prepare for round
three. But Logan, before we delve into
round three, that round two, the Ivan
matchup was super exciting.
>> Yeah, Ivan into Leblanc for that round
two matchup. Both unleashed legends that
are new here today at the Riftbound
regional qualifiers in Sydney. A
fantastic showing and we have to address
that hyper moment. Ricey, that unchecked
power and Emperor's Divide.
>> Very, very amazing play coming through
from our Ivan player who Hanzu um who
was able to counter that unchecked power
like unchecked power is an extremely in
my opinion strong spell and well that
Ivan player knew that it was probably
coming and had that Empress Divide the
entire time up their sleeves. Yeah, one
thing that I really do like, we were
interviewing Hanzu, the winner of that
game, and he did actually say that
Unchecked Power was the card that he was
most scared of for his Ivvern deck. And
reasonably, if you think about it, with
the Aurora, the dazzling aurora becoming
much more popular, much stronger here
with the addition of the Elder Dragon,
Unchecked Power is also an excellent
answer into Aurora decks. So, it's a lot
more prevalent, a lot more common in
those mind focused domain decks here,
Icy.
>> Yeah. So, we're probably going to be
seeing more of Unch.
and maybe tomorrow as well because we
have so much ribbon to go through and
well we we keep getting blessed by two
feature matches. We got one two feature
matches in round one and two now and
round two. So we've seen quite a few uh
new legends so far.
>> Yeah, absolutely loving it. Label Iburn
as we say. We saw Pike, we saw Rengar,
we've seen quite a handful of brand new
legends from Unleashed and that's what
we'd want to see. But we want to see
them shake up the meta as we take a
quick look at just the hall. The Sydney
Showgrounds showcasing the main event
happening right now. Ricey, this place
is packed to the rafters with previous
RQ winners and aspiring RQ winners too.
>> I think one of the amazing things about
the Australian community is we have so
many passionate passionate players. We
may have, you know, smaller populations
than other uh countries and regions, but
we all kind of know each other because
of that. Like we have the Nexus Knight
buddies versing off against Nexus Knight
buddies. It is bloody out there. You
know, everybody is fighting tooth and
nail to try and get become the best of
the best and and sometime sometimes
you're versing your own friends.
>> Yeah. Not only your own friends, but
also your opposition because you know
one LGS versus another LGS. It's honor
is on the line.
>> Also Sydney versus Melbourne, all the
other rivalries.
>> Don't get me started.
>> Yeah. So very very keen for that one.
Cannot wait to see how these sort of
players work their way through the field
because right now we're going to jump
into round three soon. We've seen the
round one and round two. But first we're
going to play guess the flavor.
>> I'm not excited for this Logan. Guess
the flavor. My understanding of it is
they're going to give us a flavor text
and we have to guess which card it is.
Now I know quite a few uh League of
Legends voice lines from the game. Like
I I've played the game on and off for
the last
>> 12 years showing my age here. Um but
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
that card. You know, you can have that
flavor text on uh like a different card.
Like I'm trying to think of an example,
but oh dear, first one's here. Nothing
stops us. Not cold, not death. You got
first.
>> That has to be a mind card for sure.
It's blue. It's uh frigid something. I
think it's I think could be frigid
touch. I'm going with frigid touch.
>> Okay. What was I'm also going with
frigid touch. Oh, you took my card.
>> Guess the flavor text. Nothing stops us.
Not cold. Not Oh,
as well.
>> Come on, Reva. The law keeper there.
Fantastic.
>> When you play a spell, if you spend four
or more, ready me.
>> Yep, that's it. Probably go good in gin
decks with that four cost. Yeah. All
right.
>> Well, let's see if there's another one.
>> Be nice to us production.
>> Truth barely comes without sacrifice.
I'm going sacrifice. I probably not. I'm
sorry sacrifice.
>> You hard sniped that from me. I'm
>> so sorry, but that's mine
>> cuz the name of the cards in the Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> You never know. It's probably really
not. Production is probably just uh
baiting us here.
>> You You know what? I reckon it's got to
be a Leblanc playable. Truth rarely
comes without sacrifice. So that really
speaks to me of that mind order
combination. What are you thinking? You
got another gasp.
>> The card that I use in my Victor deck. I
keep forgetting the name of it, but you
turn it into temporary
>> Shadow's Call.
>> Shadow's Call maybe.
>> Let's go. Shadow's Call. You've gone
sacrifice. I've gone shadow.
>> We're terrible at this game.
>> Oh my goodness. I hate
>> It's fine. It's fine. We'll see. We'll
see. Maybe one. We get If we get one, we
have to keep splitting up our cards so
you have a higher chance.
>> Dramatic visionary. A fantastic mind. At
least I was right with the domains. I
was like, "Oh, it sounds like mind
order." Yeah. Not the first time.
>> Was this really your plan, pal?
>> You know it.
>> Oh, I I can see the card in my head.
It's an or it's a um a body domain and
the art he's towering over his opponent
who's like lying down on the ground, but
the name of the card escapes me. My
goodness.
>> How buff is he?
>> Like buff like Ali Aldrazi buff.
>> It's not like the um champions uh
favorite champion or something like
that. That's the one I think of the the
body with buffness.
>> I know it's like a a common or an
uncommon. It's not a rare. Um and it is
unleashed. I don't have a name for it.
>> Favorite champion. Favored champion.
>> Favored champion. Is that the Is that
the name of
>> I don't know. Let's rip with that.
Favorite champion.
>> I was trying to remember.
>> Oh, no. That's not the card I was
thinking of, but you were right. I
>> I take that as a victory.
>> I'll give you that one. I'll give that
one. Uncommon, so.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Yeah, that's a good one. I like that
one.
>> This is This is fun. It's stressful. But
I want to know how did chat go as well.
Were you playing along as well?
>> I was hoping for Evelyn. Quite frankly,
I'm locked in on that player text.
Well, round three is on the way, Logan.
Here we are. We're seeing our featured
matchup right now. They are, of course,
setting up the table. Um, I'm very
excited to see who the legends are for
this feature matchup.
>> Before we even get to the legends, look
at this sweeping camera angle that we
got this panoramic shot of both of our
players and the important judges who
keep these games on track, who are there
for any rules checks, and the
allimportant water top up there. You
must stay hydrated. All these gamers,
they're out here for hours. Make sure
you've got your snacks, your bananas,
your protein bars. They're all helpful.
>> I did hear some research about bananas
being one of the best ways to activate
your brain or stay locked in or
something better than coffee even. But,
you know, as you said, got to stay
hydrated. It's eight rounds today. Uh,
seven if you got your buy. So,
>> that's true. That's true. Um, I hope
bananas unlock hair follicles cuz I'm
bald and I'm going to need some of that
energy. But they are shuffling up those
decks. They're making sure they do those
really good proper stack shuffles, too,
just to make sure the competitive
integrity of this game is Mickey Mouse
here, Icy. But like you, I cannot wait
to find out what legends we are looking
at cuz all those cards right now,
they're face down. We We can't see
anything.
>> We have no idea what legends are being
played. No idea what battlefield builds
either. No idea what's in their decks.
And that's super exciting. We could
theory craft a little bit.
>> Yeah, Kaiser. You think it's Kaiser?
>> Kaiser.
>> Okay.
>> Just because I played her in set one.
>> I was just trying to figure out like
which of the new um legends haven't we
seen yet?
>> So, we've seen Pike, Ivvern, LeBlanc,
we've seen Rengar. So, we haven't seen
Lilia, which you would like to see.
>> I would love to see Lilia.
>> We got a quick snippet of Vex just
before.
>> Vex.
>> Uh we haven't seen XP Ye.
>> No.
>> Poppy.
>> Poppy. Yes.
>> Yeah. There's quite a few we haven't
seen and we have more than a day and a
half left to hopefully get eyes on all
of them.
>> I If you're predicting Kaiser, I'm
predicting Lilia Poppy. Those are the
two. Maybe I'm cheating predicting two,
but there's two players on the There's
two players on the table, so you know.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Not sure. I only
predicted one. All right. So, I'm going
to go with Kaiser. We've already seen
Aurelia. Ah, dazzling Aurora. We haven't
seen an Aurora on featured matchups yet.
>> Well, that's why I was going Poppy.
>> Yeah. Oh, come on.
Poppy tag. I'm here for the Civer
Aurora.
>> Oh, you want Civer Aurora?
>> I want Civer Aurora. I want the mean
Aurora.
>> That is pretty mean. I mean, Civer
orange, sorry, body and chaos.
And we know how strong Chaos is. I mean,
that's going to be a Baron Nasher,
right?
>> Yeah, it could potentially be a Nasher,
but from what I'm seeing from the
chatter out there with the wild, you
don't want to run too many Baron Nashes.
It's a really good late game piece in
the Dazzling Aurora style, but more
often than not, you're going to see two
to three Elder Dragons if they're
indexing very heavily into that Windcon.
Very powerful card, but we still haven't
seen it here. And uh we're starting to
get an inkling onto the Legends and
Champions that these two will be
playing. What do you spy?
>> Is that an ARI? I see.
>> An Inquisitive and an ARI. Yeah, it is.
Did you get to see the other one?
>> I didn't see that one. I was looking at
the same one you were looking at.
>> Oh, okay. Well, we know there's an Ari.
That's pretty exciting.
>> Yeah, happy to see that. One of the set
one legends from Origins and definitely
a fan favorite. Her uh metal card was
one of the first to fly off the walls
here at the Sydney RQ actually.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm not too surprised about
that. Ari is a fan favorite across all
of League of Legends IP. Um so, not
surprised by that. And I'm wondering if
this is a metal car chaser, the best of
chaser as well. Yeah, the best of are
definitely still out there. Both of
these players will currently be two and
zero. And you know, shout out Faker for
the work he's done bringing Ahri up into
the eyes of everybody. League of
Legends, a lot of these players, this is
their first time playing Riftbound
because of that League of Legends
energy, those champions that have
converted over to legends here in
Riftbound as we're just getting some
final
working out of the battlefields and the
legends and the champions here. And I
cannot wait. We know Ari already with
that inquisitive champion unit, but we
currently do not have eyes on that
second legend. However, let's talk about
mind and uh calm domains, right? Mind, a
lot of card draw, a lot of might
adjustment, and then calm has the
counter spells in Riftbound.
lot of counter spells and it does have a
little bit of exciting um ways to uh
enhance a unit and um I guess stupify
does the opposite as well, right? And
get that card draw as well. But as you
said, mine is really really good at that
card draw. So I'm excited to see the the
spells come out as well and see what
kind of play style that this AR is going
to have.
>> Yeah, and not only that, but the calm
domain. We have seen that that is a
highly represented domain. Previously in
Atlanta, it was all chaos and calm. So
having the calm just here with this
match will be exciting. I would expect
to see defy as the classic counter
spell. I would expect to see potentially
not so fast because a lot of people will
be teching against that elder dragon. It
can stop those spells and abilities
critically. So um yeah, I'm I'm very
keen to see the AR for the first time
here at the Riftbound regional
qualifiers. Yeah, I mean we haven't seen
Ari in any any in any of the other
feature matches so far. And as you said,
Ari is a fan favorite as herself. Um not
necessarily the most played legend in
Riftbound, but because of everyone
loving how amazing Ari is in general,
she is still quite often played.
>> Yeah, definitely. She's definitely
fallen out of the meta, so to speak, we
would expect her to sort of be middle
toward upper middle of that pack. But
that's not to say that some of these
players who absolutely one trick these
legends can't take it with the best of
the rest of them, right? I would
absolutely expect, as you say, them
chasing that best of card, that best of
Ahri so coveted. And as a reminder, we
are currently in unleash. This is the
last possible chance to get the best of
from Origins and Proven Grounds. That's,
you know, 16 legends that get rotated
out once Unleash is done and we move
into Vendetta.
>> Exactly. So, a lot of people are
definitely after that Ahri, and I do not
blame them. Uh, she's absolutely
gorgeous. I got to hold a prize wall.
Not a best of, but I got to hold a prize
wall Ari, and I was like, she's
beautiful. So, I loved seeing that a
lot. Um, and so I'm sure of course a lot
of other people feel the same way as
well. And
>> she is still fun to play. I personally
really like K. I was a Master Year
player back in Origin. So that's my like
home territory. You know, the
disciplines, the defies, all that sort
of exciting jazz in calm. But blue as
well is it's got lots of um uh tricks up
their sleeve.
>> It's an interesting synergy. Green has
some great pump spells and then mind
obviously has some great I'm going to
reduce your might spells and uh so it it
almost creates that defiant dance effect
where you broaden the gap in the might
totals between both units and and you
win combat like that. But to Yi, as you
were saying, Yei plays really well in
the mid-range, but can also play a very
effective, dazzling Aurora. And we do
know there are a fair few Ye here signed
up at the regionals.
>> Yeah, I believe uh the pre-qualifiers it
was the most uh used legend.
>> It was one of the top three.
>> It was definitely the top three. I don't
want to I don't know if it was Leblanc
first, then it was Leblanc first. Okay.
Well, they're definitely all in the top
three there. So, so many master. And I
remember like the the way the legend
works for Ahri is that
>> it gives
plus no minus one minus one to attackers
or and
>> minus one might
>> yes
>> minus one might I need to see the the
words in front of me but I it works
similar to must is what I remember but
different
>> yeah but both are so surprising as well
you swing into that area and it's so
easy to forget that minus one might and
then that stupify on top just means
you're minus two might suddenly and
you're like oh wait now I have redo my
maths. Can I pump up over this
discrepancy that we've now found
ourselves in? And yeah, like you say,
Yei is the opposite. If you are
defending alone, plus two might to
units, which is why you know your dead
bloom predators, your mind spplitters,
which obviously can't play into Yi, but
those mid-range spells in body and calm,
they become so much bigger, a lot
scarier to play into. So with Ari as
well that that chosen champion um also
has some really interesting plays with
that might game the calculations and
everything you got to be really on top
of as you said you might have to
recalculate things because with the the
ARI you have that also a plus one minus
one with the might as well.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Really really strong
champion uh legend and I'm glad to see
that she is represented here at the
regional qualifiers here in Sydney this
year. But I mean, we haven't seen much
green Ahri. It's always the blue Ahri
that they go for. Inquisitive is just
that much more effective in these
styles. But let's talk about potential
matchups, right? We've spoken enough
about Ahri. What does Ahri want to see?
What can Ahri play into? With Mind and
Calm, you reduce a lot of might. So, I
have to imagine they want to play into
those mid-range aggros. I would love to
see now that I think about it a Diana
Ari match up that could go well
>> having both the blue the the minds to
verse each other and then of course
Diana having a bit more of a chaos
versus the calm it's like the opposites
as well.
>> Yeah because obviously chaos typically
will have the raven bloom student from
their mind domain but chaos are really
good at spell slinging and they'll be
able to pump that up quite a lot despite
the negative one from the passive on the
legend. So, that could be quite an
interesting conflict and uh hopefully
when we get the winners interview, we'll
get an insight into their decisions in
their favored matchups and the ones that
they were hoping to avoid because every
single legend has a strength and a
weakness and there are some legends you
just do not want to face up against.
>> Yeah, I know. There's always like this
kind of rock, paper, scissors uh sort of
thing happening, which is why I do enjoy
this Whis format because it gives you
more chances to hopefully run into more
of your favorite matchups as you were
mentioning before.
>> Yeah, definitely favored matchups,
unfavored matchups. Like we were talking
about with Hanzu, the Ivvern winner. He
uh is concerned about what mind can
bring to the table. So, he has prepared
for it. He has practiced into it. And
that's a lot of what these gamers have
done. as we see the scissor paper rock
coming down I believe for them to decide
who goes first and we are on the board
with the GG's Ricey
>> we are indeed it is going to be really
exciting to watch these two verse off
against each other I believe it's
actually a Ari versus a Lilia which is
really exciting we mentioned Ilia before
I am a big fan of Lilia getting to see
those sprites just come out of thin air
essentially and it's also They're both
the same domains, blue and green.
>> Yeah, they're mirror match basically.
Aside from the legends, we're going to
see a lot of the same sort of spells
here. Obviously, Lilia's signature spell
very, very strong. Counters a spell and
shuts down your opponent's turn when
that one is played. An AI spell, the
Firefox, it's still strong, but I don't
think it will be as relevant in this
particular matchup. However, we have had
our first turn of play.
>> It is the Raven Bloom student. uh very I
would say sta stand standard for these
types of spellheavy decks like Ahri is.
It gives you that extra might when you
play that spell on Raven Bloom Raven
Bloom Student and of course Raven Bloom
Student is going to go to Raven Bloom
Conservatory
>> which works really really well because
when you defend here reveal the top card
of your main deck and if it's a spell
put it into your hand otherwise recycle
it. So, it's really good deck control,
some great card filtering that can come
off the back of this Raven Bloom
Conservatory. So, I like the early
aggression, getting those points, and
Diana Linari. They're definitely looking
to filter through their deck quickly.
>> They are indeed. We see Miracus here
bringing out that Lilia on their turn.
And it has gone back, I believe, to our
digital Ari being able to play their
chosen, sorry, be able to play Diana. My
bad. And so that's uh another fairly
strong unit on the board right now. Up
goes Lilia. This is the Lilia that does
produce a lot of sprites. I'm trying not
to say the word that uh you guys might
have seen all over the internet. How
this I hope it's the same play style for
this Lilia where you really want to
produce a lot of sprites.
>> Yeah, I really am expecting to see
something like a sprite fountain here.
Maybe sprite queens, things of that sort
because that is what Lilia is all about.
But we just did get a C. We saw some
scuttle crab in there as well from
Unleash.
>> It's one of my favorite units just
because it's so like I think it's so
cute. I think it's also so versatile as
well, but it might not necessarily be
the strongest unit considering it only
has zero might, but I do love the way
that it reveals your opponent's hand. In
goes Lilia, leaving a fight behind and
goes to conquer black flame. But it's
not America's turn finished yet. They do
have all their runes up and they
probably want to try and figure out how
they can protect their Lilia. It's kind
of like protect the president once more.
>> That black flame alter though. Unity
would temporarily have shields. So,
we'll be looking to put as many sprites
as possible onto that black flame alter.
But we see that forgotten signpost.
>> Forgotten signpost. Exhaust a unit you
control. Move a different unit you
control to the location of the unit you
exhausted to pay for this ability. which
is one way that Americas can actually
keep their Lilia safe.
>> Yeah, a absolutely able to sort of
target that Lilia, bring it back to base
if needs be. We do see that is played.
It is resolved here exhausting three
runes and because of the legend ability,
it's actual cost is normally four and
exhaust, but it's reduced because of the
sprite.
>> Yeah, it is. So, pretty cheap ability. I
mean legend ability once you have lots
of sprites out able to then use that
signpost which is a gear activating it
and then now Lilant leaves another
sprite back on black flame alter. Yeah,
definitely creating a lot of board
presence here. Already having a total of
four units, but yes, sprites do have
that temporary, so they're not long for
this world. They do vanish before
scoring does occur. However, even having
that defenders have shield uh temporary,
right? It makes those sprites hold a
little bit more. It makes you question,
do I trade into a temporary or am I
happy to let that one go away?
>> Exactly. And I mean Diana here only has
three might as well, but they do of
course they're using the skyward strike
which will move an enemy unit. And oh,
interestingly, I love this strategy.
Digital is moving Miracus's Lilia onto
the Raven Bloom student.
>> Yeah. And using that Ahri passive so
effectively creating that showdown.
Lilia minus one might because of that
Ahri legend. Raven Bloom is going to get
pumped to three because of that Skyward
Strike and that will be a win there for
Digital because it's overcome the might.
So great play there. You do love to see
it. Diana looking to move into the Black
Flame altar.
>> I think that was incredible from
Digital. This Lilia is considered
probably one of the main uh tech of this
Lilia build where you want that Lilia to
be producing as many sprites as
possible. But now that it's off the
board, Digital is going to be moving in
onto this bride here. Three might versus
three might at the moment. But of
course, we can't forget about that black
flame alter.
>> He has a Thonk in hand. He always knew
that he had an answer. But instead, he
plays the stupify. So he'll actually be
able to take that sprite back down to
three might because it has that plus one
for the shield. And now Diana Lunari
will be three into three. And there's
the Ong Guard. Yes, that ong guard will
boost that Diana up to the might needed
to take down that sprite, meaning
Digital has gained another conquer
point, bringing them to three.
>> Yeah, three points is a great position
to be in this early in the game.
Obviously, the Lilia player here still
has a significant board presence, but
with those temporary, they will
disappear. So, right now, Miraoy is
going to have to rebuild from scratch.
However, signpost is present. has
forgotten to untap the legend here
though. That could prove devastating.
>> It could indeed. Whether or not they're
able to remember to that ready that um
Lilia, it might mean that they won't be
able to bring out those four sprites
once more. Oh, there it is. It's fine.
Everything's okay. And so, let's see
what they end up playing there. We can
see a couple of abilities, sorry, bit of
a couple of cards in their hand, of
course. Some key ones is Vex is there.
That's the
>> Vex. So we've got back off which is the
stun
>> discipline unchecked power as well. So a
powerful board sweeper there.
>> Out comes that sprite using the legend
ability and going to be ready going
straight into that Raven Bloom student.
There is one rune up in Digital's hand.
But before that there is that
discipline.
>> Discipline has been played. Digital
digging for answers here though will
likely try and respond. I don't think
he's willing to let this Raven Bloom go.
We do see the Ong Guard in his hand as
well. Another Diana Lunari here and it's
played.
>> It is played. I mean, America's did draw
off the discipline, but the on guard
doesn't means it's kind of the same
situation as before. So, out comes a
defy from Mira's defying that on guard.
>> Yeah, I mean, these are fast decks.
Mirakai wants to win hard and early. So,
that defy is going to get him that value
because he's going to conquer that
battlefield. Normally not something that
you would consider defying here, but if
Lilia can't win this game fast, hard,
and early, she's going to peter out
toward the back end.
>> Yeah, Lilia standard early aggro deck.
You definitely want to try and get as
many points on the board as quickly as
he can. Only at two at the moment, but I
don't know if Mira is going to be able
to do anything else this turn with all
the runes out. So, it's now Digital's
potential turn to answer back.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And Miraoy is shields
down. No runes up to respond to anything
that Digital might want to do as he
brings out that champion unit.
>> Yeah, that Ahri is out. Champion unit
does have to pay for that cost of course
for cycling a rune when I attack with
defense given an enemy unit here minus
two this turn to a maximum of one. That
is a really strong ability in pair with
the legend as well. So when Ari goes in
that sprite is only going to be at one
might.
>> Yeah, that definitely stacks. So it
could get to minus three might with the
Ahri and the champion there. It will be
interesting to see how Mirakai wants to
play around this one. We see that back
off. We see the lonely poor the in hand
as well as the unchecked and that
scuttle crab. So he will be able to get
some extra card draw if he goes with the
scuttle crab. However, Digital has opted
to pass the turn. Has two runes up. Is
in control of that black flame alter on
the bot side of the battlefield here.
Ricey.
Yeah, still in control of Black Flame
Alter. And of course, the sprite
disappears. No holding point from
Miracus because it's a sprite. And now,
let's see what Miracus is considering.
He has one hand, one card that he's
looking at, but I didn't get to catch
it.
>> Yeah, but he does have Sprite Fountain
in hand now as well. He just drew that
one off the top. So, that can definitely
get Lilia some tempo. And that's the Hay
we were talking about.
>> Such a versatile unit being able to do
three different options. If Miracus
plays a spell, he gets to draw one. If
>> he plays a gear, you ready? He's up two
runes. If he plays a unit, give that
give way plus three that turn. Out comes
also the uh the scuttle crab. But that's
all that Miracus is doing. Just building
up the the back of the face.
>> This is what we call a development turn,
Rice. So, you're absolutely right. When
Huay moves, you discard a card and based
on what you've discarded, you can pick
that mode. So, really good there. plays
that scuttle crab to draw that one
particular card, but also has a
fantastic death nail trigger. When it
dies, you choose an opponent, they
reveal their hand, you can look at their
face down cards and get XP. It's a
triple threat when it dies and it's
going to it's got zero mind on it.
>> Yes, it will very it it does struggle to
stay alive is one way of putting it, but
it still can conquer. So if there's an
open battlefield, you just put it in and
there is one conquer point. And yeah,
when you play me, he does get to draw
that one card as well. So that is really
good. Of course, for these uh spell
heavy decks that want to have as many
options in hand as possible.
>> Yeah, Digital currently on five conquest
points though is racing ahead here. I
must say I wasn't expecting the Ahri to
be the sort of early game aggro deck,
but just really controlling everything
that this Lilia wants to bring down on
the board
>> right now. digital considering his
options. We do see Mirakai has one up
and
>> the charm comes out is going to be moved
on to the black flame alter and don't
forget that legend of Ahri ability and
also Ari herself minus two to all units
when she attacks or defends and that
also minus
>> one on the legend ability. Yeah, total
of minus three when you attack into that
champion unit there. And that's what
he's going to force with his charm.
>> It's interesting now. I think they're
trying to work out the might totals.
>> Well, but we also has that ability where
he moves. He did get moved by the charm.
He can draw one and discard one, then do
the following based on the discarded
cards type. So, unsure exactly what
Micros is going to be deciding to
discard. So, we'll have to see what ends
up happening
>> in this situation because he's being
forced into combat. He definitely wants
to take out as much as he can. He's
forced the move. So, I would have to
imagine a unit is what he will discard
if he has a good unit to discard. And he
does. He has that lonely porro in hand.
So, that's worth it to go up and over
the top to eight might. Yes, the Ahri
combo will bring you back down to five,
but you're still going to be able to
take something out. Either that Diana or
that way, or if you can pump up again,
you can take them both out. surprising
digital here in a play that he wanted.
>> I'm trying to figure out if there's
anything they can use. America's can use
that one rune up for uh don't forget
like the on guard and everything like
that where you could use that to pump up
the the the units. Yeah, definitely a
great pump spell with that one energy up
there giving that friendly unit plus one
might this turn and an additional plus
one if it is on its own which this way
will be but discards that plundering
porro
>> plundering poor is discarded is at plus
three which means we can from matswise
sort of ignore the the minus three that
does so it's currently five versus six
on black flame ult right now in this
showdown what can Americas do now
>> but digital has a full hand of runes. He
can do whatever he wants. You remember
he kicked this off with that charm.
We're seeing the rune tapped.
>> He's doing the predict the Diana Lari
now that the showdown has been
triggered. When a showdown begins here,
you may pay one energy. If you do
predict, then reveal the top of the card
your main deck. And if it is a spell,
you can draw it.
>> Yep. If it is a spell, you can draw it.
So, let's see what is going to be
revealed here. as as I mean we barely
even started the showdown but that move
from was still that from that charm
effect so the showdown has technically
officially started.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean we have hit that
Diana Lunari trigger so it has
absolutely started the charm has
resolved the way move in with the unit
discard going up to that eight might
brought back down to five because of the
AR inquisitive minus two and the legend
minus one. So they're just having a
quick chat here to see how it's all
going to pan out. But Digital definitely
in a strong position. Three cards in
hand, six runes up. I have to imagine
there will be some spelling going on.
And may I remind you that Black Flame
alter right now useless. There are no
temporary units. So no one's getting any
shield buffs here either. It's a plain
old five into five while we deliberate.
>> We are deliberating. And I think I did
see the spell. It was in fact
>> discipline.
>> Oh god. Discipline. Discipline.
>> Yeah, definitely that discipline.
Interestingly,
>> he looked put it back looked again
revealed. So I think there was a
question around
>> how that sort of predict worked with
Diana Linari,
>> but it has resolved. The discipline has
gone to hand. Both players know that he
has that. So Miraai knows that digital
can pump up and over if need be, but has
opted not to play it.
>> Yep. Has I guess realizes that Digital
is probably going to win, especially
with that uh discipline that just got
picked up. I don't think America is
going to be able to pump Quay up enough
to be able to
>> Yeah, Digital pulled the discipline, but
he opted not to play that over the top
of play there. So quite an interesting
turn of play. Digital though does follow
up with Raven Bloom. Raven Bloom student
is going to get played. Sorry, conquers
on to Raven Bloom Conservatory, which
does bring Digital up to six. Now all
Digital needs to do is hold for the next
turn and potentially reach that A. But
Miracus has maybe
some answers. There is that scuttle
crab, but maybe it can conquer.
>> Well, we're still in Digital's turn
before we can even get to what Miritai
could do here. Dana Linari holding that
black flame alter as well as that Raven
Bloom student holding quite
appropriately if I do say so. The Raven
Bloom Conservatory as we are
deliberating. He knows he's in the
winning position right now. Has played
that second Diana Lunari Rise here.
>> Yeah, two Diana's out on play. And now
with that, Digital is passing it over.
He's choosing to keep that Diana in the
base right now. Keeping it safe.
Miracus, let's see if he draws a good
card. to see if they can be able to take
these battlefields because as we
mentioned before, Digital's on six right
now. If America's doesn't take at least
one, it's game.
>> Yeah, it could be game very, very
quickly. But unchecked power is
absolutely playable. It is 7 and two.
This might be the Hail Mary that Miracle
has to commit to here. May not be the
play he wants to make, but it is the
play he needs to make. That said, I
almost feel like Digital has read the
play. I feel like that's why he's played
that Lunar, the Dino Lunar to the base
so it doesn't get wiped out in the
unchecked power.
>> Yeah, the unrep power comes out, deals a
lot of damage to everyone. Of course,
you have to exhaust all your friendly
units and deal 12 to old units at a
battlefield, which in this case with
Miracus having the legend ability, I
don't know if you have enough runes
though to be able to bring out more
sprites. So, this may be all he can do
this turn.
>> Yeah, right now though, Digital trying
to get some value. He's played that
discipline, pumped it up for the might,
but to get that card draw before it does
go down. So, I do like that play cuz he
can't answer the unchecked power. He
obviously held his runes up to answer
something.
>> Out comes the sprite fountain,
>> which is probably the the best move he
can do right now. Be able to get that
sprite, get that conquer, go on to
three. But of course, Diana still exists
in the base.
>> Yeah, Diana though only three might. If
she swings into that black flame alter,
that sprite will have the four might
because of the black flame alter.
Defenders here with temporary have
shield one and a hidden card has been
played.
>> I wonder if that smoke and mirrors or if
it's something else. That's one of the
cards that I know that Lilia likes
having as a hidden card in their deck.
So curious to see what Miracus did hit.
I missed it completely. Did you catch
it?
>> No, unfortunately we didn't get a look
into their hand. So I didn't see if
Mirakai played that smoke and mirrors.
He does have two lonely porros in hand
here though. And a third card sneakily
tucked away at the back. Oh, my eyes
aren't that good. I'm aging here.
However, we are, I believe, over to
Digital. He's on the play. In goes Diana
on to Raven Bloom Conservatory. Any
answer for Miracus? Doesn't look like
it. That is going to be seven points
now. Going to be using that ability.
Going to be predicting and seeing what
they're going to do.
>> So, that's actually kicks off at the
beginning of that sort of combat
showdown. There we do see the thousand
tail watcher revealed off the top. Raven
Bloom Conservatory has been conquered.
Seven for Digital, three for Murkai.
Miraai has to do something here. He
hasn't been able to develop a strong
board state to answer the aggression
coming out of this Ahri deck. But what I
am loving is the adaptation here and he
passes turn with so many runes open.
That's a dangerous thing to have to play
into Rice. I mean, Digital is going for
that hold point for that victory. And we
all know how green and blue decks work
when you're holding, especially with
that AI legend ability as well. Out
comes another sprite from the Sprite
Fountain. Um, and so Americas does have
a sprite to work with here and the um
scuttle crab. But what else did we see
in his hand?
>> Yeah, there is that Lilting Lullabi as
well. I do believe we just saw in hand.
So he does have a counter should he need
it into whatever Digital is playing. And
not only can he counter, we did see the
flank from Digital. Not only can he
counter with Liling Laai, but it shuts
down your opponent in their turn, which
is a fantastic piece of tech here. So
we'll just take a quick squeezy, counter
a spell. Its controller can't play
spells this turn and it's at reaction
speed, Ricey.
>> It is. Out comes that discipline to try
and buff that sprite to try and get over
the reh minus one. So Diana now at
three. Marcus at five four
>> 3 2 1.
>> Well yeah plus two minus one from the RA
now sitting at four. So how comes the
discipline from Digital? Look at the
cards. Look at the runes that he has up.
>> He has all of the answers available to
him there. That discipline is on the
board, but I don't see the tapped runes
for it just yet. Rise. He does have that
thonk there though, so it will be
interesting to see.
>> He does. Let's see what else happens
between these two. I mean, Marcus only
has two more runes up. So, let's see
what happens here. He might have to be
forced to use another buffing or as you
said thonk or something like that to try
and win this fight cuz Mirus has to win
here to be able to take this or stay in
the game really.
>> Yeah, he absolutely has to because if
Dino Linari holds it's Digital's game.
So Mirakai is doing everything he
possibly can here. He's got a lot of
exhausted runes down there in his side
of the board. And Digital has so many
runes, unexhausted, not exhausted, that
he could do everything. I think that
might even be a Skyward Strike. It looks
like a thong. So, he could move a unit,
he could stun. Skyward Strike is an
interesting choice into a nonXP deck as
well. They're valuing the move a unit
more than the stun that is provided on
the back end when you get that extra XP.
I mean, we did see the skyward strike
being used earlier, like very early in
the game. And that completely took out
Lilia Forn, which was really important.
And there is that signature spell that
we were talking about. It is the lilting
ly. And it prevents that discipline from
occurring in the first place and also
prevents Digital from doing any other
spells. This could be what Miraus
needed.
>> Yeah, it will keep Mirakai in the game
and it will resolve. I did not see any
counters in Digital's hand there. So,
he's doing everything he can to stay in
this game. He's got the two sprites.
He's got the scuttle crab right now.
That signpost, which he can still use,
by the way. It is a gear. It sticks
around. He can exhaust and move units as
he needs. But Digital, unfortunately,
with that liilting lullaby resolution,
it will shut his turn down.
>> We're just taking a moment to breathe.
We're
>> considering our options.
We're playing this one out slowly
because if Mirakai is able to win this
showdown, he'll push Dino Lunari off
conquer for himself
>> and Digital will have to work that much
harder to keep himself in the game.
Yeah, no units in base right now on
Digital's side, but he does have a
little bit of breathing room considering
he is sitting on seven, but Miracus,
he's got a little bit more to get up to
that seven as well. If he conquers, if
he's able to win this um showdown, he'll
be sitting at four points. And that's
still a three-point difference.
>> Yeah, three points is not an
insurmountable amount of points to
overcome here as we're just taking that
breather. And like we were saying again
earlier, right? We've got the mind,
we've got the body domains here. They're
just playing around one another. Do we
have the defies? Do we have potentially
another unchecked power? Not that now
would be a good time to play that one,
though. There's barely any units on any
of those battlefields. You know,
potentially we have the stupifiers.
We've seen the Skyward Strikes and the
Thon, which are very good for those sort
of combat based showdowns that we
currently do find ourselves in. But with
that Liling Lullabi having been played,
countering that discipline and shutting
down Digital,
>> I think Murakai could take this one.
>> It's actually possible at least take
that battlefield. I can see that
happening. Um, still has a couple of uh
that play of Lily might be what he needs
to be able to, as you said, take that
battlefield and bring himself to four.
And it's going to be back to, as you
said, no more units in in um Digital's
hand. So, it's going to be an uphill
battle for Digital to build that board
back up.
>> Yeah, you're so right. With only spells
and no units, it will be a challenge to
develop that board state and be able to
contest those battlefields. Whereas
Lilia can just make sprites all day
every day and then chuck them on the
black flame alter where they're nice and
tanky, four mites a unit. And if you
don't have units, you can't do anything
about it. So, this could be quite the
pivotal moment, which is why we're
taking a minute just to make sure we've
got it all correct here. I see.
>> Exactly. We don't want to make uh we
want to make sure that these two players
are able to fight each other properly
fairly and everything like that as well.
And I'm really excited to see I've been
excited to see Lilia all day. So I'm
really excited to see of course how
Lilia bounces back from I mean if this
is the moment if this is the pivotal
moment that Lilia bounces back I think
that's pretty exciting.
>> Well that's the thing right we were
talking about Lilia coming into this and
that you love Lilia as a deck and all
about the sprite generation. She's an
early high aggro tempo deck, right? And
so far, we just haven't seen that. So
far, it's been a really, really slow
Lilia game.
>> Yeah,
>> but what I'm liking is the resilience.
>> We're still seeing this Lilia be able to
contest this board state right now. And
we are back.
>> We are in fact back. It looks like we're
doing the reveal from Diana going down
at the bottom. Going to reveal now the
stupify and he gets to keep it in hand.
Yeah, it will be interesting to see how
this uh judge call went. Obviously, we
went back a few steps re-revealing that
thousand tower watcher uh that stupify
off the top which Murkai gets that
information now knows Digital has that
too. However, Miraai, I can't see all of
his runes. I believe they may all be tap
exhausted right now. And uh yeah, Miraai
takes the battlefield.
>> I think that's all on the back of that
lilting lullabi. We can see that in the
trash that it was used. And so Americ
points has that also second sprite now
on four. Black Flame Alter has been
conquered.
>> Yeah. And now Digital finds himself up
against it with no units to play right
now. He will have to hopefully top deck
this one. He does have that stupify
though, so we'll be able to draw another
one. We see back off has been drawn. So
still not a unit. Those sprites are
present and they will continue uh
unfortunately to be a problem, but due
to their temporary nature, they will
disappear before they get to hold those
points. And there's that stupify. He's
searching. He's trying to find those
units.
>> Yeah, he did get that draw up. And I it
was successful. He top decked that Raven
Bloom student. Out it comes immediately.
And well, I don't know if he's got
anything to move it on to a battlefield.
Maybe. not onto a battlefield, does have
that Skyward Strike. So, what he can do
is move that Raven Bloom onto either of
his preferred battlefields and then
start dragging Murkai's units into him
and forcing the fights on his terms. So,
definitely not a bad unit to pick up
here as we just double check and make
sure. And it looks like Digital is going
to pass the turn with that hand signal.
He does have about eight runes ready to
go though, so Miraai, he has to play
carefully.
>> Has to play very carefully. now on five
points from those conquers previously
and doesn't get the hold points of
course. So now five and seven he's
catching up. Murky is in fact catching
up quite quickly here. Does have of
course the legend to be able to bring
out that sprite to maybe conquer again.
But I don't know if I saw any other
sprite plays in hand. Two lonely powers
which we've seen quite a few times now.
But let's see what he actually plays.
Yeah, those lonely porros though, he he
could just play them out, get some board
presence and get some card draws. But
instead, he's opted for the legend
ability from that Lilia and gets that
sprite ready straight onto the
battlefield.
>> Yeah, and there's that sprite able to
get Murky now to six points. Going to
move scuttle crab and get them to seven
now too. That does mean that they are on
the exact same points.
>> Yeah, suddenly we have a game on our
hands. Seven conquer points aside.
Did I see a uh Thousand Tailed Watcher
in the head of Merakei?
>> I don't believe we did. We did see him
reveal one earlier. That's a Thonk a
Skyward a back off. Can't identify the
last one. Very, very purple though in
its nature, but Murkoy looking up.
Sorry, Murkoy looking to shore up his
defenses. He knows he just needs to hold
the one, so he's going to concede this
black fame alter. is a temporary unit
and he's going to put everything into
that Raven Bloom Conservatory. Both
players here, seven conquers points a
piece, Ricey,
>> seven conquer points a piece. It really
is Digital's turn to try and stop Micki
from getting that hold point. Has to try
and conquer well at least uh Raven Bloom
Conservatory because Blackfam Ulta won't
give that holding point. Digital has so
many runes up. Is that 12 or 12 runes?
Has a lot of spells. He knew that he
only had spells essentially and Raven
Bloom student loves spells.
>> Raven Bloom student is the biggest fan
of spells I've ever seen in the world.
Uh Donna, no longer human. Probably
close second. She gets two per pump. But
Digital going to have to decide what to
do here. 12 runes and a lot of spells
including that defy he just drew as
well. So he will be able to shut down
those shenanigans. Charm too. So a lot
of control here. He will be able to drag
Mirakai into fights he doesn't want.
Yep.
>> But he still has to get onto that
battlefield in the first place for Icy.
>> He does. He has to get onto that
battlefield where the Lonely Pearl and
Rift, sorry. And Scutter Crab is lying
in weight. And it should be a pretty
easy fight for Digital judging by the
the number of spells in hand, the number
of runes up. Out comes back off first
and is going to be able to stun probably
the Lonely Pearl. I would probably go to
stun the biggest thing which would
absolutely be the lonely porro because
scuttle crab presents no might at all
rice here.
>> And the pump has begun to back off
putting that plus one might on raven
bloom too.
>> Nice. And with that maki is going to
have to of course uh put them in the
trash but he gets a look at digital
cards hand from that death now from
scuttle crab. And now he can see
everything that we could see as well.
Look at all those spells and they're all
green.
>> Yay. Absolutely. The flonk, the charm,
the defy, the skyward strike, and I
missed that last one before we went back
to this shot. I'm sure we'll get another
look at it, but this is full
information. And there it is. Ah, it's
the new unleashed, the frisky hunter. I
think it is the
>> um m uh mouser.
>> Oh, the mutated mouser. So, I love the
mouser. That's why I was like, I know
it's the mouser mutated
mouser, which has that tank and shield
ability.
>> Yeah, it's so strong at holding
battlefields as well. If you get that
out nice and early like we saw in that I
game, it can be a real problem
especially with Ahri combining that
minus one from the legend and
potentially that and there it is. It's
played on that battlefield. He's looking
to shore this one up and hold it for the
win here. I see.
>> Exactly. That is what Digital wants to
do. That mutated Mau as we said does
have that plus two shield when a
defender and is a tank and combined with
the AR legend. It's a pretty scary
battlefield right now.
>> Yep. Murkai has full information on
every card in Digital's hand except the
freshly drawn on guard.
>> So Digital will be able to pump it up
even more than Murkai's math can
calculate right now.
>> And we can see the number of runes that
Digital has up. He is ready to pump that
Mouser or pump actually sorry pump the
Raven Blade suit cuz that would be the
best option. But there is that
singularity.
>> He does have Oh, it's outed to fire
range as well. Can't use that one to
answer this. He can't pump them big
enough to get over the six damage that
Singularity. He could invest every
single spell and save the Raven, but
it's just not worth it. That does
eliminate Digital's unit. And we know
that there's a chance that if he top
decks a unit, he might have a unit in
hand, but we know he does not have a
unit in hand for the next turn. So now
America here is going to be playing the
lonely parro.
>> Diana Lunari top decked. He has the
unit.
>> He does. But the problem is all right so
Daniel Larry will be played digital will
likely pass turn Makai will ready up
conquer a battlefield but because he may
not be able to conquer oh no with the
sprite
>> right this might be game Mai does have
access to that ledge where he can of
course exhaust it and produce that
sprite and then he'll be able to conquer
both battlefields on next round. There
it is. Digital does does the fist bump
and it's going to be Mira winning game
one. Yeah, Mai wins game one of our
round three best of three match here.
Ricey in a close and tense
>> 8 to seven. I mean, Digital, he was
racing away at seven conquest points to
Mira's one at one stage. And to come
back from that has to feel good.
>> Definitely has to feel real good. I
personally when I lose my chosen
champion that early, I start sweating a
little bit. And Murakai though was able
to keep the cool and be able to come
back from that huge deficit 3 to7 and
now take that first game victory. Of
course sideboarding is happening. I want
to have a little bit of a sneaky beak.
Looks like that was a not so fast and
two zas I saw.
>> Yeah, I think I saw two not so fast in
there as well.
>> Yeah. So good sideboard tech. Not so
fast. Definitely a really really strong
answer into a lot of things but also
critically elder dragons should that
come up. We are just taking a look.
Miraai passing a card over to our judge
who has approved that card with that
little head nod there just to say yep no
worries all good to go here I see but
that was a great game one and we take a
quick look at these deck list look at
that overnumbering overnumbering
overnumbered plundering porro I do love
that they treat these cards with such
phenomenal art there's that unchecked
power oh my goodness even Miraai had
2,000 tail watches.
>> Yeah, I I thought I saw a Thousand
Tailed Watcher in the hand, but he
didn't need it. The singularity was in
fact better as uh so many spells in the
hands of Digital, it was just much
better to just
like blast them from above.
>> Kaboom.
>> Kaboom. Exactly.
>> That's it. But a lot of new unleash tech
here as well. That back off with the
stun proving invaluable. If played from
hand, you also get a draw. that
forgotten signpost able to move around.
Scuttle crab. Scuttle crab seems to be
rising as an allar for most calm decks
here.
>> No, I personally agree with that, but
I'm happy to be corrected as well. But
but cuz I also find scuttle crab to be
super useful being able to get that draw
on play for only two uh energy and also
the benefits when scuttle crab
inevitably dies.
>> That's it. But take a quick look at
those battlefields. We've got the
Arena's Greatest and Rockfall Path as
well. So, Arena's Greatest, fantastic at
accelerating the game. Each of you get
one conquer point at the start of your
first turn and Rockfall Path units can't
be played here.
>> That's really interesting tech for a
sprite deck like Lilia where you just
ready your sprite. Well, you play your
sprite sprite in base and then it's
ready so you can just go onto that base.
So, it really works well for Lilia.
>> Yeah, minimal negative impact there for
that Lilia, but I have to imagine
they're indexing into the maximum
negative impact for their opponents. Uh,
Dead Bloom Predators have been out there
in the Dazzlings and the mid-range Ye
deck, so that could be a strong answer
into that. And we do get to take a look
at Digital's deck as well. So, a lot of
very similar cards here. We do get to
see that Thousand Tail Watcher. Both of
them running two copies
>> at least in their main deck. We have we
aren't seeing their sideboard just yet,
but you're completely right. Two,
Thousand Tower Watch. Of course, we have
three Raven Bloom students as well. And
the What do you think of the battlewoods
for this?
>> Yeah. So, Grove of the God Willow does
not surprise me. When you hold here, you
may draw one. So, I do like that
abandoned hall. Very, very strong. Two.
When a player uh plays a spell, you may
Yeah. So, that's the one might. So,
we're expecting to see that in Aurelia
as well. When you play a spell, you can
give a unit here one might. So that's
that opportunity to turn those defiant
dances into six might swings.
>> I love that uh Digital is also running
the sprite burst, but we didn't get to
see any of them. It would have been
really fun to see the sprites versus
sprites, but not just yet. Not sure of
course what Digital will be
sideboarding, so maybe we'll be still be
able to see it here in this next game,
but of course time will tell.
>> Yeah, that's it. But also the three
copies of Diana Lunari, they're valuing
that predict being able to get through
their deck. You look at the one on the
top, you either put it back or recycle
it to the bottom and then you draw a
card. So great sort of deck control,
deck management coming out there. The
value on the stuns is interesting.
Obviously the back offs
>> preventing a lot of your swings into
them. So, it's an interesting choice
because obviously sort of mitigates a
lot of the swing that opponents want to
bring into her.
>> I don't see any way from a quick glance
for Digital to be able to gain
experience. So, that Skyward Strike will
always stay at move an enemy unit and
won't be able to stun them as well.
>> Yeah. No, that's very, very true. A lot
of people are running Skyward Strike but
not building up the XP for it. They
value that move an enemy unit. It's
literally a charm. It just cost one
extra energy and the same power. So it
gives you more consistency in that game
of dragging them.
>> Yeah, it makes a lot of sense to me. And
we don't know what the sideboard is. So
maybe there is some experience play, but
I honestly do not expect that at all. I
think as you were saying and what a lot
of people are playing that Skyward
Strike is super strong even without any
experience.
>> Yeah. However, we have a lot of
experience talking about Riftbound here.
pricey as we do take a quick little
glance back at that sort of game one
battlefield matchup. The Raven Bloom
Conservatory into that Black Flame
Alter. Neither of them really proving,
dare I say, pivotal in this game. They
they did what was expected to be done of
them on average.
>> Yeah, nothing super duper exciting. I'm
very curious to see whether or not
Digital is going to go for the um
abandoned hole or it's going to be the
Grove of the God Willow for Digital.
>> Yeah, a great showing there with that
grove of the Godwillow when you hold
here draw one. So definitely looking to
get a lot of units down onto that
battlefield and force Murkai into him,
which is obviously the strong strategy
of Ahri, but Murkai has picked up that
rockfall path. Units can't be played
here. I think these are pretty good
battlefields that they have chosen. I
mean, Digital presumably will be going
first here. So, wants to try and get
onto Grove of the God as soon as they
can and start holding. Well, of course,
Murky doesn't really do much holding as
the sprite. I say sprite queen, but so
as little with a billion and one sprite.
>> She is indeed the queen of the sprites,
though.
>> Yep. I I agree. I totally agree. But we
don't want to get mixed up with the
actual sprite queen, which I don't
remember if I saw in his deck. No, I
don't think we did actually. But I
really do appreciate the energy there.
Lilia with that aggression. She's
definitely much more of a conquer deck
than a hold deck. Doesn't want to stick
around for too long as these two,
they've shuffled up. They are ready here
to play Ricey. And uh they've got their
notepads. That's one of my favorite
things about these games, right? They
they've got their notepads where they
write down their conquers, they write
down their holds, they keep track of the
point scoring. It's just another way of
ensuring that yes indeed everything is
right. I have to believe this. We've got
units on the playmat already too.
>> Yep. I think that's a Diana Lunari that
we see. We've got runes down. We're
already into game two here. Ricey
between this Ahri and Lilia legend
between Digital and Mira. From what I
can see as well, looks like Mirakai
already has a sprite on the bottom
battlefield and units. Lilia is up on
the Grove of Gold Willow and of course
with that hidden card. I wonder what it
is. Is it smoke? It's a back off. We'll
see in a little bit as super fight does
come out from digital first going to be
minus one mining to the Lilia and of
course get that draw.
>> There it is. You called it.
>> Mirez comes out, which does mean that we
can move that Lilia to safety and move
the sprite back. But what happens when
Lilia moves, Logan?
>> Oh, she um leaves behind another sprite.
>> Leaves behind a trail of sprites. And
that is exactly what's going to happen.
Out comes that sprite from the transfer,
from the switch, and there leaves
another sprite behind in her trail.
>> Absolutely. I didn't want to say the way
that the sprite was left, hence the
pause. I was like, looking up another
word here, but it's a six might into a
three might showdown right here, right
now. And Digital considering his
options, does have three runes up that
he could exhaust at a moment's notice
and not so fast. A back off, a turn to
dust as well.
>> Turn to dust is really interesting
because can you would you use it on that
Sprite fountain or would you hold it for
something more nefarious later on in the
game? But that skyward strike, you could
maybe move one of the sprites away is
one option. I'm not sure what you would
do here either because you wouldn't
really want to skyward strike their
Lilia back into that battle. It's kind
of not the right goal there.
>> Yeah, and you do value your Diana
Lunari, but obviously Digital here
conceding that one, allocates the damage
over to one of the sprites and Miracy
happy with that does conquer that
battlefield. We do find Mira on two
conquer points at the moment to digitals
one right now.
>> Turn to dust does get used on that
sprite fountain and
will be turned temporary.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Yep. Temporary has been applied to that
sprite fountain. And if we do take a
quick look at sprite fountain, it does
read temporary. Yeah.
>> So when you play this player ready three
might sprite unit with temporary. And it
also has a death nail. Repeat this gears
play effect. So you'll get two sprites
out of that one. But
>> yeah, out goes the sprite going on to
rockfall path. Able to get that conquer
point. Now on three and Lilia goes on to
grow of the god Willow and leaves
another sprite behind. Now wondering how
is America's going to try and protect
Lilia here. We don't see any units
though in Digital's hand. So maybe maybe
Lilia is safe for now. But what is the
play here?
>> It feels like a rough draw and it's a
great question. And if Digital doesn't
have units, then he can't really contest
what this Lilia is doing. And this is
Lilia in fine form here. We do see that
Thousand Tower Watcher, but that's a
late game card. And we're not there yet.
He can't even afford it. Ricey,
meanwhile, Mirakai is going to hold up
to six points next turn if Digital can't
do anything about it.
>> Yeah, with that Lilia on the path, the
God Grove of God will give Mira that
hold point, but Rockwell path of course
with the sprite will change things. Ari
gets played when I hold score one point.
He's switched up the uh
>> yeah sideboarded the champion.
>> Dude, the champion unit has changed to
Ahri Alli.
>> Yeah, not one we see too often actually
getting those champions switched out and
we were talking about it. We're like,
"Oh, we haven't actually seen the green
Ahri in quite some time, but there it
is." And we also got a sneak peek at
Murkai's hand. He does have that
unchecked power in hand in case of
emergency. So that's got to feel good
for him that if it does get to the late
game, he'll have the answers. But he's
at five conquest points. I just don't
see this getting to the late game. I
see.
>> I can see definitely why with that
Ariuring the Grove of the God Willow.
That would have been an amazing combo if
Ahri, if Digital can get on to that
Grove of the God Willow. Mai is going to
be moving Lilia Forn back into base back
into safety knowing that Ari is about to
approach. Lily's behind a sprite though
just to, you know, give a bit of
defense.
>> Sprite. Sprite. Sprite. Sprite. Sprite.
Sprite. Everybody. Lilia is leaving
enough sprites for everybody and then
some. And that's what you want to be
seeing when you are playing this new
unleash legend Lilia Bashful Bloom
because this is the set that's focused
very heavily on junglers. And that's
what we're getting right now. We're
getting this jungler just absolutely
ganking this Ahri. It just doesn't feel
like there's much of a response coming
out of Digital into the pressure being
applied from this early game legend. And
then we do see
>> sprite burst coming out. It's going to
be able to bring out two more sprites.
And that will mean that the god of go of
God is going to be having a six might uh
showdown potentially in the future. And
the other sprite is going to be played
in base because you can't play on rough
path. Taps the sorry exhaust the legend
and will go forward onto ruffle path
with those two sprites as well. That's
six might on both battlefields. Yeah, be
very surprised if Digital's able to find
a response to this one right now.
Obviously, they do have temporary. They
will depart, but he still has to fight
his way into them if he wants to
conquer, get some more points, and then
hold and start cashing in that card draw
from that grove of the God Willow. Right
now though, Mira one turn away from
winning Rice. He is on that six point
threshold. And as we've said before,
that sort of even number points so much
more important than those odds. Unless
of course you're on that aspirin climb.
We've got to remember he's in that
thousand tail watcher range now.
>> Yeah, Digital could bring that out right
now. That could help because it's going
to minus three everybody. And the spike
only at three. So it's going to be
pretty useful for Digital if he uses it
right now. And I think we called it. It
is out. It's in play.
>> There it is. Accelerated ready to roll.
pushing in on that grove of the God
Willow and Mira goes, "Yep, all yours,
buddy." And so Digital goes to two.
>> He does go to two, but we did see
Murkai's hand. We know of that unchecked
power, so I'm not sure if uh Digital's
going to be able to come back too much.
Ari goes and claims Rockfall path now at
three points. Mai still on six points.
Does have Lilia in base as well.
>> We did see actually thousand tail watch
in Mirakai's hand also. I think we I
think he actually has two copies and an
unchecked power. This is a Lilia that is
presenting a fantastic early game state,
but is able to answer those late game
threats as well with their own. So
Mirakai, I feel like he's built a
fantastic Lilia deck here. There it is.
>> Unchecked power does get used and that
eliminates the entire board. Digital is
completely exhausted. No runes are ready
right now. And of course, Lilia is now
going to be exhausted though. not be
able to conquer, but I think is pretty
happy with that round being able to get
rid of all the units. Once again,
Digital has nothing.
>> I have to imagine that Mirakai has a
play next turn to conquer both in the
same turn. So, unless Digital is able to
get onto a battlefield this turn, I
frankly think Mirac has got this game
from here. Icy,
>> exactly. He has that Lilian base will
become ready next on the start of his
turn. Will be able to also uh exhaust
his legend to bring out that ready spite
as well. Be able to conquer both. But
out comes that discipline trying to get
another car, trying to find any sort of
units.
>> Really unusual there cuz obviously he
had no units. So he actually pumped up
the Lilia and threw into another
discipline which is not what you want to
see right now when you're searching for
those units.
>> I guess he has to discipline the Lilia
again. Make it a very uh
>> very disciplined Lilia.
>> Exactly. And there it is. Another
discipline comes out. Another draw one.
Is this card on God? This is painful.
No, he's passed the turn over to
Miracle.
Ready's up that Lilia.
>> Yeah, I think this is game. All Miracy
needs to do is go in, get that seven
point. Out comes the sprite. Sprite is
not ready though. But that legend
ability will bring out that ready
sprite.
>> That's it. That's it. We're looking at
Digital. I don't He could stun the unit,
but Zero might still conquer a
battlefield.
>> The sprite's outy. It is out and this
might be it. Mai just making sure the
notes are correct before they go in and
conquer. They fist bump. Murkai wins
this round three. A two.
>> A 200 clean sweep for Murkai here in our
round three best of three matchup. Ari
into Lilia. Lilia takes it. Proving
extremely resilient in that game one.
and then showcasing that early game
aggression we expect from Lilia in game
two.
>> I love the plays that Digital did make
in that game one. Able to eliminate that
Lilia faith so early in the game. I
think that was pivotal to try and put a
lot of pressure on Murkai. But as you
said, the resilience from Murkai was
phenomenal. Able to come back from that
deficit and take game one and of course
take game two in such a fast fashion.
>> Yeah, that singularity though really
proving fantastic. a really strong
removal piece and then seeing yet
another unchecked power drawn from mind.
I really have to think that this
unchecked power, we're going to be
seeing it in almost every mind domained
deck that we have here at the regionals
because everybody knows that the Elder
is out there, but not just the Elder,
it's still a good answer into
overwhelming board states
>> like that one that we just had. But I
mean it wasn't overwhelming in when you
consider like you know other body
domains with you know the 12 might units
that you could potentially have but this
one was still quite overwhelming for
these little sprites. We had five might
Ahri and I can't remember what else was
on the board at the time but it was
enough to bring out that unchecked power
and take that game.
>> I do want to shout out though that we
did get to see like we called that
champion unit switcheroo the the change
up there in that sideboard. It's always
great to see these sideboard techs.
Obviously, Digital grab that turn to
dust as well. Hoping to get some value
out of that one, preventing that spite
fountain from getting its second trigger
of those sprites. Kind of slowing
hopefully that tempo, that game plan
down. But, uh, just a really I liked the
difference in the matchups despite both
being in mind and body.
>> Mind and calm.
>> Yeah, mind.
>> So much. Yes, you're so right.
>> My Yeah, mind. It's it's so good to see
how Ahri and Lilia both play and they
played really excitingly. I know that
Ari is not considered meta meta meta,
but we have so many fans of Ahri still
and uh being able to start this day two
is pretty good still. Now though, only
2-1. We'll have to see who's going to
get that best of Ahri.
>> Yeah, Murkai finding himself at three
and zero. Three wins, zero losses, zero
draws is a fantastic way to start the
Riftbound regional qualifiers here in
Sydney.
It is a start that anyone would envy and
I cannot wait to get to those player
interviews to kind of get some insights,
get into the minds of these players and
understand the choices in these decks
and the the timing of the players that
they've made. But let's throw over to
pastry time.
>> Thank you very much, Logan. I'm here
with the winner of our round three
feature match, Morocus. Willie, you're
looking very good. How did you find
those games? I honestly thought I lost
the first game because it looks very
dire and
yeah I I don't know how I put the win
off but I did.
>> Well, game two looks very dominant. Was
that kind of the game plan your deck is
expecting to use every game? Uh, not
really. But, uh, most of the time I see
leaders being played uh, very
aggressively, but I don't feel like it
should be played that way because
it's just
a lot of counters will blow you out and
>> you'll just lose right out.
>> Okay. So, how do you think Lilia should
be played then? How how should players
be approaching the champion?
>> Uh, I play it more towards a mid-range
build. Yeah. I think uh they have seen
the my my special tech, the signpost.
>> Yeah,
>> I don't think a lot of people know what
it does.
>> Every time I get asked
>> like what what does the sign do?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, it looks good. Um I'm curious. So
40 legends in Unleash. How did you
settle on Lilia for this event?
>> Uh I love Lilia.
>> Yeah,
>> I love playing Lilia.
>> Uh I did play League and uh I love
playing Lilia in the game too because I
love going fast.
>> Nice. Yeah, this game uh of Riftbound,
it's also on the faster side uh for
Lilia. So, it's just, you know, right at
home.
>> Yeah.
>> Nice. So, what did you expect to play
matchup wise? What's the match up you're
not looking forward to facing? Maybe
>> Aurora. Aurora.
>> Aurora. Have you hit any yet?
>> Uh I played one during the pre-e.
>> Okay.
>> Uh I didn't see any of my uh ways to
take away their Aurora. I didn't see any
ways to take away their units, too.
Yeah.
>> So, it's just very difficult to play
because all my units are very small.
>> Yeah. What matchups are you happy to see
then? What do you want to pair into?
>> Honestly, anything other than
>> Yeah, fair enough. Uh, so so far so
good. How are you feeling about your
chances to maybe win the best of AI?
Obviously, a lot of different best ofs
are on the table. How are you feeling
given that your record's quite good
early on in the RQ?
>> I'll try my best.
>> Okay. Well, I think you're doing pretty
well so far. Thank you so much for the
interview.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. We're going to throw it back
to the casters.
Loved hearing that insight there from
Miracus. It's it's fantastic to hear how
he came to decide to play Lilia. I think
that's a lot of reasons uh the same
reason that a lot of us choose which
legend to play. We have such fond
memories of playing these legends in
League of Legends. And so I mean I
that's why I kind of like Lily as well.
I think she's amazing in League of
Legends. So that's kind of why I have an
eye on her.
>> I think you'll find so many people here
who played League of Legends and then
they they find these legends. their
champions in League and then they're
legends here in Roofbound, so you kind
of get mixed up, but then they come over
here and you go, "Oh, I like the play
style." And that's what translates
really, really well actually from LOL
into Roofbound is the play styles. So,
Ael, she wants to dash around and
conquer a lot of battlefields at the
same time. And oh, we're into our second
featured matchup here. And we find
ourselves at one game a piece.
>> One all at the moment between Ireelia
and Master Yi. Wu Master is this is this
is the experience. This is the new Yi.
This is exciting to me because I did
play the proven grounds year, but this
new experience um master Wuji master,
lots of masters in there um is very
different or not quite different, but
it's like very different with all the
experience.
>> Yeah, for sure. Experience being that
new mechanic that has come to the four
with the unleash set here. The level six
with, you know, the level 11 as well,
the being ready, the extra might on the
board, very very helpful. That new
Master Yi champion unit has a lot going
for him when he comes online around that
level six XP mark. And because it's new,
it's harder to play around. It's it's
more that you need to learn and
understand. But let's take a look at the
board state here. Codzilla four runes
exhausted, three up. Sequinox all runes
up. Does have that Vex apathetic on that
battlefield with that stun, that very
power. Oh, and he moves it across there.
must have the boots of swiftness to
conquer that other battlefield.
>> Makes sense to me. And now on five
points, but Claude Zilla still on zero.
A bit of a rough situation for this Mari
Ru master player who is two in the uh
regional so far. So has a game or two
under their belt um of a win. And in
this situation, it's 1. So these two
players are definitely wanting to try
and keep that win streak going. Ireelia
is in base. Fervent has been played,
but I exhausted can't be played onto
sunken temple at the moment, but it's
going is going to hide a card there.
What card is could it be
>> in Aurelia? It's likely a Z. I do
believe that Z is still very prevalent.
Uh uh other it's chaos as well though,
so we could get the tide turners. We
could get the switcheroos.
something to change up those showdowns,
those fights. But my money will be on
the zas to protect that Vex apathetic.
It does have the swiftwood boots. So it
is a six might unit with ganking and
deflect. So it is hard to remove. And I
think a lot of people underestimate that
Vex apathetic in an Aurelia deck could
definitely be that queen that you can
protect as well.
>> Yeah,
>> definitely doesn't pop off as high and
hard as the Aurelia, but in a pinch can
do the job. And the job right now is to
hold that point, get themselves to six
as Quzilla is considering, do we bring
out the Mari? Where do we put the Massi?
I'm not entirely sure what experience
level um Quadilla is at, but judging
from how many units are on the board
right now. I think he had a really poor
draw.
>> Yeah, we do only see that discipline
coming down for that champion Yi. So
coming out so early does speak that
there are potentially no units in hand.
We did see that gromp down there which
has that hunt mechanic. When I conquer a
hold, I get additional experience.
>> Uh, however, plus two might for that ye
onto that star tipped peak looking to
conquer that one. So, when you conquer
when you hold here, you channel one rune
exhausted. So, it's a bit of ramp there.
Two
has seven runes available.
They flip through these cards so
quickly. Rise.
Sonox has two runes up as well for
himself if he decides to use a potential
maybe death of himself. He is of course
running Ireelia which is a calm domain.
Um and is going to actually consider it.
There are the two runes. They have been
exhausted. It is invite discipline as
well. He will get to draw as well. Going
to be disciplining the Vex of course
>> doubly disciplined just like Lilia in
that last game. We've seen two played
obviously on different units this time
around. But it is good to see that very
strong calm domain card. Ooh,
>> defy comes out. It's going to be define
discipline which means does not get that
draw as well. Out comes that hidden
card. It is in fact that zas. You did
guess correctly predict exactly what was
in that hidden card. So Vex does not
get eliminated.
>> Yeah. So the z has been recalled.
There's a timing there that you can
actually reveal and recall. Uh obviously
saving the Vex still there on that
battlefield is presenting that six might
into that six might of the Y. We still
have a decision point coming through
from Codzilla here. He's exhausted the
two discipline again. Ricey
>> going to be disciplining that master Y.
I'm wondering if he has a Skyward
Strike. Maybe he's going to try and
bring somebody else in later in the
round because he still has four runes up
and a very very mighty Master Yi. Yeah,
I did see one of the cards in Codzilla's
hand here though. It is one of those new
unleashed ye, the Master Yi unstoppable.
So that's 12 energy, three power for 12
might and its cost is reduced
significantly as you gain more
experience. So it's important for
Godzilla to get this Yi onto this
battlefield and stick has that hunt
mechanic and is able to start building
that XP up.
>> Out comes another Mari tempered um and a
hidden card as well. Potentially could
be another Zas. I mean this is a calm
deck as well and so that conquer does
mean Kadzilla does have that one point
on the board but Sequinox has three
units in base.
>> Yeah, Sequenox's in a really good
position. That lonely porro, that
Aurelia fervent and that Vex apathetic
on the base with the Swiftoot boot. So
will be able to gank around if needs be.
Bouncing between that sunken temple and
that star tipped peak here Icy. with two
Y master Y tempers on the base and
battlefield there on the side of
COZilla. He will be able to start
snowballing that XP if he can conquer
and hold. But Vex loves to stop you from
doing that.
>> Especially when Vex is on a battlefield.
Sunken Temple has been conquered by
Sacronox. Going to get himself now to
six points. Only needs two more now to
win this final map in this best of
three. Yeah, as you said, we're in this
third game of the best of three match
here between Aurelia and Ye. And uh
we're seeing some players. Vex obviously
goes went in to conquer. We still have
more steam here. We've got that Aurelia
fervent. She was readied. So she has
that plus one might indicator and a
showdown is being considered.
>> He's smiling. He's laughing. Do I do
this? He does it. Zakonox is going in
with that Ireelia. Out comes that Zas.
It's Zas all around. is going to go back
into that base being revealed as Masahi
tempered here is going to I don't know
if he has any runes up. I don't think
Quzilla can buff Masi anymore.
>> Yep. So he's revealed that Zas when
Aurelia went in preventing the trigger
occurring and then the combat has
resolved. The damage has been dealt then
cracks the zas saving the Yei recalling
it from that battlefield back to base.
So currently two me he's tempered on the
base but is at seven points here. Icy
just needs to hold one to win the game.
>> It's looking very much Sequenox's game
right now as we said has control of both
battlefields only needs to hold one
which means Quadzilla who does have two
units in a base. We'll have to try and
conquer both to try and stay in the
game. And uh it could be possible he
does have a few runes available when
it's his turn. But I mean, is still
building up his board and it's going to
be starcrossing
one of those mas and that lowly power.
This is uh kind of good for second.
>> I think that might be it there because
Godzilla unless he's able to present a
readied unit onto the battlefield this
onto his base this time around. He's not
going to be able to double conquer. We
already know he's used two of his
disciplines. So, he's missing a couple
of pumps, but he's feeling comfortable.
He's feeling confident. He knows what he
has in his hand. We don't.
>> Out comes the on guard onto Mari
Tempered who is currently contesting
sunken temple who does have that Vex on
it. He has to get rid of that Vex who
does is vexed apathetic when Vex is on a
battlefield. It will stun uh any unit
that is played.
>> Yeah, absolutely. So that on guard lands
pumping Y up currently presenting as a
six might. However, it would just be a
trade at this stage.
on that sunken temple. That's if you
conquer it with a mighty unit, you can
pay one energy for a draw. So, it has no
impact on this showdown. Godzilla though
deep in the tank thinking about his
options. What can he do to overcome this
Vex? Squox,
>> that is the defiance dance, which is
such a strong signature spell. Ireelia
loves it and so I'm sure does. Out it
comes. Reaction time as well. Give a
unit plus two this turn and another unit
minus two this turn. Meaning that is a
>> four might switch up.
>> A four might switch up. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. Taking that Vex uh
from six up to eight and that Y from six
down to four. That is a tall order for
Godzilla to have to cast more spells and
pump Y up even higher.
>> It's going to be a hard battle for
Godzilla. He definitely wants to get rid
of that begs but I mean Squinox wants to
keep that begs and that was the legend
now being exhausted.
>> So Aurelia Fervent has gone up by one M
and Yi has gone down by two here. Ah
Defiant Dance put the two onto Aurelia
Fervent and the minus two.
>> Oh
>> onto Yi. Yes.
>> Oh okay. I see. Instead of putting on
begs decided to put it on Ireelia
instead.
Not a bad idea because it still puts him
in a winning position on this sunken
temple battlefield and it prevents
Godzilla being able to have easy access
onto the star tip. Yep, there it is.
>> That is game. Not much Godzilla could do
from that position, but Squox had all
the H cards in hand. And with that,
Squox wins two to one against Godzilla.
>> Yeah, well played by both here, but
Squanox wins that best of three round
three matchup. Yeah,
>> he's now finding himself at 30 and0
here, Ricey. Again, like our previous
game. You've got to be happy with that.
It is such a strong start to the
Riftbound regional qualifiers here in
Sydney 2026.
>> I love the conversation afterwards. You
can see um Quadzilla being like, "Oh,
look, I had no cause. I couldn't do
anything." That's how I feel as well
when I'm playing in my next night. I'm
like, "Look, I wish I could have done
anything." But it it be like that
sometimes. It is the luck of the draw.
But of course, it is also what you
decide to put in your deck.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And that's why the
sideboard exists. Between zero and eight
cards, you were able to tech for your
opponent's legend. But that was a
scintillating round three. Last game
three of that one. We are going to break
and we'll be right back with more
Riftbound.
A key component of playing League of
Legends is gathering XP and leveling up.
Now you can do that in Riftbound 2 with
the newest additions in Unleashed. Every
XP you get will add to your level as a
player and will benefit you in different
forms. So far three legends have been
released that directly benefit from XP
gain. Kha'Zix Void Reva Poppy Keeper of
the Hammer and Master Yi Wu Jun Master.
Notice that all of these have the body
domain in common. Master Yi uses XP
passively. With higher level, he finds
stronger passive effects. At level six,
your units are permanently boosted, and
at level 11, your units always enter
ready. Of course, in the main deck, most
masteries will rely on the champion
unit, Master Yi, unstoppable as a win
condition. This one gets cheaper the
more XP you have, and at level 16, it
even becomes unargetable. Combined with
Master Yi, Wu Master's ability to enter
ready, he can really swing games.
Kha'Zix and Poppy have the unique
ability to gain XP through their own
legend abilities and otherwise use it
like a resource. While Poppy generates
card advantage by spending XP, Kha'Zix
gains utility by either buffing his
units or moving exhausted units away
from their battlefields back to base.
Since all of these three legends have
the body domain in common, there's a
huge variety of body cards that can get
you the XP you need through the hunt
keyword. For example, hunt cards grant
you an XP whenever you conquer or hold.
So winning combats for those decks is of
utmost importance. Cards like Gemand
Hunter, Boracious Gromp, and Master Heat
Tempered can be found in all three
decks, but XP can also be splashed into
other decks. Grim Resolve, for example,
is a strong combat trick that gives the
unit three might on action speed. If the
unit wins a combat, it grants you two
XP. This card might find its way into
other decks as well. Fiora players have
already played around with the
Shepherd's Heirloom, which works like a
Dorance Blade, but does not equip for
power cost, but for XP, there are plenty
of ways to integrate some XP gain into
your decks. So, get those level in and
scale into the late game. from
Riftbounders.
>> We are here at the Riftbound regional
qualifiers in Sydney 2026 and I have
Attack on Cardboard with me here,
content creator. How do you feel about
the regional so far?
>> It's freaking awesome. I I can't believe
how massive the space is and so many
awesome people are here today.
>> It's going great.
>> Oh, sorry. I also think it's going
great. We've seen so many events and
there's a lot of vendors here, but
what's an event that you're looking
forward to playing this coming weekend?
>> Super excited for the what is it? The
Nexus event tonight, the Super Nexus
night. Hopefully meet some riders, play
some play some good games of Riftbound.
Looking forward to that.
>> And if I can ask you one more question,
what is your favorite legend from
Unleashed?
>> Definitely Vex. Vex is awesome. I I
really enjoy the uh the game plan.
Really enjoy the artwork of the
signature which I opened. So yeah, Vex,
very nice. Congratulations on that
signature. It is a beautiful card and
I'm very jealous. That was a tack on
cardboard.
I'm here at the Riftbound regional
qualifier Sydney 2026 with Dwali who
actually won the Houston regional
qualifier on Annie which is pretty good.
Yeah. You've been having fun so far this
weekend.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um, I think this new set's
like super powerful. Probably the most
powerful that they've printed and
there's a lot of like stuff to explore.
I uh main Jin and then my second
favorite champion in League is Pike. So,
it's it's a big set for me. Yeah. Yeah.
So, it's fun.
>> Also plays League of Legends, which we
love to see. Now, doubtlessly you're
here for the main event. That's what
you're most excited for. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Main event for sure. Uh, I
decided to come to try to win. Um, even
though I was tempted to go for best of
jin or best of pike, uh, I think the
first set, um, sorry, the first regional
of the, uh, the new set is somewhere
where you can like come with things that
are unexpected and do really well and
maybe win the whole thing.
>> Yeah, less known sort of answers into
certain archetypes and builds, stuff
like that. So, yeah, take advantage of
it. Really, really nice. And, um, do you
have a favorite set three legend from
Unleash without hopefully giving away
your champion or legend here? I'm
playing Diana.
>> I love
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm playing Diana. Uh my
favorite one, like I said, is Jyn, but
like power-wise, I like Diana. Um she's
really good. Uh obviously Allen's also
on Diana, so I'm contesting him, which
isn't all, you know, it's not the
greatest thing ever, but you know what?
Maybe I'll pair to him and we'll fight
for the best of Diana and that'll be
sick.
>> You mean you'll beat him again like you
did at Houston?
>> It's possible. Exactly. Yeah, it's
possible. He's strong. He's a strong
opponent, but yeah.
>> Exactly. Exactly. Thank you so much for
your time, Dwali, and good luck here at
the Riftbound Regional Qualifiers in
Sydney 2026.
I'm here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifier Sydney 2026, and I'm joined by
Draghu. How are you, mate?
>> I'm good, bro. Happy to be here.
>> Hell yeah, that's it. So, ex LOL player
turned hopefully riffbound pro.
>> Um, yeah, I think so. Um, it's
definitely I think a lot of the skills
that I've learned from League have
actually came back here. Um, I think
practice has been going pretty good, but
there's a lot of strong set players
here, so, you know, I'm just trying to
do my best, actually.
>> That's the one. And have you been having
fun here today on the first day of the
regional qualifiers?
>> Uh, yes. I think the burger was actually
really nice at the cafeteria. Um, so
yeah, that was a big highlight.
>> Sounds good. Burger comes strongly
recommended. Now, you're here to play
the main event. Are you willing to
reveal what legend you're playing?
>> Yep. I'm playing set. Um, I'm also a big
fan of Colin, so if you're listening to
this interview, hi. Um, please don't
play set so I can have a chance. Um, or
you can just rate my deck list. Maybe
it's the same thing. But yeah. Um, no,
I'm very excited. I want to play set.
Um, everyone in Sydney knows me as the
set guy. Probably cuz I'm probably the
only one, but I've been playing since
the start of Origins with set. So, yeah,
very nice. Very committed. And, uh,
yeah, Colin did win that best of set at
Atlanta in that RQ there. Very
inspirational. And now if I can ask you,
do you have a favorite legend from
Unleashed?
>> Honestly, my favorite legend. Okay, this
is going to be like kind of funny, but I
actually really like Ivan.
>> That's funny. Yeah.
>> Oh, and Pike, actually. Pike.
>> Yep.
>> I really like the Pike mechanics, being
able to return those units back to hand
with that legend ability. Well, thank
you very much for your time here today,
Draku. Have a fantastic regional
qualifier and hope to see you on the
feature tables.
Still Steph Panicasio and we are
starting to
>> get through some rounds of Riftbound.
Halfway thereish. Round four is the
halfway point. Once we're done, we'll be
through the first half of today's Swiss
rounds.
>> It feels like equally every single hour
has gone really long and really short.
Everything is happening all at once.
Time is a void.
>> Time is avoid. And uh perhaps that'll be
something we'll see in our next match up
once we get it. But uh the metag game
has been kind of a fun thing we've
wanted to take a look at cuz of course
unleashed brand new set, brand new
cards, brand new legends, brand new
Battlefield. So we're going to take a
look at some of the things that uh
players are playing cuz we finally have
some numbers that have been crunched,
confirmed, and solidified. Let's take a
look at genuinely one of my favorite
things is what is the Battlefield matter
and Starring right up the top. The
number one battlefield, 20% of the field
playing this new one.
>> I mean, I'm not surprised people will
gravitate towards it, but 20%
impressive. We did see a little bit of
it in the match we just saw on stream in
Lilia and we saw it actually in Lebon
game as well where you can move some of
these temporary ready units around. But
I think lots of different legends can
get value out of this. It turns out that
movement is a fairly valuable thing in
ribbound and Starring kind of gives a
lot of different units the ability to
move things around. But uh interesting
to me is the next two on the list.
Aspirin's Clam and the arena's greatest
right next to each other basically.
>> Yeah. Look, I mean, I feel like both of
them change the game in such very
specific ways. It does make sense that
they would be in the top, but I was
surprised to see them that close
together.
>> I think I'm curious to see which decks
want to play what, and if any deck has
both, cuz one of the things that started
happening is that well, if you're going
to try and make the game go to nine
points, well, maybe I'll just start with
an extra point and make it more of an
eight point game. So there is often a
little bit of metagaming that happens
between players in their battlefields
where you tend to want your climb to not
hit the arena's greatest and you tend to
want your arena to hit their climb if
they have it. So again, I'm not
surprised to see those numbers close
together because I think when one feels
popular, the other feels not required
necessarily, but something that is more
attractive. And I think there are a
bunch of decks that are happy to go a
bit slower, especially given the amount
of Aurora I suspect is in the field. Sun
Temple though rounding things out. Have
a look at our most played units.
Thousand tail watcher at number one.
That is not what I expected.
>> Oh no. I mean, I did expect to see Vex
up there and love to see a scuttle crab.
Uh, but no, Thousand Tailed Watcher 31%
is pretty sizable.
>> Yeah, that is a lot. I'm actually
surprised there's that many mind decks
running around. Maybe something to do
with the popularity of maybe a legend
like Ahri,
>> who is a very popular choice generally
at these things because uh the best of
Ahri is a very prized best of indeed
even though Ari herself hasn't had
particularly good results. Vex Apathetic
though are definitely I think we
expected to see quite a bit of not only
just in Vex that deck but Diana we've
seen playing this card basically most of
the chaos decks are happy to have at
least one copy of this unit.
>> I mean I I can see why it's a great unit
to have in there and also I mean the Vex
decks in general have been pretty well
performing. So it's it's really makes a
lot of sense to me.
>> And I think the card that I probably
should have been a little bit more aware
of is actually Scuttle Crab coming in
third at 22% usage. This card has found
its way into just about every single
comm deck, which I didn't necessarily
think would be a thing cuz a zero might
unit doesn't seem all that attractive,
but there's a lot of text on this card
to basically say get an incremental
advantage and also sometimes I get you
points, which is enough. It turns out on
a two drop,
>> you simply have to respect the crap.
That's all I'm saying.
>> And then Axan as well. That uh I guess
unsurprisingly that that is the most
played unit. I will remind everyone uh
this is only units. This is not the
entire metag game. So there could be
other cards that are played more than
this. I suspect actually that one
particular piece of gear may be the most
played card in the event. This is just
units we're looking at here. And
unsurprisingly, uh even the decks that
maybe play that gear I'm alluding to
don't play that many units.
>> Mhm. You're 100% right. I think also
seeing that many vile moors as well,
17%.
>> That's pretty good.
>> Makes a lot of sense to me.
>> Disarming rake as well alongside Axan
near the top. So again, people have
their eyes on a particular strategy. And
then Lonely Porro probably been the uh
the most successful poro in terms of uh
winning/ presence. Plundering poro also
quite good, but Nox's hopeful another
card that has continued to be incredibly
good. Uh there are lots of different
ways to potentially play hopeful very
early on, but even as kind of a uh a two
drop that's on your second turn
alongside some other ones. Uh still
pretty good. As we have a look at most
played spells, I think shocking
absolutely no one. The first two are
defy and discipline.
>> Yeah, look, I mean it it was always
going to be the case. I think having
them both there makes a lot of sense.
37% 34% that tracks for me. I think
realistically I would be surprised to
see them any lower than that.
>> Yeah, again calm kind of the spells
domain in a lot of ways. So not
surprised to see two of their staples up
there. Gust a little bit more surprising
to me.
>> Yeah, look I mean I can understand why
but yeah, I would have expected
something else. I think I well look
realistically the the breakdown between
33% to 3130 it's not that big but yeah
Gust coming up on top a little
unexpected. I am glad to see Staff Frost
there. I'm not hugely surprised that
that's come up as well.
>> And uh yeah, sabotage I think makes a
lot of sense given what uh what I
imagine is going on out on the floor.
>> I have a feeling that Gust is also one
of the reasons oh sorry that deck is
also one of the reasons Gust is showing
up so much. It's not a unit and it's
pretty good at dealing with early plays
with that deck. Sometimes you just never
get around as we are going to have a
look at the most played decks perhaps.
Leblanc still up the top as we expected.
7% though only of the meta again. 40
legends. I will mind 40 legends and all
of them basically guaranteed to have at
least some representation. So total meta
share for even the most popular deck in
the room is not going to be very big.
>> Mhm. I'm not surprised to see Leblanc up
there. I think given how excited
everybody was in the unleash reveal, it
makes a lot of sense and there are a lot
of really cool ways to pilot her. So, I
think it makes a lot of sense to see her
coming up at number. I think Master Yi
being up there as well makes a lot of
sense to me too.
>> I mean, it's very very close between
Master Yi and Aurelia. So, realistically
either way,
>> yeah, definitely a deck we expect to see
a lot of alongside Aurelia who's dropped
a little bit in presence but still
pretty far up there. Diana also I think
we expect to be a pretty popular deck.
Seems quite strong. Vex actually being
in fifth is quite interesting, but only
again kind of these numbers start to get
a little closer together. You see the
first three, Leblanc way ahead of Ye
with 80 plus copies, Ye getting close to
70, but Diana, Vex, and Misfortune have
what, like six copies between them as
far as the difference goes. So, we're
starting to again condense the field
down towards the bottom, although it is
impressive to see Fiora at number 36.
Fun fact for everyone at home though,
Misfortune, the 44% there, 44% of the
meta share. Uh, Misfortune makes up of
33% of the total Aurora decks in the
room. Yeah,
>> all of the misfortune decks are Aurora
variants.
>> Look, I wish I could say I'm surprised.
I'm not. Not even a little bit. It makes
sense that it should be up there as well
for that reason. So,
>> I think honestly the surprise maybe is
that she's in a bit higher. I would have
expected maybe a bit more Aurora in the
field.
>> Yeah.
>> More misfortunately. So,
>> absolutely
>> plenty of Aurora. Don't worry about
that. Don't worry.
>> Aurora everywhere. Absolutely.
>> Misfortune. We'll see.
>> Well, uh I think in some ways the meta
game breakdown we expected.
>> I think so. Not a huge amount of
surprises, but I think the ones that did
surprise were reasonably close to the
next ones down. So, it's really not that
big of a difference. It's very, very
tight.
>> Yeah, it feels like we have kind of a
clear top three as far as the decks that
people are expecting to play a lot with
and maybe succeed with. Then after that,
it's like I don't know.
>> Yeah, it's also really wonderful to see
so many unleashed champions in that top
list. I think it makes a lot of sense
that people are so hyped for it given
how recently it's come out, but it was
always going to be a challenge for
people to make it work so quickly after
release. So, good honor, I say.
>> Yeah, clearly a lot of practice has been
done cuz cards have been spoiled for a
little bit and window testing groups
basically as soon as they get the
opportunity are going ahead and uh
trying the new cards as quickly as I can
as we are going to settle in for our
next match here in round number four. a
very uh
precariously placed Teemo hat under that
headset,
>> but uh a Teemo hat nonetheless. And uh
hopefully they're playing Teemo, but I
not necessarily a guarantee.
>> I mean, if you're going to accessorize,
you might as well accessorize to match
what you've got going on.
>> That was uh No one could see there, but
I was really leaning into the television
thing if I get a little computer enhance
moment, but unfortunately can't quite
see just yet what our matchup is. But
whatever it is, I'm very excited to get
round four going as we see which decks
may maybe aren't just in the metag game
doing their thing, but perhaps which
decks are going to get towards the top
of our metag game.
All right, two players shuffling back
and forth, conferring with the judges,
making sure everything is all in order
as I have a feeling I know one of the
champions. I think I can just barely
>> Yeah.
>> see the edge of that card. I think that
may be Vex.
>> Oh, I hope so. I manifested it.
>> Manifested some Vex, did we? Players are
shuffling.
Everyone's getting the low down. Water
bottles are nearby. That's good. Love to
see the players staying hydrated. Kagen
tournaments are long affairs, folks. If
you've never been to one,
>> it can be grueling. You have to stay
hydrated, otherwise you will 100% end up
having just a really, really off head
space more than anything else. But the
endurance is so important.
>> Certainly is. as we get a little fly
over. Ooh, I do see Victor.
>> Interesting
>> as one of our units.
Definitely a deck that has relatively
good representation. Uh a deck that is
shockingly popular. Usually a pretty
hotly contested best of at the regional
qualifier level.
>> Uh doesn't hasn't done all that well uh
in terms of conversion, but certainly a
deck that people like to play whether
they should or not.
>> All right, let's get ourselves involved.
have a look perhaps at what these
players are piloting as it is indeed Vex
Bowl and Zang going to be our Vex player
here in round number four.
>> I love Vex. I'm I'm really glad to see
so many Vex apathetics out here. A lot
of this is not super surprising. Running
a few charms, but Defy Zour Hourglass
stacked deck and yes, there is the Teemo
in there as well. Little bit of Evelyn.
Interesting. Yeah. No, I think having
the Boots of Swiftness in there gives it
a little bit more versatility. It would
normally be more of a hold, but that's
going to give a little bit more
movement, and I'm intrigued to see how
that will go.
>> Yeah, this is not pure holdex. This
actually has a little bit more DNA with
Aurelia of last set and quite a lot of
Teemo's DNA. Weirdly, there are an
unbelievable number of hidden cards in
this deck. Three Titona, three Edge
Knight, three Switcheroo, three Evelyn,
that's 12 plus one Teemo is 13. 13
hidden cards in this deck.
>> Goodness me. Look, I mean, I like to see
Vex in all her forms, so I'm I'm
intrigued to see how this works. Sorry,
I forgot about that one.
>> Oh, yeah. Little spare 14th hidden card.
Also, with Last Rights, clearly leaning
on a couple of particular units.
Obviously, uh Evelyn's kind of a bit
close to a spell, sneaky deck hand,
decent unit, but one you kind of just
try and grab points early. And Aelia
Fervent three copies, so leaning into
the last Chaos Karm legend, who we still
see again quite a lot of here in Sydney.
>> Absolutely. It will be interesting to
see how it goes up against who I think
you said Victor.
>> Pretty sure it's Victor though. 99.9%
sure
>> that it is Victor which I will say if
your goal is to protect your individual
units perhaps does not bode well. As we
have a whole look, it is Sque. And it is
Victor.
>> Triple Imperial Degree, triple Bellow's
breath, triple CI. This is a lot of
spells. This is actually very close to
almost all spells.
>> Yeah. Oh my goodness. We do have the
thousand tailed watches in there as
well. But yes. Oh my goodness. That is
quite a lot. Very spell heavy.
>> A lot of sprites here as well. So kind
of using things like sprite burst to
empower something like Zenzhal.
>> Pretty good unit. Very efficient. Three
energy for might and enters ready a lot
of the time, especially when you can
make enough units. And of course
Victor's legend ability of paying one
and exhausting it to make a recruit
token means that turning that on won't
be too tricky. you'd love to see a bit
of Ash focused. I think this is a card
that in this particular metag game uh is
pretty well positioned and two
salvagers. So, clearly prepared for the
dazzling Auroras that are in the room.
Although not in this matchup,
>> not so much. But I mean, good to be
prepared. It does make a lot of sense to
have that. But yeah, very very low on
units.
>> Yeah, seems to be wanting to just hold
with recruits and maybe some smaller
units. I mean, the units that this
Victor deck does have are pretty
efficients that make gold. So, wanting
to uh get the get the gold generation
going, pay those power costs, and I
guess we'll figure out what happens from
there cuz this is very curious. Uh seems
like decently good at dealing with units
of all sizes, but uh Victor is a deck
again we see we see a decent amount of
typically, but have not seen Victor
obviously in this matchup because turns
out unleashed is happening right now.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> I am intrigued to see how this will
unfold.
>> I know you're a Vex enjoy. So, how do
you how do you feel about call the week?
Look, it is what it is. It's fine. I
as a Vex enjoyer, I
I don't necessarily learn,
>> but I can respect it and I can I can
make it worth
>> working around.
>> It's a defiable spell, I suppose. So,
off the races we go. Vex actually on the
play, but starting off with no unit, but
actually just a ZAS the first turn. We
know we know that that's the only one in
the main deck. as fortified position is
the battlefield of choice for this first
one. If you don't remember what that one
does folks, I won't blame you.
Forbidding waste here on the Victor side
is whenever you defend alone, you get
minus two. Makes sense for a deck that
makes a lot of small units and will
often almost never be defending alone.
But fortify position uh your units here
get shield two if I recall correctly. I
don't even remember if it's only if
you're alone, but it's something very
close to that which again projector
wants to do a lot of holding with things
like sneaky deckand makes quite a lot of
sense as the opening battlefield. I
don't think it's if you're alone. I
think it's it's just gentle.
>> When you defend here, choose a unit. It
gains shield to this combat.
>> There you go.
>> Thanks for pulling it up.
>> Happy to help.
>> So, that uh that Sneaky is a four right
now. And again, this is the tech that
Aurelia used for quite a while in early
Spirit forge of just being able to get
points early and then just I mean for
Vex, for Aelia, it would be all about
regaining those points by ganking
across, rerating Aurelia. This one, it's
like I just want to get points and then
hold on to my points. You can kind of
think of this in some ways like build
your own proven grounds mastery.
>> You're not wrong. I think it's also very
interesting that we're seeing quite a
lot of Vex in Aurelia and now we're
seeing Aurelia in Vex. I I like the
synergy there.
>> It turns out when they share domains,
they sometimes will also share cards.
Even if the strategy seem to be designed
to do different things. So sweet. How do
we want to approach here? Going to start
off with the recruit moving to the
waist. Again, just having uh one little
recruit alone doesn't seem so bad. One
might's not going to do a lot of winning
anyway. So, it being it potentially
getting minus two for defending alone
doesn't feel like a particularly big
cost for Victor to have to pay. And
we'll leave the deck hand for now in its
fortify position, especially with AA on
the other side of the table. But the
follow-up is what I'm interested in cuz
again, there are a lot of spells that
this Victor deck has. We'll start by
making a recruit though because Victor
loves to make recruits.
>> Boy, doesn't he? I guess also there are
two salvages. So it could be one could
be a thing where not a bad spot to have
one potentially. Zin going to be the
play is going to enter ready.
>> Mhm.
>> Thanks to that recruit and the
plundering power and we're going to
rumble on in. This is going to be six
might playing four effectively with the
shield. And uh that is going to be a
combat win here for Victor pushing this
sneaky deck hand off of the fortify
position.
Normally I would be a little bit more
concerned given that most of the time
Vex would run more of a hold build, but
this is going to be interesting given
that there is so much more mobility in
this deck.
>> Right. So actually Squeach as the
attacker first window to act stupifies
this to make it a little smaller. So
pull three total. Now Zin's not even
going to lose the combat effectively
plus one thanks to that shield. Not
exactly how it works, but in practice
that is a clear enough representation of
the board today.
>> Ong guard in hand though. Pretty good
when defending alone. Zin does have tank
does have to be the unit picked first,
but on guard is not going to be enough
to kick back over here. 3 plus two is
five and we already know six is on the
other side. So Zin's going to go
bye-bye. At least committing the spell
to make sure to trade up with Zim. But
plundering Poro, it does indeed do the
job. Finds a bit of gold in the
fortified position.
It is so fun to try and sneak a little
look there at those hands. Oh,
>> stack deck. Sneaky deck hand.
>> Mhm.
>> Put down of course soon as I start soon
as I start figuring out what they are
away.
>> Absolutely.
>> Should be two points though for Squitch
on the other side. So two to one should
be the point lead for Victor. currently
doing kind of the thing Victor wants to
be doing is getting points early and
often.
>> Absolutely.
>> Aelia hand as well.
>> Interesting.
>> Alongside the discipline, you might have
to take a turn off to develop here, but
Aurelia is a pretty good unit if she
sticks around.
>> You are definitely going to get
absolutely Well, you have a sneaky deck
hand, so maybe it's not. So, wait, why
is the sneaky deck hand just chilling
there? How did you get there? H
is a great question.
>> Doing math in my head right now.
>> Oh, the ZA.
>> Zas. There we go. I knew there was an
answer.
>> Yeah.
>> Over we go. Sneaky Deckan going to go
ahead and take the waste away. That is a
negative one might recruit. So, not a
very good defender.
>> Hey, any defender can be a good defender
if it's the only one you've got. And
then uh I was going to say don't really
want to play Aurelia into a potential
cold a week when it's your only unit.
But that sneaky deck and thanks to
Sonia's surviving means that Aurelia
doesn't feel like a bad thing to develop
here.
>> Can even hold up a potential ong guard
as well. So see if we want to go looking
first. Indeed we will. Stack deck going
to be the play and have a peek. That's
discipline. A relia fervent once again
and one more card I can't quite make
out.
It looks suspiciously like a
back off.
>> Yeah, I think he might be right. Oh, a
little hard to tell.
>> Well, whatever it was, that is the car
that Bolan took.
>> We'll find out in just a moment.
>> No, last right. Okay, that's the other
three energy
>> thing roller king around the deck.
>> That makes a lot of sense.
>> So curious what the game plan is here.
Yeah, it it's not necessarily super
intuitive, but I'm I'm very intrigued to
see this this blend of strategy.
>> Here's Vex. Feels like a decent play.
Again, four energy, four might, no power
cost, and Vex Apathetic, of course, when
I'm at a battlefield. Uh units, your
opponent play gets stunned and then
cannot be moved, which in this matchup,
that text isn't super long, although
actually it's quite good against Zen.
And we do know that Squitch has three of
those.
>> Also, deflect on Vex. Yep. Love deflect,
which is uh Yep. They just added another
word, huh?
>> Mhm. Got to have more words.
>> Didn't have enough.
>> Never enough.
>> Pretty powerful unit. Actually, one of
the more popular units among the uh I
was asking the dealers, the card dealers
out around the venue, what have what's
been popular. Vex apathetic. Pretty
common one was getting picked up. So,
not too surprised to see uh to see that
given how powerful that card has seemed.
Look, as someone who very much never
grew out of the emo phase, I can 100%
reckon with why that might be the case.
>> Chilling at the waist also means that uh
no might penalty will be incurred as
Squeach has held up to three points.
>> I'm just considering what to do now cuz
that hand does not do a lot of
attacking. Hidden Blade,
>> uh the new card that's Waiters of Pain,
but different. It's one of Jyn's cards.
Makes a goal. Deals three damage.
Doesn't tail Watcher.
Chakram Dancer and Honest Broker. The
cards there. I know what the card is. I
just don't know if I have the name
right. Ch something. So, I'm going to
pay a bit of gold. Flip to power over.
Play something.
What do we got?
>> Hidden blade.
Oh, deflect. I was like, why is he
paying another power? Has to pay for
deflect.
>> Got to do it.
>> So, Vex gets deflected. Draws two cards
over on uh over on Bolan's side and then
uh move on over. Challenge the deck head
is currently a zero cuz it is defending
alone once again. So, one plays zero.
Pretty easy fight for Victor to win.
>> Yeah.
>> On guard.
>> We have on guard.
>> Exit a two again.
>> Mhm.
>> Switch as you got it.
And then we go back a little bit more
perhaps.
>> Shark of dancer ambush unit.
>> Mhm.
>> Gives the temporary units a shield I
believe. Pretty good in Lilia. They're
not bad in this spot either.
>> It's funny to think how many domains
have ambush in them. Does feel like a
very fury coded thing, but not in
unleashed.
>> No, no, no.
>> That actually gives other gives your
other units here shield. So it doesn't
even need to be a temporary unit. that
are obviously on offense not going to
get the shield, but the three might is
going to be more than enough to win that
combat and move Victor to four points
now in this game.
>> Recruit split it somewhere.
>> Where we going?
>> Feels reasonable to turn the penalty of
waste off by reinforcing there.
I mean, at this point, you might as well
really
there's
>> some value in just having random
recruits in your base just because uh
they can often conquer for you. We
actually saw the interaction this last
turn that sneaky deck hand was no match
for the one might recruit thanks to the
downside of that waste. Feels like a
really sweet battlefield for Victor to
be playing. I know a lot of different
decks have been playing this kind of
does buildin and counter with proving
grounds ye which uh as we saw on the
metag game breakdown just a moment ago
very popular deck
>> I think Squeach is asking for the text
to fortify position
but uh only one unit gets shield to but
looks like enough to protect the parro
who's going home that's why going to
leave the recruit up there to defend and
leave the dancer at the waist still a
one might unit even with the penalty on
defense as you pass on back Vex trying
figure out what to do cuz Vex I feel
like a deck that is real good when she's
holding and can sometimes struggle when
she's not.
>> Yeah, look, as I said earlier, I feel
like splitting the strategy a little bit
here to be a little bit more mobile can
go either way. At the moment, it doesn't
necessarily feel super intuitive,
especially given that they haven't
really been able to establish a hold
very well at all here, but you can see
what happens. I mean, look, at this
point, being 6'2 is tricky. I just uh
I don't know if what they've got in hand
is really going to be able to make the
difference there.
>> Definitely a development turn there.
Just need all the runes to play Aurelia
and Sneaky Deck hand and Sque doing uh
the expected thing. Awakening a unit
>> running the recruit back and going to do
the same cuz those units already scored
their points on their battlefields. No
need to linger them. Leave them out to
dry as it were.
>> And I don't know, just keep making
recruits, build up a big enough uh base
and then charge on in for the final two
points. You've certainly gained enough
point tempo
>> to force your opponent to do something.
And that's going to be true for the rest
of this game.
>> Absolutely. Bunch of little guys. They
do the job.
>> Sometimes they do.
>> Mhm.
>> Victor coming down. Making the non-token
recruit units make extra recruit units.
Feels pretty good. And go ahead. I have
six units. You have two.
with all the different removal spells
available to Victor. Doesn't feel like
the most comfy position.
>> No, not so much.
>> Last rights coming up by the looks of
things.
>> Yep. There we go.
>> Let's shovel in time. Equip recycle to
Yep.
>> Mhm.
>> The graveyard rights gives plus two
gets plus one for being chosen by a
piece of equipment.
So, right now, she's currently a four,
five, six, seven,
>> and when you conquer a hold, you may
play a unit from your trash. And, uh,
there should be a Vexpathetic in there.
>> Mhm.
>> There he comes. Earlier, charges on in,
grabs the point, sits at the fortified
position, which seems pretty reasonable.
>> You would really, really have wanted to
do this a lot earlier, but hey, we get
there when we get there.
>> Little bit bigger. And here we go with
Vex.
>> Should be reinforcing, which again turns
off things like Zin, but
>> not sure. With only three runes up, it's
enough for to hold onto this
battlefield. And she's going to need to
for the rest of this game.
>> No pressure.
>> Discipline. Evelyn Switcheroo. That's
not a bad one. Defy the cards in hand
there for our Vex player.
>> Could be interesting.
Still a lot of units on the other side
there with the recruits everywhere.
>> Yeah, a bit awkward switch against all
these little units
>> given that uh but I think it makes sense
given the presence of some pretty big
units in different decks across the
field. So hides a card passes on back
three runes still up and available.
And so uh the formalities will begin in
the bottom battlefield as Squeech is
going to presumably roll on over with a
recruit and collect at least the seventh
point.
But can Victor get to eight is the
question we will ask ourselves.
>> Lot of thinking going on there.
>> See a call. I wish I remembered the name
of that card. It's not Rocket Barrage.
That's from the other set.
>> I can see it in my mind's eye. See, it
looks like Rocket Barrage. in your eyes.
>> Oh, you know what? Maybe maybe I can
maybe I can Well, Squitch doesn't think.
Perhaps I can figure it out myself.
>> Have a little peek through the card
library. Perhaps.
>> You're a smart fellow. I'm
>> so
pretty decent board to deal with as
well.
>> This big Aelia versus Vex. And of
course, any spells in hand do feel a
little bit bigger. Deadly flourish was
the card I was thinking of.
>> Ah, there you go. It is a gin ability. I
was right about that. Deal three to an
enemy unit. When it dies this turn, play
a gold gear token exhausted.
Very similar to Wages of Pain.
>> Yes,
>> pretty popular card in these mind decks.
Nice little addition from Unleashed as
Squeach considers all the options. We
know that Cere's going to do a decent
amount of work, but three damage does
not bear too much against these giant
might units.
>> Absolutely. I do enjoy that we've been
able to get multiple perspectives on the
multiple options given that he's clearly
having a think there getting every
single angle of that thinking face on
Sque.
>> Squitch also once again asking for the
text of fortified position wanting to
double check what the card says.
>> Obviously Chinese cards are allowed in
uh Rickband events all around the world
and that some players choose to play
with them which is great and sometimes
if you don't read Chinese can be tough
to figure out what the card does. asking
for some clarification
>> and wants to try and make sure to factor
in the shield. This is the part moves
on, grabs
>> can we get the final one here?
Conquering that top battlefield. Anyway,
Victor can, we're going to win for game
number one.
>> Let's do a quick count, shall we? 3 4 5
6 7 8 9. I believe Victor is four might.
>> 10 + 2 is 12. Okay,
>> so 12 currently plays 10, but it's
usually more than 10 with
>> inevitably.
>> Sneaky Decan notably stayed home.
He's not joining any potential combats,
at least not anytime soon.
Double checking Victor's might, base
might as well. It's three or four. We'll
find out in just a moment while Squeach
has a good old think.
It is four I believe.
>> Sounds about right.
>> It is indeed. Victor leader. Four might
for four energy. When your non-token
units perish, play a recruit.
>> Perish.
>> Fun word.
>> Plundering porro. Thousand tail watcher.
The other thing to consider. Thousand
tail watcher feels like it can win a lot
of combats for you. But that is only
seven runes. Unless Squeach's hand is
covering one that I cannot see. It is in
fact covering one I cannot see.
>> Yes,
>> eight is enough to accelerate.
>> Also playing out the thousand tail
watcher. There is the Vex stun that
would have to be contended with.
>> All right, we'll see what happens here.
Deadly flourish going to kick things
off.
Pointed at the Vex, I believe. Oh, I see
what's happened. Oh, no. Never mind.
Can't follow up with the Watcher. So
instead going with a different line,
trying to use multiple spells here to
chew through the potential problems. Uh
notably you if you're trying to work
through fortified position one at a
time, you got to be a little bit careful
>> because uh the shield only applies once
to choose a unit to get it. And
obviously with two units there, that
means shield two can only be granted to
one of them. But if you go in one at a
time trying to kind of wear them down as
it were, could potentially run into more
might than you're expecting. And Shakrim
Dancer going to roll on in with the
Plundering Porro. Few more units being
picked up here. That's three, four,
five, six, seven might total.
>> Currently up against four plus one. That
would be five.
Plus the two from last rights is seven.
So need at least eight. And that is
eight in hand.
Putting the recruit down though. Put the
recruit in the bag.
Pretty
tense motion in this game as we are
going to move on in. Should be eight
might playing seven if I did my math
correctly. Four, five, six, seven on one
side
and there's eight on the other. So just
barely winning the combat, but that's
not considering any additional pumps,
any extra might on Aelia and of course
whatever the hidden card is.
>> Mhm.
>> Oh, shield too. I did miss the shield
too.
>> And they've just come in. So, are they
stunned as well?
>> These units are not ones.
>> These units are not.
>> They're good.
>> But I
hope Squitch remembered that trigger cuz
it also chooses a unit, which means
Aurelia gets bigger as well.
>> So, that shield makes Aurelia
significantly bigger than she was before
this all started. That's nine might on
the Aelia alone. That is more than the
eight that got sent in. Of course, three
damage on Vex means Vex is going to at
least perish in this combat. But Squeach
losing all these units, leaving Aurelia
there to hold the fort perhaps.
Again, if Victor can get in and score
this last battlefield, that will be
enough to win game number one. Gets a
goal, gets a couple recruits. Thank to
thanks to Victor Leader.
>> Call of the week though is not going to
do it. Thanks to Sneaky Dean still back
in base.
There's no more units to roll on in. So
I think Sque might be playing to do this
over a few turns.
>> I guess if you play the call now, you
take out the deckhand probably and then
force your opponent to find a way onto
the forbidden waste. You can win by
threaten to win by holding at least.
>> Look, at this point the point advantage
does mean there is a little bit more
leeway timewise to be able to build and
figure out what you're doing.
>> Rebuilding instead. Plundering Porro.
Victor makes a recruit. Pass it on back.
So this recruit at the forbidden w
forbidden waste can win the game. Don't
know how likely it is as Vex Gloom is
finally going to draw a card for the
first time this series.
>> Goodness me.
>> Bangs. It turns out pretty decorated
player at least on this deck.
>> They went undefeated in the pre-regional
yesterday which is pretty impressive
given how many people were here to be
able to contribute. I I believe they
were also a regional open winner in
Nanjing during Spirit Forged and they
went top eight at the regional open in
Fu Fuju during Origins as well. So
they're really quite experienced.
>> Hope I hope they've changed decks every
set by the way cuz on a very new one
this go round and on a pretty unique
take on Vex. So really a player that
understands the game and says, "You know
what? Everything else that you're doing
with Vex, I think we should do it this
way."
>> Yes. Well, it remains to be seen how
well that's going to work out in the
long run, but definitely a unique take.
I'm I'm very excited to see more of Vex
over the course of the next day and a
half, but this is definitely not a
formation that I expected to see.
>> Well, I think perhaps a little clerical
error in the mats
>> may have caused an issue. Evelyn
entrancing going to be the hidden card
reveal. This one is kind of like a
charm. You have to go through a couple
of extra steps to get there. You have to
hide the card and then flip it up on
your turn. But when you play me from
face down on your turn, you may move an
enemy unit at a different location to my
battlefield. Evelyn charming a unit on
in.
>> Mhm.
>> Very flavorful for that particular
League of Legends champion.
>> Absolutely.
>> And very bad news for Victor Leita about
running into this rampaging Aurelia.
>> Also of note, last rights did trigger
once again thanks to holding.
>> Only four points for Ball and Zang, but
a replay of Vex Apathetic. And that unit
is not stunned.
That's not how Vex work, but Vex is
going to get the shield, which means
there is nothing for this Victor to do
in combat but perish. That's
>> it. Yep. Inevitable.
>> Roll on in again down the bottom side.
Might as well take the point cuz that
recruit is negative one. Thanks foring
waste.
>> All of a sudden it feels like Vex may
have turned the corner. Yeah, look, I
mean, early game it did seem like there
was a significant tempo advantage there.
But look, I mean, anything can happen,
especially if you're able to hold that
well with Aurelia. It's It's going to
make a big difference for them.
>> I wonder if now I'm trying Now I'm
trying to recall deck list. I don't
remember if Squitch had an unchecked
power in their main or not.
>> I don't think so. No,
>> that's the case. I am not too sure how
you break through these units. I mean uh
the honestly the mutated Mouser and the
sneaky deck hand alone are already quite
good
>> together currently defending for six
after you accommodate for the shield but
the top battlefield is terrifying
>> a truly fortified position.
>> Yeah look I mean at this point
I don't know what he's got in hand is
the question.
>> I do know Squitch has Imperial Decree.
>> Okay
>> has quite a few copies I think has
actually three in the main from memory.
So that card would be good enough to
take out quite a few units in this game.
Kind of makes all your recruits really
makes all the units
>> not infinitely big, but very big.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh that would be enough to pick off
all these pesky units. But that hand we
can see Sprite Fountain hold a weak
thousand tail watcher. That does not
feel like it's getting the job done
here.
>> Not so much there.
It's four might in base from the
recruits, two mites from the plundering
porro. Again, have to factor in because
I almost forgot last round. Fortify
position and that shield makes Aelia
that much bigger.
>> Mhm.
>> Vexpathetic turning off things like Zin.
Even turning off the sprite fountain
actually.
>> Oh, true.
>> Stunning that poor ready sprite. One of
the reasons we've seen quite a lot of
Vex apathetic
>> as far as units represented in this
tournament go. Even in not vex, it's
pretty good. And when you can play it
straight from your champstone or back
from your bin
>> if you happen to have a last rights and
that's pretty threatening as we're going
to have six might rumble on in. That is
five though.
>> Sneaky deck hand on the two. Did I
misremember? I think I may have
misremembered but sneaky deck hands
might. So are currently looking to trade
here as Ball and Zang going to play a
discipline and say I don't think so. I'm
going to make my tank unit bigger.
>> Look, if there was ever a unit to do it
to at this point, I mean Aurelia is
already so significantly large. might as
well make that mutated Mouser much
bigger.
>> I think you reasonably predict that your
opponent is not going to try and
challenge you on the top battlefield
this turn if this is what they're doing.
So easy to commit the discipline. Uh the
Mouser goes away. Unfortunately, the
sneaky deck end which does only have two
might.
>> Yeah,
>> does stay there for the whole point.
Recruit moving on in is now alone. So
again, it is one to zero the current
might there thanks to forbidding waste.
A card I have said many times today. Not
necessarily what I expected. Perhaps I
should have predicted that all of the
people did not like proof of crowns
here.
>> That is very fair.
>> Fallen considering something else.
Another discipline.
>> Having a little read. Even a stun here
would get it done to hold this point.
>> Mhm.
>> Switcheroo. Oh, that is adorable.
>> Pretty costly. cost two energy and two
power, but uh that's going to make
that's going to mean you get my
zeromite. I'll take your one and that is
enough for the sneaky deck and to win
the combat.
>> Look, you when it comes down to it,
whether it's trading for literally one
or trading for a bunch,
it it's it's just coming up.
>> Nifty little card. Switcheroo does get
the job done. Sneaky deck and stays in
position. Vex Gloom is going to draw
another card after this hold
>> cuz I don't think Squeach has any other
way to crack through this turn at least.
>> And all the recruits falling by the
wayside in that exchange means even if
decree comes off the top of the deck.
I'm not sure what's left to try and play
with here. So Sque going to go digging
playing Thousand Tail Watcher. This
one's going to get accelerated. Nope,
that's a Victor recruit. We're going to
go again next turn.
Decides not to move on in. So going to
go ahead awaken up.
>> Mhm.
>> And quickly reexhaust that Vex, grab our
two points, go to seven, and draw a card
to the Troubles. Not so bad.
>> This really has turned around very, very
quickly for Bolan Zang.
>> Lost Rights as well. Also ready. Play a
tank unit to that fortified battlefield.
Now you only need to hold for one point
to win this game. So I think Mouser is
going to go join Aurelia and Vex. I'm
very bad at this game apparently cuz
it's not. It's going back down to the
bot side.
>> Down in the forbidding waste. I guess
you want to give a sneaky deck and a
friend.
>> Why not?
>> Little lonely in the cold getting minus
two might. Vex draws a card.
>> And another mutated mouse I found off
the top alongside two to five and a
switcheroo with one more card in that
hand. And Bolan Zang
>> looking primed to take game number one
here on Vex. Had a very good preq
yesterday. had a couple of top finishes
throughout their career and are looking
to maybe add another one here halfway
through round four here at RQ Sydney.
>> There we go. Boots of swiftness.
>> They can't win.
>> Already scored all the points that there
are to be scored this uh this turn.
We just uh boots for fun for a little
bit of extra might perhaps. We'll confer
plus two and ganking. Ganking doesn't
feel all that relevant right now, but
the plus two certainly could be.
>> And there we go.
>> Open line fans rejoice. Plus two for
Aurelia. Eight might now base at that
battlefield. Still alongside the Evelyn
and the Vex in the fortified position,
which once again when when you defend,
choose a unit you control, give it
shield to. If you choose Aurelia, that
is a choice you have made. And Fervent
says, "You chose me, I get even bigger."
As Mousa is going to tank up the top
lane. Evelyn goes back and Bon Zang
says, "What do you got?" Cuz I'm pretty
sure I have this game on holding.
>> Look, I I don't know what's in hand
there, but I don't think it's going to
be enough, especially given that we do
have the Mouser on both fields now
with Aurelia there that big. It just
doesn't seem penetraable. It
>> certainly doesn't. back to Pathetic also
turning off a couple other outs as well.
But it's just the units you see on your
screen basically
>> that are what we're going to have to
contend with. Ooh, Imperial Decree was
the rip off the top, but all those
recruits have already gone.
>> Usually the way you line that up is
having a bunch of one might units you
can run on in with, but
>> not so much.
Seven points for so long in this game,
but it may not matter. The switch back
into the tank and it's the cards we
already saw. Call the weak, sprite
fountain, and that Imperial decree that
did come off the top. And Sprite
Fountain once again does not work the
way you want it to with Vex Apathetic at
a battlefield.
>> Exactly. All of the momentum has kind of
stilted a little bit for Screech.
I know what's in I know a little bit of
what's in Bolton's hand. I think it's
defy defy.
Thousand watcher going to try and make
something happen. Down to the bot side
we go.
>> Seven plays five as the tank triggers.
Switcheroo.
>> Switcheroo again.
>> Give me your might. That should be the
game. I don't know if the top
battlefield was uh takable anyway.
>> But this switchoo should put an end to
things.
A very very powerful turn around on this
game.
>> Kind of showing why Vex kind of the
premier hold deck in unleashed. Again,
not the way I thought the players were
going to draw it up here. But Bolan Zang
with a kind of a unique take on the
archetype looking very good in this
first game at least.
>> Currently XNO looking to add a fourth
win to their run as Imperial Decree is
going to at least try and trade the
might back and forth. That is going to
be enough to clear out
>> that battlefield. But again, we still
have the issue in the top.
>> Yeah.
>> So when any unit takes damage this turn,
kill it. That's what Imperial decree
says,
>> which is pretty good when you can assign
uh your now two might thousand tail
watcher might to uh both of the units
that are chilling at the battlefield.
Unfortunately, there's only one recruit
left and uh there is a tank unit in the
other battlefield and three units total
occupying the fortified position. So
>> I just don't think it's going to be
enough. Unfortunately, yes, there is
that defy in hand.
>> Yeah, I think based on what we know,
>> there is not a way out in this game, but
>> continuing to just resolve things.
>> Oh, the tank unit you don't have to get
hit.
>> Ah,
>> that's interesting. Okay. I I thought
you could apply more damage, but I guess
not. No, you can't actually. It's the
opposite of Elder Dragon. Elder dragon,
you can just assign a single damage and
say that's lethal.
>> That does not work that way. So tank
getting in the way of even Imperial
decree as there was no way to break
through either battlefield and bowling
Zang takes game number one despite being
a couple of turns at seven uh with your
opponent at seven points
>> points. Yeah, look I mean and really
impressive turnaround given that they
have had such a good run in the past
however many uh tournaments. I think it
makes sense that they have got that long
game kind of planned out a little bit
more especially when you are playing a
little bit more of an unconventional
deck. I do really like the synergies
though. I didn't think that it would
work as well as it did, but I'm I'm not
mad about it.
>> Aurelia continuing to work in every
deck. It turns out
>> was good in Yasawa and Spirit Forge. It
was good in Aelia and Spirit Forge.
Turns out might just be good in Vex in
Unleashed as well.
>> As I do feel like Victor has the tools
in this matchup, but sometimes the
spells do not line up with the threats
your opponent have. Yeah, look, you can
have as much momentum as you want, but
then if you get stuck on that seventh
point, it's just extremely frustrating.
>> Yeah, I think seeing that Imperial
decree ripped, I think the turn after
all the recruits ran into the bottom
battlefield.
>> Perhaps not how he drew it up.
>> So, we're into game number two. Players
reset their boards, just getting their
battlefields ready. Bonang already
picked battlefield number two. still
have the old one in our squeezer zone,
but that will be replaced in short order
as the players do quickly sideboard and
shuffle.
What else would you want? I feel like as
Victor in this matchup,
>> I mean just I think the issue is going
to be that once the Aurelia engine does
get running, it is going to be so so
difficult to really prevent any extra
growth from it. So, look, I I don't
remember what was in the sideboard and
well, the sideboard wasn't seen. I don't
remember what was in the main deck
before. So, look, any kind of disruption
will be good to be able to get through
and really try and hold them back from
building that hold. But, I mean, look,
it's it's going to be tricky, I think.
>> Yeah, we saw a couple salvages. Can't
imagine that is all that good in this
match up. Although, you did see some
boots and a za, so maybe you want to
keep one in. I mean did feel like most
of the good removal spells were already
in Victor's main
>> triple decree, hidden blades, cold
awakers
are playing things like vengeance. I
think that's probably a little bit too
much
>> for uh for the order decks these days.
So it does feel like the answers are
there. Maybe just have to hope it lines
up good. If we have a quick look at the
deck once more, triple bellow's breath
also maybe not at its best in this
matchup. Units are pretty big on the Vex
side. Although it does take out Mousa
before you have to deal deal with it in
combat. So maybe something you want to
consider.
>> Quite a few cards. We didn't see that
game at all as well.
>> Yeah, a couple sweet ones. Shadow's
core. Nice new draw spell out of
Unleashed.
>> Mhm. Ash as well.
>> Ash very sweet.
>> Bad in this matchup if you can take
spell out of hand. Although not at its
best, I would say cuz kind of all of the
little spells that Vex plays
>> uh kind of all do the same thing. Like
if you you ash someone and see a
discipline and an on guard, it's like
okay well I can take the best one for
this situation but
>> but there's still going to be another
>> kind of the same thing I left in your
hand.
>> Watch a bellow's breath I guess not a
bad way to clear the whole battlefield.
So there are definitely things to look
for here as we have a quick squeeze once
again at bowl and zang's very
interesting vexless here. Triple edge of
knight is the is the one that's really
kind of sending me
>> especially given that we didn't see it
at all that last match
>> that is so many copies of that. It's
basically a hidden card, but it's
basically a pump spell that you can
hide.
>> Yeah,
>> that's how I look at Edge of Night. So,
not a bad one. Certainly. Yes.
>> So, we've got Abandon Hall
>> and the Arena's Greatest. Interesting.
>> We're continuing the uh I like Aurelia
and I want Aurelia to be good in my
deck. Fortify position doing extra work
that I did not expect. Making Aurelia
even bigger on defense. Abandoned Hall
just makes put takes Aurelia to the
moon.
>> Absolutely. Battlefielder says when you
play when a player plays a spell, you
may choose a unit you control there,
give it plus one this turn, which you
may remember is pretty similar to the
text of Raven Bloom Student, a card
that's been pretty popular in mind decks
for quite a while since Origins. Now,
the thing with Aurelia is that when you
choose a unit, if Aurelia is one of the
units at the abandoned hall, well then
choosing Aurelia gives Aurelia Fervent
plus one. So suddenly those disciplines
and on guards we've been seeing maybe on
something like edge of knight flipped up
from hidden uh makes Aurelia even
bigger. Although that one I guess is not
actually a spell. So that one doesn't
work.
>> True.
>> But uh you see the Aurelia players
playing this a lot. It makes their units
absolutely monumentally big. And uh even
without Defiant Dance Aelia signature
spell, I suspect Paul and Zang will be
making pretty large Aelia if he can
maintain control of the hall.
>> Mhm. And then obviously we also have the
arena's greatest as well. Obviously
Squeach did make it to seven very very
quickly. Maybe having a little bit of
extra points there would not go astray
in helping them get back up to there and
be able to hold for the final point as
well.
>> Bit of sportsmanship as well. Bolan just
tapping the arena's greatest when
Squeach channel wanting to make sure
that that trigger is not missed.
Pondering Porro going to be the first
unit deployed in this game as Victor is
going first and Bing Spirit not a card
we saw actually in the main I believe.
So, something coming in from the board
wanting to try and grind out the cards
from his Victor's hand, take away
potentially some of those very pesky
spells like I don't know,
>> maybe that Imperial decree I see in that
hand.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Salvage stayed in. Bella's breath in.
Chuck chrome dancer I believe. Yep.
>> Looks like it. Yeah.
>> So, uh, one of the nice things about
Spirit is that it always hits something.
>> Yeah. Look, you're never not going to
get some value out of it at this point.
>> Fellow's breath to the bin.
Pass it on back
>> and Porro is going to go a plundering in
just a moment. Little channel, little
draw. We'll make a gold on our little
seaf fairing adventures. More gold
generating two drops as abandoned hall
going to be the battlefield of choice. I
do think that both players are going to
be fighting over this one. It kind of
makes sense. Arena is greatest kind of
already did the thing.
>> Yeah. So unless you have unless you're
trying to score yet another point, the
only battlefield that does has any more
text throughout the rest of this game is
going to be abandoned hall. So
>> nobody wants to chill on the hole and
the recruit is going to get made and we
will be reinforcing by the looks of
things.
>> N
>> psyched out.
>> Interesting.
>> Back to base we go. All right, so Bonane
awaken
channel some runes. Notably, I don't
think it matters too much cuz I think
most of these decks are more chaos power
heavy, but no calm runes currently
flipped off the top of the rune deck.
>> So, if there's calm power costs to be
paid, uh, not a thing you can do right
now. Mercively, Aurelia does not cost
calm power despite being a calm unit.
And Aurelia Fervent right on time going
to make her presence known on turn two.
>> Absolutely.
As early as possible. Oh, did we see a
mind spplitter in there?
>> I think Yeah, that is a mindspplitter. I
don't believe we saw that in
>> that must have been sideboarded in.
>> Clearly valuing the hand disruption here
in this match up bringing in I believe
both Spirit and Mindsplitter from the
sideboard to try and strip away Victor's
key cards. I mean the Victor's units
are, you know, only only so interesting,
right? Lots of uh lots of porros, lots
of good uh good two drops, but they're
mostly two man. Lots of recruits, right?
Lots of small units that band together
>> to work things out. But uh if you can
take away the spells, well, Victor looks
a lot worse.
>> Yes,
>> when he stripped those away.
>> So, honest broker played. Plundering
Porro finishes Plundering. It did finish
last turn and goes back home. Recruit
does claim a point at the arena's
greatest. And now it's four points to
one. Little early lead here for Sque and
Victor.
>> Look, we've seen this before, the early
lead. It's not necessarily a guarantee
of anything at this point, but it it's
got to feel good to have a little bit of
momentum in the early stages. I think
so. Victor leader deployed again. Last
rights rift ripped off the top there for
Bolan Zang. Saw how good that was in the
last game, especially with Vex
apathetic. So, we may well be seeing a
similar turn that we saw before moving
Aelia into the battlefield, parking in
the abandoned hole, and then reinforcing
Vex apathetic and basically creating a
stronghold that says, "I don't think you
can break through this." does have to be
a bit careful cuz again still behind on
points but I suppose if you take a
battlefield and never let it go you can
technically win a game that way.
>> I mean we just saw that.
>> I guess we did just see that.
>> All right, seven runes and a lot of
choices here for Bolan
>> into the tank for the first real time
this game.
>> See that switcheroo again. Defy
>> boots of swiftness. I guess salvage
staying in makes sense given how much
work shovel did in the last game. True.
Very, very true. I can't imagine that uh
it was put into the deck specifically
for the I think maybe something else
might have been the priority to address
in other matchups, but hey, if it works,
it works.
>> Certainly. A in a pinch draws you a
card.
>> Exactly.
>> Not a bad one as two points now for Ball
and Zang as Bewitching Spirit does win
the fight against the lonely recruit,
but the point was gained already. So,
not too fast. Mindsplitter are going to
reinforce the arena's greatest. Not the
play necessarily expected, but pretty
effective here as Bowen going to write
down the cards in hand and then take one
of them away. It's Bellow's Breath,
Shakum Dancer, Salvage, and Imperial
Decree. And I have a feeling that we can
reasonably ignore Bellow's Breath and
Shakum Dancer.
>> Yeah. Yeah, just a bit.
>> What would you be going?
>> I think Decree is the card that makes
most sense to take away here. I don't
think you care that much about your
gear.
>> Not really. I feel like obviously at
this point there aren't that many
recruits still as well, but you don't
want to let that happen and have the
decree in hand. So it
>> just feels like your one job is to
protect your, you know, pressure one or
two units that you're using to reinforce
a battlefield. And decree basically
means uh all units win all fights.
>> Mhm.
>> So probably something that Bolan Zang
isn't interested in, but we'll see.
Going to give it a think here after
writing down the cards in hand and does
point to three or three.
>> There we go. Two more where that came
from though. So plenty of uh juice left
in the deck for Squeach as turn's going
to get passed on back in just a moment.
>> I got to tell you, I'm really enjoying
the word sque.
>> It's a good one.
>> Keep on your toes, you know.
>> Absolutely.
>> You have to You have to use a little bit
of brain power every time. It's not a
word. It's similar to other words, but
not quite the same. So, you got to make
sure the uh the gray matter is working.
Back we go. Two points to four. Feels
good for Victor again. Off to an early
lead. But well, more might now that
bottom battlefield. Nine total between
the mind spplitter and the sprite
spirit, excuse me. It's not actually a
sprite.
>> All right. What is up?
>> We know three of the four cards in hand
for our Victor player.
units are of reasonable size, but I
would say mine splitter is more of an
unreasonably sized unit.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think that's fair to say.
Is that a second
>> second dancer?
>> So, the shield's pretty nice on defense,
but that does not work on offense, which
is currently where Victor finds himself.
So, four might in.
Obviously, that's a smaller number than
nine.
>> Yeah,
>> we're going to dance on in and try and
take out the mind sweater. It looks like
that is seven. And there's another one.
Going to try and win the combat
outright. Bolang two thumbs up.
>> You got it. I'll take out this unit. You
keep your shakam dancer.
>> Oh, killed the two dancers actually
leaving the honest broker instead. I
guess that makes sense. That's the least
might available on that battlefield.
>> And our point goes to Squeach. Three
recruits also get made thanks to Victor
Leader's passive text.
five to two for a battlefield to
potentially claim here and uh push
yourself within two points of winning
which generally the increment you want
to be at in a game of riftbound but
committing victor leader not something
squitch wants to do in the face of Aelia
so instead we'll take the odd point
total and just pass it on back
>> it must feel good to have that many
recruits again less so now that the
decree has been taken out of hand
>> where that came from though as we know
as bowl then considers how do I get
myself back into this game.
>> I have to imagine the game plan is
somewhat similar to last time. Also
knows about the salvage too. So maybe
doesn't want to commit the last rights
when uh when he's aware that there could
be a salvage in the future. Oureli
though going to start things off by
rumbling on in for the arena's greatest.
Wins that combat pretty effortlessly and
now up to three points. Recruit given
over, gold given over. Plenty of uh
value on death
>> here for Victor.
>> Seeing what was draweria
switcheroo lost rights defy the five
there for Ban.
Seven runes from memory. Yeah, seven
there.
>> We could play Aelia.
>> Could play a
>> course for the Aelia. Could play a piece
of gear. maybe try and bait out that
salvage by playing those boots. Or if
you don't really care that much about
last rights, you can run it out and just
kind of let it get destroyed.
>> What happens
at this point last game boots came out
first. So maybe now knowing that there
is that salvage, it would be worth
baiting it out a little. But no,
>> just another Aurelia as Switch
>> looks to the judge and
>> just another
>> gives a little chuckle. So I think
perhaps maybe not fancying how many
Aurelas are hanging out.
>> They are different arts but they are the
same card. That much I can promise you.
That is Aurelia fervent both in base and
on battlefield. And Volenang happy to
slow down in this game. Not trying to
claim any extra points. Didn't really
have many options to I suppose.
But just holding on to the cards
continuing to develop believing that
Aurelia is the biggest unit in this game
which I think is a relatively accurate
statement.
>> Yeah, I think it's a fair statement to
say. Right.
Five recruits, one Victor leader.
>> Some more points to be grabbed. Gold's
going to get used.
>> Yep.
>> Salvage just to draw the card.
>> Banzang pretty happy to see that, I
think.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, another salvage.
>> Oh, well, I mean, Bolenang probably
feeling slightly more confident in using
the boots or the shovel, but now having
that, yeah, not so much. Point number
six as the recruit pines a way into the
abandoned hall.
Have to think if the first one was good
enough. Second one's not going to be
there just yet. Honest Baroa make a
recruit.
Pass it back. Leave up some runes and
say right now feel okay. I'm maybe try
and hold
>> for a point or two. Put the pressure on
for Bolan to have to make the first
move. Vex Gloom is still going to
trigger.
>> Draw a card thanks to a holding. Do you
have to exhaust your Vex to do it? Got a
a fine price to pay for an extra card.
>> Love a little card draw.
>> Oh, who doesn't?
>> Cannot complain.
>> Elo's breath looking
>> very underwhelming
>> in this particular board state. Would be
really good against Victor.
>> Yeah, unfortunately not this time
around.
>> Probably not the not what you want to
deploy. I would imagine you can do it. I
don't recommend you do it. actually did
see a player on stream already today.
Fellows breath their own unit to draw a
card off of watchful sentry. But Aurelia
Fer going to charge on in recruit hits
the dust and fourth point for Bolan Zang
who's just
>> hanging out with Aelas on both
battlefields. Must feel pretty good even
though you're behind in points.
>> Look very patient play. I feel like
there's a confidence especially coming
in from the last one there being able to
regain. I mean, look, in that position,
when you know your deck very very well,
it's not necessarily as scary. I feel
like it's one of those things where when
you have two Aelia out there, it's going
to be a little less daunting. Even
though there are a lot of recruits on
board.
>> Rex apathetic. Going to go downstairs
reinforcing the arena alongside the
first Aurelia
>> that got played in this game.
>> I think maybe just saying yeah at
abandoned hall is pretty powerful. Going
to hide two cards, one at each
battlefield.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh see what Squeach has on offer.
Not going to win this game if he holds
both these locations, but going to make
it closer. Certainly asking the question
of Victor. What do you have for me?
>> Yes.
>> And we know unfortunately
>> right now not a lot.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Decree off the top one time
deal.
>> Oh, can you imagine?
I
>> think Victor can put three in the deck
for a reason.
>> Awaken everything. Hidden blade. All
right. Oh, okay. It's something.
>> So, you've already seen Zas.
>> Yes.
>> And Zas is one of the funny ones.
Despite being hidden at a battlefield,
which generally means you have to play
the card at the battlefield. Well, Zas
doesn't care about that. Z can simply
just be played. It's a piece of gear
that will go to your base regardless of
what battlefield it
>> jump scares you from. And that will save
the Aurelia from the hidden blade if
that is one of the pieces of gear that
is hidden at either of these
battlefields.
Also, we know
>> Bonzang is a defying hand.
>> Yes.
>> Which is also quite good
>> against hidden blade. Maybe hidden blade
your own unit perhaps. Are we on that?
Are we we on that level at this point? I
think that would also get defied for
what it's worth. But is another line of
play available
>> potentially. Still got those boots, the
switcheroo, and the shovel in there as
well.
>> Fun fact, I suppose. that uh if uh
hidden blade does target well actually
in either the case if hidden blade gets
played and then defy uh you can still
pump the Aurelia at the abandoned hole
that is a spell you played
>> true play a spell you choose a unit you
have at this battlefield and make it one
bigger
>> and choosing Aurelia
>> and choosing Aurelia as we know Aelia
loves to be chosen doesn't she
>> look I mean sometimes you're allowed to
be a bit of a pick me it's fine it's
fine
>> it's fine
That's certainly been early as well
since she entered the game in Spirit
Forge. Couple runes
>> going to get rotated over.
>> Also have a redraw with the salvage as
well.
>> We want to try and find another card. I
think Bellow's Breath must be the play
here though. We'll be getting getting
some runes recycled. Indeed, it will be.
>> There we go.
>> I have to play deflect. Don't forget.
>> Oh, yes.
>> Looks like Aurelia. Aurelia Aurelia Vex
and Aurelia. Aurelia. Mhm.
>> is chosen, which I believe means bellows
was repeated.
>> Thankfully, I believe Bellows is Oh,
they all have deflect. I forgot about
that. Oh no.
>> Mhm.
>> Oh no. Goodbye runes.
>> Not ideal.
>> All right, Ben Hole.
Let's choose Aurelia because that fellow
got defied.
>> Did successfully
maybe bait out
>> a spell as uh recruits going to run into
this giant Aurelia.
>> Oh, bold recruit.
>> Fight in.
>> What do we have here? Time for hidden
blade. Hidden blade. My recruit.
>> Have to be a unit at a battlefield.
>> Mhm. This is why we're doing this. To
draw a couple cards.
Very important bit of sequencing, but uh
very clever to draw a couple cards.
Plundering pot off the top. One more.
>> And the tail watch
>> not currently. Oh, actually there is two
energy floating. So it is currently
castable.
>> And now both units have damage marked on
them already.
Except they think that got cleared
because combat happened.
So the classic bellow's bre Watcher
combo is not going to do the thing right
now.
>> So Vex is going to live.
>> Aelia is big enough already. She's going
to live regardless.
>> Oh yeah, she's fine. But
>> but now there's a bunch of one might
units at the battlefield.
>> Poland says, "Yep, I'll use this die. I
got nothing else to do. Hanging out.
Waiting to see if I get a couple points
here and trigger my Vex Gloom Mist."
>> Pilot's still hidden. Notably, still two
cards to contend with and just a salvage
left here that we know of in Squeach's
hand. Bolan obviously doesn't know
exactly
what Victor has up their sleeve. So, one
recruit in. This is kind of like build
your own Imperial decree, but it's going
to be good enough in this spot it feels
like. So, each unit is small enough as
Edge of Knight.
>> There we go.
>> Going to be the hidden card here.
>> It's going to give Aurelia a little bit
more now. only one smaller net after we
calculate the edge of knight.
So, we're going to take a little bit
more muscle
to kick these units off the battlefield,
but recruit can at least potentially
trade for Vex.
>> Suppose there's a dream of getting a
conquer point. Ooh, tie turner.
>> Try and save that Vex.
>> First time we're seeing that in the
matchup so far.
Recruit goes down. Damage dealt, but it
doesn't matter. Damage will get cleared
after combat. And now it's
>> four might I believe in the bottom
battlefield.
>> Went to one up plus two to three
actually. So minus two net.
>> Is that right?
>> So there's
three.
>> Yes, that
high turner also at two. So five might
on one side. Vex still shrunk by the
way.
>> Mhm. went to a different battlefield.
Didn't escape her potential fate
>> and Aurelia also received some pumps
earlier. So minus one in totality is
what that D is representing. So three
might for that Aurelia up in the top
battlefield. One might for the Vex still
despite Titoner saving her that time.
>> And it's good asking cards in hand.
>> On Zang representing three
>> taps the rune shows I have this many
runes available. Again very sporting
very clear about the game set to the
opponent. always love to see that.
>> It has been really really nice to see
the sportsmanship displayed at Sydney. I
wish I could like just bottle it because
there are so many just really really
lovely dialogues that have been had and
I feel like it just really represents
Sydney so well.
>> Now a couple points here. Rex also going
to draw another card.
>> Should be up to seven points I believe.
Started the turn at five. Hold for two
means seven.
>> Mhm. And now both players in touching
distance of a win this game, but Ve
seems to be a little bit more ahead, we
can say.
>> And
what do we have there? Oh, is that
Teemo?
>> It is Teemo.
>> Teemo.
>> Another pump of sorts you can hide at a
battlefield.
>> Mhm.
>> A unit that a lot of different chaos
decks started experimenting with.
>> Those boots.
>> Boots of swiftness. Once again, pretty
good for making Aurelia bigger on
offense.
>> Mhm.
>> I guess a little bit on defense as well
with the plus two. It gives the ganking
not going to feel all that relevant it
seems this game.
>> Not so much.
>> Rex apathetic can wear the shoes.
>> Stylin.
>> Just trying to think quite a lot of
units
>> on the other side there for Scooch. Have
a quick might count, I suppose, while we
wait cuz I think Bolan Zang's turn going
to be relatively straightforward. Just
try and reinforce as best you can and
then pass it on back.
>> Absolutely. This is what 10 up top.
>> Yeah. 10.
>> 6 + 4 is 10 base plus the hidden card
which we know is Teemo.
>> Mhm.
>> And then uh 6 + two down the bottom
side. Very similar calculation. Eight
might.
>> Very strong on both counts.
>> So seven for the watcher, two for the
breaker is nine. And then some number of
recruits. I think five. Four recruits.
Four recruits plus Victor it looks like.
>> Mhm.
>> I already lost track. 13 + 4 17 I'm
pretty sure is how much might Squeach
has access to. 1 2 3 4 5 6 13 17 indeed.
Did the math correctly on air. Sometimes
it works, sometimes it doesn't as uh it
was deadly flourish drawn by Squee for
this turn. So I think a redraw is
coming. And there's the salvage.
>> Actually going to get a little bit of
extra value here on the salvage.
>> Has two different gear to try and take
out. And Bol, wait a second, let me look
at these cards or either of these to
fire. I kind of want to hold on to my
might.
I think you will find that they are not.
You may kill a gear when it resolves. Is
picking a target. I actually don't know
if you have to pick until it resolves,
but perhaps you do as defy is there.
>> And Zang going to protect it. Abandoned
Hall going to target Aurelia. So plus
two.
>> Therefore, Aurelia fervent as well.
>> All of a sudden that M calculation
getting a little bit more out of
control.
I think no matter which gear it was,
Bolan would have just taken the plus
two. Pretty good conversion of your
energy into more might on a turn where,
you know, pretty much you just have to
hold to win here.
>> So, more math. Fingers starting to tap
the table here for Sque.
>> Numbers, numbers, numbers.
>> Cuz you have enough might to cover one
of these battlefields for sure.
>> But you do need to cover both.
>> Both. Yeah, look, I think it's fair to
say he's in a bit of a pickle at this
point,
>> especially with the hidden card still
there.
>> Less than five minutes left in the round
as well,
>> which does not bode well for Victor's
chances of winning this series.
>> This game already looking tricky.
>> And that's it. Squeeze the sides. Extend
the fist. You got me. Good game.
>> Impressive.
>> Poland Zang four and zero.
>> Wow.
>> Two different regional qualifier top
eights.
looking for a third here in Sydney.
>> Look, I mean, it's definitely a deck
that is worth consideration. I am very
impressed with how it has synergize and
just the very very calm approach to
play. Didn't look particularly bothered
at any point. Very, very, very patient.
And again, that sportsmanlike conduct
there by just having a little bit of a
giggle at the end there. Yeah, I feel
like the Teemo hat is kind of uh
underelling the potency of this player.
>> Absolutely. Although I do respect that
it's a little bit of a almost scop to be
like, I'm wearing a Teemo hat. What do
you think I'm going to play? There is
Teemo in the deck.
>> There is.
>> So, there we go.
>> And there is Aurelia as it turns out.
>> Yeah,
>> perhaps more Aurelia than Vex that game.
We did see more Aelas than Vexes.
>> Almost definitely. Yes. And look, I
mean, it still works. It still holds. It
holds very very well clearly. And uh
>> I mean that last one having two Aurelia
covering off both. What are you going to
do?
>> It's funny again with all those hidden
cards like not
>> I guess some of them are spells but not
all of them. So being able to still find
the right mix of like yep I'm going to
be able to pump my Aurelia with my
abandoned hall. I'm going to be able to
choose them in my different
battlefields. Like I don't even remember
what the third battlefield was but I
imagine it was another one where you can
choose Aurelia. I would imagine so which
clearly means that this Vex deck again
Vex deck I will remind you it is in the
same domains as Aurelia not an Aelia
deck but clearly having that card is a
very central piece of it strategy
>> look I mean the amount of Aurelia decks
that have Vex in it I feel like at this
point it's nice to see a little bit of a
swap going on but definitely more Vex
adjacent in some ways by having this
much of an Aurelia presence in it. I
like it.
>> Yeah, I like it too. I think I mean I
think uh clearly very successful here
for Bolan.
>> Absolutely. 4 and0 now in AQ Sydney
looking to maybe uh at least try and
play for the best of play for day two
perhaps even play in top eight
>> maybe might as well give it a crack
>> and Victor unfortunately again I think
Vick had all the tools actually coming
into this match up I was like surely
Victor with this many removal spells
he's going to be able to beat the deck
>> there were a lot of opportunities but
yeah just having the decree taken out
just before it's it's difficult and when
you don't get the draw you don't get the
draw
>> defy exists right as a card that stops
all of the spells that you're worried
about on the other side. Uh again,
Victor can kind of draw like the wrong
half of his deck sometimes where you
have a bunch of units and a bunch of
recruits, but you sometimes need spells,
but you sometimes need ways to make your
recruits better. And back to Apathetic
also shut down like a bunch of different
options that were also there.
>> And also just when you're dealing with
such a significant board presence and
there's such high might involved, it's
just not an easy one to come up against.
>> Yeah, Vex also a deck we see we've seen
a lot, not a lot of. We haven't seen
quite a lot of it yet, but a deck we
expect to see quite a lot of uh both
today and in day two cuz it is a pretty
popular deck.
>> Very very popular. I hope to see
certainly a lot more of it as a Vex
Enjoyer. This has been great for me. Uh
I'm really really happy to see just
different takes on it as well.
>> Very versatile.
>> As you can see, there's an interview on
the way. It's not quite ready yet.
>> Almost but not quite.
>> You didn't see anything. There's going
to be people in that studio in just a
moment. As long as we are going to hear
from Volan Zang, which I'm honestly very
excited about because
>> I have a lot of questions.
>> Me too.
>> For this deck, how did you land on three
Aurelia as your core?
>> Why do you have so many hidden cards?
>> Look, I I'm very curious to hear those
answers, but I also am very excited to
see the little Teemo hat again.
>> The Teemo hat's pretty great. Again, uh
we've seen a lot of different biomorphs.
I think Mousa been a card that's been
kind of a standout from Unleash in a
bunch of different strategies. It does.
It's funny because it looks very similar
to stalwart porro which is in some ways
better cuz it's it's two might base plus
one on shield instead of the two shield
but it turns out the tank is a pretty
relevant keyword to have especially in a
deck like vex
>> 100% and it clearly worked out for Bolan
Zang today so we'll see how it shapes up
in other Vex decks as well. I really
like it. It will be maybe a different
vibe in decks that don't feature Aurelia
quite so heavily but still really really
strong. and also a chaos tech that
didn't have rubik, didn't have slust.
There's like a bunch of things that we
expect from the this domain that we
really didn't see any of and it didn't
seem to matter. I think perhaps a domain
that is just quite deep as far as the
options you have when you do pick it as
one of your domains rolling into any
game or ribbound.
>> Absolutely. And I think the only other
thing that's worth note as well is
obviously people have had a week to deal
with unleashed. A lot of these cards not
necessarily unleashed.
>> Well, we have a lot of questions so
hopefully we have some answers. We're
going to go down with a interview with
our winner.
>> Thank you so much, Pastry. We are here
now with Bolan Jen who just won on the
VEX. And just a little bit of background
information about Bolang. Bolan. I don't
know if I'm saying your name. How do you
say your name?
>> Bolan.
>> Bolan. Yeah.
>> Um he actually is from China. Came and
flew over for this event here in Sydney.
And this is your first time playing Vex.
>> Yes,
>> exactly. First time.
>> Yeah. you um went you came first in
Nangjing on February 8th with Annie and
you've now switched over to Vegas. How
are you finding the switch?
>> Because uh the meta changed too fast. At
first I probably think Ann is the best
choice in this in this in Alish because
uh there are so many ambush cards. It's
so
uh it's perform so well with Annis and
is legendary and uh and also Annie could
play Gas is really good versus Lily and
uh Lebron. But at first the meta is
Lilian LeBron.
>> Yeah.
>> Um but uh however some uh somebody uh
built
a master e deck and um and is really bad
versus master E and and even the even
bad news is uh more Aelia come come out
to try to counter Master E.
>> Yeah.
>> So and Aelia even have more u more more
deflect guys. So I try Annie try Diana.
Oh, it's too bad versus versus deflect
decks. So, um my uh my uh so I think I
first I need to play Wax. I I must play
a purple deck with Wax to on turn two so
that the Master East Ringard will won't
be too frightened. So, so you know Wax
could always play uh Wax
Legend could always play Wax uh champion
in turn two.
>> Yes, agree. So this the first import and
the second one is the the green green
deck they usually only target themselves
other than target your opponents.
>> So I I believe maybe wax is is the best
ma best deck versus the like master and
arelia meta. Yeah.
>> I noticed you're wearing a Teemo hat. I
also noticed you had a Teemo in your
deck list. Uh what is the reasoning
behind Teemo in the uh the deck? Uh,
Teemo is good, but it's the the last
choice for me for the two drops. You
know, Vex need to play many hidden cards
to scared my opponent. And so, at first,
the the other nine um two drops is
probably must play. And
>> and Vex is a deck that must play two
drops. Yeah, Vex could never if if if
Vex play nothing in in sec in turn one,
probably do. So, so I need another two
drops and need to be a better to be a
hidden card. So, Timor is a really good
hidden card because it has four might.
>> Yeah, indeed. He can be quite strong way
of being played from hidden. Thank you
so much for your insight. It's very nice
to hear from our Chinese community
coming over to play in this event. Good
luck with the rest of the games. We'll
head back to the casters.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you so much. Lovely to hear from
Bol and Zang there about some of the
choices made in that VEX deck. Uh I feel
like for me it boiled down to one thing.
Uh, I was scared of all the ambush
units, which again, very big thing in
unleash, so I just played the best card
against him, which is Vex Apathetic. And
there's nothing like having Vex in your
chosen champion zone if you want access
to that card.
>> Going to do it every single time.
>> Makes sense why I've seen a lot of it as
well. But we do have one more game to
show you all at least on stream. Uh,
time in the round has been called, but
our players did of course get a time
extension. Pretty common occurrence in
the feature match area. And they have a
third game to play. I have no idea how
much time they have, but let's pop in
and see just how they're doing.
>> Let's find out.
All righty. What have
>> we got here?
>> I see a grove of the god Willow.
>> Don't ask me how I know that.
>> That was in such a glimpse.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> It's the top battlefield.
>> Yeah. I mean,
>> oh, it's a monastery of Hana. No.
>> Interesting. The confidence that you
had.
>> I really thought it was uh it was the
purple. I don't even know what the unit.
Anyway, we'll move on. It's Kha'Zix
versus Fury, which I think should be
maybe a bit more exciting. M
>> it is a forid for forbidding waste which
again uh something we've seen a lot of
already today versus monastery of harana
which is an interesting one. This is uh
when you conquer here spend a buff to
draw one. And this is something we see a
lot on set,
>> not so much on Kha'Zix and certainly not
a match up we expect to see a lot of.
But it is 4 minutes left in this game
three. Unsung hero the first play here.
So players are going to be playing real
quickly.
>> Absolutely motoring through to be able
to get the best value out of that 4
minutes.
>> Irresistible Fay folk. Pretty good card
if you can make it a little bit bigger.
>> Mhm.
>> Have a quick squeeze at Kha'Zix as well.
Definitely a new legend here in Unleash.
Let's give that one a little bit of a
read, shall we?
>> So, Kha'Zix is when you win a combat,
gain one XP. Uh, you can spend one and
exhaust to buff a unit or spend two and
exhaust to move an exhausted friendly
unit from a battlefield to its base.
>> Makes sense why monastery is something
we want here cuz Kha'Zix has free access
to buffs as Unsung hero going to move
into the monastery, take it over, and
score the first point of the game. And
again, not a lot of time left in this
one. So points you can get are very
valuable.
>> Absolutely.
>> We have seconds on the clock. Couple
runes going to be exhausted.
>> First mate, not to be confused with old
mate. Going to pop that on sing back to
base.
>> All righty. What do we have in hand over
here?
>> So fa folk. Fun one. We can give a read
as well. When I go to places, charm
somebody over. It's irresistible as it
were.
>> Irresistible.
All right, combat has begun and
currently the fay folk is losing, but I
can't imagine that's going to last too
much longer. When I move to a
battlefield, you may move an enemy unit
to that battlefield. So, unsung hero has
been dragged on over and forbidding
waste is triggering and that unsung hero
is the defender.
>> Yep, there you go.
>> Which means you actually just straight
up lose the combat to a one might fade.
That's gross.
>> That's rough. That's real rough. Uh
really really well strategized by
Phoenix there to see that.
>> I know that is a one combat by the way.
So that should be an XP.
>> Mhm.
>> Yep. Phoenix notices it just right away.
And you saw you saw Jiggly, our fur
player in the player camp saying, "Oh,
all right. Clearly learning that
interaction maybe for the first time
today. Certainly I did as insightful
investigator going to be played. This is
a card we do not see very often,
>> but it's uh you know a version of some
of the the hand disruption cards we've
seen in Riftbound so far.
When you play me, choose an opponent. I
choose you. They reveal their hand. You
may pay two XP to choose a card from the
hand. If you do, they discard that and
draw one. With only one XP to spend,
unfortunately, there's nothing to be
chosen, but you still get the
information.
>> Mhm.
>> One point a piece. As we pass on back,
it's time for Jiggly Fiora.
>> With only a minute left, you want to
have that info so you can try and figure
out a way to just really, really be
decisive and get a point on the board
here. Yeah, looks like card already
drawn here for Jiggly off for their
turn. Phoenix quickly writing those
cards down. But again, time is of the
essence, lads. So, let's channel some
runes.
>> Mhm.
>> Freddy style first mate and see what
happens. Jiggly very again very
sportsman like just leaving the rest of
the hand that's known up and available.
>> Taking out a bit of the guesswork.
Fortunately, not easy to figure out what
to do here. First M going to charge on
in. Irresistible. Folk going to be
threatened. Mhm.
And
>> of course, Kha'Zix can move units back
to base, but you have to do that on your
turn at regular speed with enough XP.
So, not happening this time. Folk does
bite the dust.
>> And forbidding waste is forbidding once
more.
>> Here's set brawler.
Very powerful card. Gets a buff is made
mighty thanks to Fiora. Going to go
ahead and channel a rune as a result
after the legend gets exhausted. And you
can spend the buff to give set plus for
this turn. And when you conquer, you get
to buff him again. So going to be able
to make use of the monastery of piranha
that is on Fiora's side. It's funny
actually. I thought it was Kha'Zix's
battlefield, but it is not.
>> Nope.
>> Something Kha'Zix can use though,
interestingly enough. It's not something
you that normally happens when you're a
buff deck. Not a lot of splash damage
from Monastery.
>> We have run down the timer.
>> So we may well be in turns at this
point.
>> Yep.
>> Buff going to be expended there thanks
to Kha'Zix's legend ability. That means
the four might investigator is going to
beat the one might first mate cuz again
the forbidding waste debuff going to
shrink that unit even though it was
losing the combat on that Charale.
And now Phoenix just deciding what to do
next. Two points to two. Very close
>> in this final game. Again time is done.
Time in the round has been called
already. Void assault.
>> There we go.
>> Going to be the choice here. Going to
move a couple units over. introduce set
to the insightful investigator
and there's got to be a little bit more
after that I have to imagine because
there it is groom resolve going to try
and win this combat void assault reads
move a friendly unit then move an enemy
unit so they've both moved and now
they're chilling at the monastery where
grim resolve is pumping up this
insightful investigator so currently
winning the combat trying to take out
this set and unlike set regular set
legend I should say no way to save this
set with its own buff it just goes away
in Fiora
Okay,
>> three points to two and uh again players
are
got to be close to time at this point.
Not sure who had the first turn in
overtime. You do get three total between
the players with the first one being
turn zero. A little bit confusing, but
you can think of it as two turns a
piece.
>> Did I spot another Vex in hand there?
>> Everyone loves Vex.
>> Everyone's loving Vex.
>> It is Vexpathetic.
>> There you go. Absolutely. Look, the more
the marrier.
>> I will say given that you do have to win
by two if memory serves
>> when we are in the uh in an overtime
portion of a game, uh ride the win feels
like a pretty good card to have.
>> Very much so.
>> Given that you want to score points and
scoring on your opponent's turn uh could
be the difference maker here in this
game as
players maybe just now
being told what the situation is.
talking to the dodge.
Everyone deciding, everyone just trying
to make sense where we're up to. Couple
fingers exchanging back and forth.
>> Is it turn?
>> So if I believe
that Phoenix had turn zero and Jiggly
had turn one. They should each get a
turn after this. But it kind of depends
where we were
>> and time in the round was called or at
least when their time in the round
called cuz they did get a time
extension.
>> True.
Four cards in hand.
>> All right, here's the
>> coming on out.
>> Still behind in points as we've noted.
So set going to come back.
Going to recycle a rune going to be made
mighty. Going to trigger Fiora. Going to
recycle that rune right on back
>> as it were up. So power neutral in
essence as Fiora gives you a little bit
of ramp when you make mighty units.
Not a lot of points being scored in that
exchange.
The set did get readied by Fiora worthy.
>> Yes.
>> When a new control becomes mighty, you
may pay an order to ready it. That's
going to mean second ride on in as the
wind gets rode the other way instead.
>> Mhm.
>> It's going to be a fourth point and then
a fifth point
>> after you awaken for holding. So,
Monastery is up and available.
Unfortunately, Set no longer gets to do
the thing.
>> Conquering and then drawing the card.
You have to fulfill the condition at the
time of conquer.
>> So, you're going to get the buff, but
not going to be able to get the card
that comes with it if you wanted it. Not
an option you even get to have here.
So, going to be five points to three
at the end of this.
And this is the last turn, is it?
>> I think this is the second last turn,
but I don't know which player
>> started. I believe Phoenix started,
but I could be wrong.
>> You never.
>> Oh, all the time. All the time.
>> Not once. Surely not. Well, I can tell
you that Phoenix has four units in hand
and uh that doesn't feel all that
useful.
>> Not so much at
>> this particular juncture. Now, we could
be popping the old Kha'Zix
to move a unit back.
>> He's got four XP there.
>> Unfortunately, the uh unit has to be
exhausted when you move it. So, uh can
be good for some things, not so good if
you're trying to move a ready unit to a
different battlefield.
So, that's not going to help us here.
Treasure Hunter, Vex, Apathetic,
Irresistible Fate Book, and Set Brawler.
>> The four cards in Phoenix's hand.
>> Nothing that I would necessarily see as
particularly beneficial right now. Not
right this moment, unfortunately.
It's always really interesting coming in
at this late stage to see how well
things are going for the players,
especially because obviously these are
both decks that have quite a lot of
whether it's buffing, whether it's XP,
it's just a lot of maths first of all.
Uh, and yeah, just seeing it at this
point, right at the tail end coming in
at this point is very, very interesting.
>> Yeah, the body decks tend to do a lot of
math. That's kind of their whole thing.
Yeah,
>> it looks like Phoenix is uh considering
reinforcing with Vex Apathetic, which
would have been really good on the
previous turn. Could have stopped that
set from being readied by this Fiora.
>> Not literally, but in effect
>> cuz the stone set is not that useful.
>> Coming in with Vex.
>> All righty. So he's trying to hold down
the fort,
>> buff up the Vex,
>> giving it that extra one,
>> and maybe just go again. Little Foke
action.
>> Look, at this point, you kind of really
just have to throw it all in there.
>> Maybe leave up one rune. Just bluff
punch first.
>> True.
>> Got to make him uh got to make him
scared.
>> And there's the faith.
>> Folk coming in.
>> Does leave up one. That one does cost
the same amount of energy as the other.
So, why not leave the treasure hunter at
home? Pay folk may be a little more
useful from time to time being able to
charm a unit somewhere else. There's
four points now for the Fiora.
And I believe if I was keeping track of
turns correctly, if the round timer
was correct, I believe Phoenix would
have had the first turn in extra time.
So, I think at this point, players got
win by two. So, the hands are going to
be exchanged. And I believe I believe
>> we have a draw.
>> Yeah, it looks like
>> you go.
>> It happens.
>> Coming in right at the end. Seeing how
that goes. Look,
it's an interesting matchup if nothing
else.
>> All right, it was a draw. Thank you.
Production did confirm that for me.
>> So, as expected, uh you have to win by
two in extra turns and uh players could
not make enough room. So, fun little bit
of interaction there between these two
decks. Not decks I necessarily expected
to see on stream today. Perhaps we'll
see them again. Would be nice to maybe
get a
uh more of a game instead of a fragment
of a game.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'd like to see a little bit
more Kasix. I want to see the XP in
action. I want to see a little bit more
growth to it. So, it would be nice.
>> You see some sweet stuff though. Again,
both players playing set. Pretty good
unit. uh you kind of see some of the
things especially with that faith for
forbidding waste interaction is like
>> something I will take with me for the
rest of the weekend cuz that might be
something that players are leaning on if
that's a popular battlefield which it
does seem like it is.
>> It seems like it. We've seen a fair bit
of it today. I mean look it really is a
little bit more unexpected but it
clearly is working.
>> All right. Well, four rounds in the
books. There's a few more to go with
four left for just today. Don't go too
far away. After this break we're going
to have even more Riftbound.
Welcome to Riftbound Basics featuring
actions and reactions. There are three
different types of spells in Riftbounds.
Normal spells which you can use to start
a chain during your own turn from a
neutral game state. Actions which can be
used in exactly the same way but can
also be used in combat to start a chain.
and